Good morning, Mr. President and board members.
Good to be able to report another active couple of months, and I'm gonna highlight three visits I had to schools.
Those are the most inspiring parts of our work, I think, is to go see students on the front line, excited, thrilled to learn, thrilled to be there, and teachers teaching their hearts out.
The first of the schools I visited was Jenny Oropeza Elementary School by invitation of board member Ortiz Lacan.
Her husband, Roberto Lacan, teaches fifth grade there.
And it was fascinating, they have incredibly strong parent involvement and partnership with the YMCA.
The head of that organization and partnership actually recognized our board member as being a former counselor for the program.
And he said she came a long way, which is great.
So they have a youth leadership institute, and again, strong partnerships with the community and parent groups.
The second to highlight, I had a chance to go to Pittsburgh.
Visited three Head Start programs, and of course seeing the little ones just eager, exploring the world, full of energy.
Then I visited Los Madonos Elementary School, where they had a special assembly, and a large number of parents, I would say over 100 parents and grandparents and nieces and nephews came for a celebration on the overall performance of all students on the Smarter Balance.
and then they had medals to hand out, and I got to place medals around the necks of about 200 students for meeting or exceeding the standards.
So it was a celebration of accomplishment and looking at all groups, including those that were moving up, who were below the meeting standards expectation.
The third visit I took was to Elk Grove.
Among many, I wanted to highlight these three.
At Dreen Elementary School in Elk Grove, I'd heard about their super high attendance.
They set a record high attendance of 98%, and that's the top for all 65 schools in the Elk Grove Unified School District.
And we had an assembly there as well, and they chant regularly, every day, all day, on time.
And then they fly flags.
Every classroom has a flag.
If they've had a perfect attendance the day before, they fly a flag and celebrate attendance.
So we know that that makes a huge difference.
You've got to be there to enjoy the great skills of the teachers and the wonderful facilities.
And so parents there really put a high priority in getting their kids to school on time every day.
It's part of an ongoing effort.
We're going to actually expand our efforts to increase attendance.
We have $27 million in grants to school districts for programs to reduce high rates of chronic absenteeism
out-of-school suspension, dropouts, and crime.
The department is already putting the guidelines together for this $27 million in grants to tackle attendance challenges.
I want to thank Assemblymember Patrick O'Donnell from Long Beach who authored AB 2815, which promotes effective attendance practices.
Nine million of the grant fund will come from Prop 47, a voter approved initiative that reduced prison time for some nonviolent crimes and allocate savings to school programs.
And the governor approved an additional 18 million in the state budget.
Districts can hire more social workers, counselors, nurses to identify and expand efforts to increase attendance as those defined as at risk for not being there on a regular basis.
I also wanted to share a grant program.
It's called New Skills for Youth Grant.
I'm excited that we have received a $100,000 planning grant and that a team from CDE just went back to Washington to promote getting a phase two grant.
It's an effort partnership between the Council of Chief State School Officers and Advance CTE, a national nonprofit that represents career technical education and JPMorgan Chase.
So it tracks very well with the work we've done in California, this building on the work of our career incentive grants and career pathways.
I wanted to just recognize Joe Ratting and Donna Wyatt if they're here for their work heading up the California team that made the presentation.
This time I'll turn it over to Glenn just to give a brief comment on the Collaboration in Common grant, another grant that we're lucky to have within reach.
Thank you, Superintendent Torlakson.
Is this mic on?
Great.
So we've had the opportunity a couple times to reference this effort, Collaboration in Common, which has been a public-private partnership that the California Department of Education is undertaking in conjunction with the CDE Foundation.
And we also had the opportunity back in October, well October already seems like a long time ago, and we are November 2nd, to review briefly the use of collaboration in common with the California Practitioners Advisory Group in relationship to the expanded statements of model practice work that we're putting together and the curation of resources for that.
But wanted to announce that as of today, educators around the state who have signed up as early adopters of Collaboration in Common are starting to use the platform, starting to kick the tires and make it real.
And then additionally, in some very exciting news, we wanted to announce today that the
Chan Zuckerberg Initiative is making a $2.25 million grant to the CDE Foundation to expand the resource, particularly in relationship to promoting collaboration amongst education communities in the state of California, and will really help us expand the platform and get out the word around collaboration in common.
So I wanted to share that exciting news and also issue a call to action.
If there's anyone else who would like to sign up as an early adopter,
of Collaboration in Common, please go to collaborationincommon.org, just like it sounds, and sign up, and we'll be happy to see you there.
So back to you, Superintendent Tarleson.
Again, thought that would be good news to share and just fresh news, as it were, and again, great work on the staff team that helped put this together and worked and interacted with your team here, President Kerst.
And I'll just wrap with saying that I'm looking for some magic numbers to get green lights and bring in some green.
That's 51, 55, 56, and 58, which are ballot measures which I strongly support and believe that given the debate on them, we will hopefully see green lights on those measures and more financial stability and enhancement of our programs in our schools.
So with that, Mr. President, thank you.
So.
Spanish interpreter services will be available for items 3, 4, and 5 on Wednesday, and on Thursday, items 18, 19, and 20.
There are four public hearings, item 9, science framework, and the three charter petitions, items 18, 19, and 20.
There are three addenda to the agenda, which was published in advance.
The recommendations of the three finalists, the student report and recommendations from the Student Advisory Board on Education, and item eight, the Screening Committee's recommendations for appointments to our advisory commissions.
The consent calendars is there.
It's items 11 through 17 will be on consent, and there's a handout on the table in the lobby listing these.
The proposed regular consent items, as I indicated, are 11 through 17.
The waiver consent items are W1 through W8.
As I indicated, W9 was withdrawn by Tehachapi's Unified School District.
If you want to take up board members, any waiver consent items and regular consent items and put those on their agenda, please advise Karen staff Walters by the end of today, Wednesday.
today, we will be using one minute per speaker for all items and tomorrow, but they can bundle where you can have five members and, uh, five speakers and then take three minutes.
Uh, we, uh, provide at least 25 copies of anything.
So if you want to submit any materials to the board, bring 25 copies.
speakers, please.
Whenever you speak, introduce yourself and the organization that you represent.
Gravity and speaking will be appreciated and additional seating is there for the TV monitors.
So with those in tow and announcements done, we're now ready for agenda item one and the state Board of Education student member recommendations for the finalists who will be handling this member Burr will be handling this.
Good morning.
It's a pleasure to be with you here this morning.
This is the most exciting time of the year for us.
Now, how about that?
Better, okay.
Red means that it's on.
I thought it was green.
Again, nice to be here this morning.
This is the most gratifying time of the year for the screening committee, when we get to engage in the selection and our recommendations for our student board member.
I'll just say that it's always so thrilling to have a chance to talk to these young people, to see their enthusiasm and their commitment and their passionate
Wanting to be on the State Board of Education, I can just say that we're all in great hands and you'll see that when you get to experience the student members that we've had in the past and certainly the one we have now with Olivia Sisson.
Just a little refresher of how this process works before we acknowledge all of the students who participated in it.
The screening committee, which consists of member Holliday and member Ortiz-Lincoln and myself, get the entire package of applications.
We narrow it down to 12 semi-finalists.
Then those 12 are interviewed by the student council organization.
And they narrow it down to six people who then the screening committee interviews, and our job is to identify three candidates to move forward to the governor, and the governor actually makes the appointment.
So what I'd like to do today is acknowledge all of the semifinalists, and we will close with the three finalists that we're recommending.
So the first semifinalist, I want to make sure that I acknowledge their schools as well.
And if you would come up, we have a certificate for you, which I'd be happy to present to you, is Ryan Chen from La Canata High School in Los Angeles County.
The next semifinalist that's shown on your addendum is not able to join us today, and that's Deborah Assayas-Gatta.
She's from Robert F. Kennedy Community Schools in Los Angeles.
So our next semifinalist who is here is Ren Li from Stockdale High School in Kern County.
Our next semifinalist is Julissa Lopez Vega from Owens Gilroy Early College Academy in Santa Clara County.
Next is Thuy Van Nguyen from Monterey Trail High School in Elk Grove in Sacramento County.
And the last semifinalist is Chloe Perath.
Chloe is from the Abel Charter, Humphreys College Academy of Business Law and Education, New Jerusalem Elementary School District, San Joaquin County.
This next group of individuals are the candidates who were forwarded, and we had the pleasure to interview them.
I should just say these are always really hard decisions.
These are very able students, very, very capable, and we're just thrilled to have them.
So first, I'd like to acknowledge Ardith Chavez from Western Sierra Collegiate Academy in Rockland, Placer County.
Next is Lydia Chun.
Lydia goes to John Marshall High School in Los Angeles Unified School District, Los Angeles County.
And the next one is John John Huddleston.
John John goes to North Hollywood Highly Gifted Magnet in Los Angeles County.
Okay, and these are the three finalists who we will be, once we acknowledge them, we'll be making a motion to forward their applicants to the governor for consideration.
And first we have Jayden Gray.
Jayden is a student at James Logan High School, New Haven Unified School District, Alameda County.
Next is Madison Laster.
Madison goes to Redondo Union High School in Redondo Beach, Los Angeles County.
And our last finalist is Steven Pineda who goes to University Senior High School in Los Angeles.
And with that, I would like to move that we forward the three finalists who are listed on your addendum to Governor Brown for his consideration for appointment for the student member of the State Board of Education.
Second.
Okay, it's been moved and seconded.
Is there any board discussion?
Seeing none, any public comment on this item?
No.
All right, all those in favor, raise your hands.
The motion carries.
Congratulations to the three finalists.
Okay, we're now ready for item two and Bruce Holliday will lead off on this item.
Over the past few years in this room we've spoken a lot about LCFF and rubrics and LCAPS and accountability systems and yet every discussion we've always continually stressed the importance of student voice in all decision making.
We've also created pathways for student voice to be heard at the local level as well as at state level.
And I can assure you that when you hear these student presentations this morning, as I had the privilege to preview them last night, that you will be inspired and reminded that when students join the conversation, everyone benefits.
These are passionate and committed young people who embody the spirit and the excellence of education in California.
Okay, go ahead.
Good morning.
Good morning and thank you Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst, Vice President Strauss and esteemed board members for having us back once again.
My name is Sam Goidel and I am a senior at Davis Senior High School in Davis Joint Unified School District.
In addition, I am the Education Policy Director for the California Association of Student Councils, commonly referred to as CASC.
For over 40 years, students from all across California have come to evaluate the state of their public schools at the CASC-hosted Student Advisory Board on Education, or SABE.
This year, after three days of continued hard work and long nights, I can tell you with confidence that we have created implementable and feasible proposals.
On the first day, these 50 delegates gathered into one room, and we brainstormed possible topics.
From there began the arduous process of compressing all our different wants, needs, and experiences into succinct proposals.
Much like a construction crew raising a house,
The topic groups had to work long hours, first laying a curriculum foundation, and then building the walls of their proposal, debating the root problems, assumptions, and evidence associated with the topic.
Finally, these delegates perfected the word choice and feasibility, painting their new house.
Today, with the proposals completed, we have come to sell you these houses.
Additionally, delegates learned to spot the difference between state and local policy ideas, keeping in mind the state's direction towards local control.
With this in mind, we specifically set aside time to evaluate possible local solution ideas to each of our topics, and we have attempted to eliminate all locally geared propositions from our presentations.
With that being said, we have also attempted to do the same thing with legislative proposals, spending a great deal of time focusing on the role and limitations of this body.
I and many others here today joined this organization not because we wanted to pad our resumes or just to make a lot of noise, but because we joined this organization because we want to improve the schools that we have grown up in, and I believe today we will do just that.
These six proposals will cover current hot-button issues for the educational world and this body.
In order, today, we will present proposals to combat the issues associated with and we will present solutions for current technology in schools, mental health, the under-representation of English language learners, the new accountability standards, school discipline, and student-to-teacher feedback.
First, I would like to welcome up the Kask State Council President, Nandini Patel.
Okay.
Good morning, Superintendent Torlakson, President Kurse, and Vice President Strauss.
My name is Nandini Patel, and I'm a senior at Vista Mureta High School in Mureta, California, as well as the California Association of Student Councils State President.
On behalf of CASC, we would like to thank the California Department of Education for establishing the Standards Support Office and its Contingent Standards Steering Committee.
We would also like to extend our commendation to the State Board of Education for their continued support for the Student Advisory Board of Education for the past 53 years.
We would also like to thank student board member Olivia Sisson for her continued support and going above and beyond any of our expectations for the past four days.
Thank you.
All right, okay.
So, well, thank you all for making this possible, just off the bat.
And good morning, President Kirst, Vice President Strauss, and Superintendent Torlakson.
So, my name is Kai Bergman, and I go to Berkeley High School.
So, today I will be proposing how to address the problems in implementation of technology in our school system, as well as the lack of student voice inside of this process.
Our proposal will recommend the creation of a committee of stakeholders featuring parents, teachers, and at least one student, as well as tech industry experts, as decided by you all, to serve as a source of guidelines, standards, and efficient practices for the implementation of technology.
But to start, I want to lay out that technology can clearly be used in a positive way.
Technology gives our students the power to communicate with those around the world, to share their ideas for feedback, but most importantly, it just completely reinvents the infrastructure in our schools.
It establishes more student-to-teacher connections, student-to-student connections, and everything is better.
To start again, the California Association of Student Councils stands with technology.
There is, however, room for improvement.
First, there is often a lack of functional and working computers in many schools.
Due to lack of clear, standardized recommendations on damaged or expired technology, schools around the state, such as my own, have computers with broken parts and outdated technology.
The same is very true with internet connection, and many schools lack working and fast internet.
The typical school has the same bandwidth as a four- to five-person home, over the population of an average of 600.
Additionally, the SBAC, while being extremely progressive in the realm of technology, is still relatively new to those administering it, resulting in implementation issues in some schools.
Lastly, there have been some troubles with regards to initiatives such as the attempt at a one-to-one iPad to student plan in the Los Angeles Unified School District.
Yet, in the exact same state, many districts find success in these plans, and they should help serve as guidelines for the future.
School districts like Redondo Beach Unified have had a variety of methods in order to ensure successful technology implementation.
This includes an effective one-to-one textbook checkout-esque Chromebook system, which has had incredible success.
School districts like Redondo Beach Unified and others should help serve as a model in order to replicate these strategies.
As all of you are aware, there is no easy fix for any of these serious and impactful problems.
However, today we present a solution to help mitigate a lot of these negative impacts that we see.
Again, we, the Student Advisory Board on Education,
for the recommendation of the creation of a committee of stakeholders and tech industry experts, which includes necessary student involvement, as decided, again, by you, to serve as a source of recommended guidelines, standards, and the best practices for the implementation of technology.
The Education Technology Task Force, which was disbanded in 2012, laid out the blueprints for technology implementation.
But like I just mentioned, work still needs to be done.
As a result of creating a committee on the implementation of technology, the State Board may incur the cost of recruitment and transportation of committee members to and from meetings.
To help meet with costs, things like meetings can be done over the internet through applications such as Skype.
The committee would be continuously active unless the state board, you all, see a reason to dissolve it.
First, recognize that all the issues that I just described previously have the underlying theme of a need for better direction and implementation.
This committee has the potential to address a lot of the issues that cause things, such as the digital divide, and will help strengthen the administration of the SBAC.
The administration of the SBAC, when improved, will provide an even better representation of students' understanding of Common Core.
This is extremely beneficial.
This committee could also address and help school districts to make informed decisions about technology, to make educated recommendations on the best practices and techniques.
This group could additionally recommend school districts to appropriately spend LCAP funding for technology.
The impacts of this issue, again, are of the greatest magnitude.
Again, there are many schools to look to as models, and by looking at the best practices as guidelines, this committee can provide clear and correct information in a standardized and formal way to the school districts.
One last potential area of focus for this committee is turning away from the status quo by increasing engagement of schools and students, teachers and parents.
This committee, again, solves for this as there will be higher levels of involvement from all the parties stated.
With the promotion of student involvement, implementation plans can be improved and bettered.
The support of adding a student to this committee is critical as it will allow for a higher level of insight on the problems.
Students are the one being directly affected by the policies and the technology in schools and they deserve a say in this process.
The effect of the committee and its student involvement can greatly improve the methods and for which money is spent in schools to ensure the maximum utility and benefit from it.
Thank you very much and I'm very proud to propose.
I now open the floor to prep questions.
Board member questions.
Go ahead.
Just make a comment.
Excellent recommendation.
We've been seeing a need to update that technology plan that was formed from the task force work and started some meetings and want to make an invitation right here.
Can you join us?
Would you be one who wanted to?
be one of the voices on the working group.
Yeah, I would love to.
Excellent, excellent.
We're signing you up.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And if there's another colleague of yours that worked on this that you wish to be involved, let us know.
I have a comment.
The statistic that the average bandwidth is the same as a family in a school
I think we've made a lot of progress from that.
I know that was two or three years ago, but we have poured hundreds of millions of dollars into technology, a lot of it to administer the Smarter Balanced test.
So to administer that test, you have to have much more broad-based bandwidth.
It's probably, I don't know what the situation is now, but I think the task force ought to take a look at that.
How much have we closed that gap?
So that's something I'd put on your agenda.
We really worked hard on that in the past few years.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, Super, oh, what's this?
How do I press the button?
Okay.
So it was on before.
The red light should be on.
Okay, this is working?
Okay, all right.
Good morning, Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst, and esteemed board members.
My name is Shamaela Pregada, and I am a senior attending Torrey Pines High School in the San Diego Unified High School District, which is located in San Diego, California.
The mission statement of the Department of Education is to create strong, effective schools that cause a high standard of student accomplishment.
However, the lack of knowledge among students about resources designed to support those suffering from mental illnesses are hindering students' ability to reach this high standard of student accomplishment.
They're simply not receiving the support that they need to be successful in school.
Given these circumstances, the Student Advisory Board on Education suggests that this can be addressed by establishing a framework for mental health which would supplement the pre-existing mental health standards created by the California Department of Education.
Comprehensive and extensive standards such as recognizing common mental health conditions and methods of seeking mental health assistance are in place.
However, these standards are not as effective as originally intended.
When speaking to students throughout the state of California from diverse schools as Hamilton, South Pasadena, Torrey Pines, Henry M. Gunn, and Vista Murrieta High School, there was a common underlying theme.
The majority of students are not able to identify that they have a mental illness or how to maintain positive mental health due to their lack of education on the topic.
From a recent case in San Gabriel High School in Alhambra Unified School District, we find the knowledge of these standards help prevent suicide.
Over the span of four months, at the beginning of the 2016 to 2017 school year, at least three students from San Gabriel High reported suicide thoughts or contemplated suicide.
These students were able to seek help from peer counselors and ultimately were referred to professional treatment.
San Gabriel High has a two-year counseling course that trains students to become peer counselors, and because of this program, students are more comfortable reporting mental health concerns, thereby addressing the issues at hand and decreasing the risk of suicide.
The peer counseling program is just one example of a school developing a framework for mental health and the framework's effectiveness in promoting student wellness.
While these standards may seem like they thoroughly address a variety of topics relating to mental health, we still see suicide being the third leading cause of death in our youth.
In fact, one in five children have or will suffer from a mental illness some point in their lives.
Of all the disability groups in California, those with mental illnesses make up the largest high school dropout rate.
Mental health impacts students' capacities to compute knowledge, thereby lowering academic performance.
Meanwhile, in New York, the state ranked 50th in age-adjusted rate of suicide.
A separate mental health framework is in place for pre-K to 12 public schools.
The agenda of this framework includes delivery models that focus on mental health and education, as well as suggested frameworks to promote positive school climates.
Massachusetts, for example, as well, has a mental health framework that introduces how to identify common mental health conditions.
In comparison, mental health is being devalued throughout the state of California.
The root problem here is that students of all ages are not adequately educated on mental health, their symptoms, and are ultimately not taught how to combat certain mental health issues.
Without sufficient mental health education,
Students feel discouraged to ask for the support fundamental to the individual growth and academic success.
Many California frameworks are being evaluated, including the health framework that has not been changed since its creation in 2003.
This is the opportune time to make our existing health framework more comprehensive with the mental health section.
In fact, one of the 2016 goals of the Health Subject Matter Committee on the Instructional Quality Commission is to provide guidance and support for the development of the 2019 health education framework.
Therefore, we, the Student Advisory Board on Education, recommend that you urge the Instructional Quality Commission create a framework for mental health for the existing mental health standards for California public schools.
Both Massachusetts and New York have mental health frameworks in place to guide educators to meet the mental health standards of their respective states.
The low rates of suicide in both of these states proves that having a mental health framework is effective in promoting student wellness.
In order for the Department of Education's mission statement to be fulfilled, students must have sufficient mental health education in order to be able to cope with mental health issues they may face later on.
Proper implementation of extensive mental health standards are essential to the well-being and success of students throughout the state of California.
Thank you.
Board member comments, questions?
Board member Rucker.
Well, first of all, thank you very much for, I want to thank both you and your, wow.
My mic is really on.
I want to thank you and your committee members who worked on this project on this particular topic.
And I'm whispering, by the way.
I just want to say that.
Because this is a particularly difficult subject to tackle.
And so before I say my comment and ask my question, I do want to ask the members of your committee who worked on this to just please stand if they're in the room.
So the reason why I ask that, thank you very much, the reason why I ask that is, you can go ahead and sit down, the reason why I ask for you to stand is it's very difficult whether we're talking about adults or children in high school or elementary school or middle school to talk about issues of mental health.
And it's not a new thing.
Having the concerns and the issues that you raised about students in school, it's not a new thing.
It's easy for people to say or to distill it down to a single topic and say, well, this is something that's happened because of all the changes in school and the stresses that are put on students.
But there are many stresses that are common to every generation that's gone through school in this country or in any country.
But the fact that you were able to so well develop the idea and develop the cause and the purpose for adding a study of mental health and training for educators, I think that that was very well-rounded.
I did have a question for you concerning the statistics you talked about on dropouts.
You said that there are many students with mental health issues who are a large portion of the high school dropouts.
And so can you tell me a little bit more about where you teased out that information from?
So part of my group did the fact checking and research for that, so I'm not aware of the specific percentage, but we did find that students with mental illnesses do make up the largest high school dropout rate.
Part of it is because of their mental illness.
So I was just trying to get out to have in place a mental health framework to address those with mental illness.
The reason why I ask is because right now when the board has had the discussion about setting policy concerning the graduation rate and looking at the cohort and talking about dropouts,
We talk about academic programs and about academic recovery, but there is a link to school climate issues that you touched on in identifying this group of students or this subgroup of students among those dropouts that I'm not really sure we have thought about as well as we could have.
So I really do appreciate you bringing out that particular topic and that particular statistic.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
So first, I want to thank you and your entire committee.
You really did your research, and so those who did the research and the fact-checking, just a credit to you to present a really thorough presentation.
So you may know, and you did comment, the Instructional Quality Commission is going to be looking at the health framework and the recommendations with a commitment to update from 13 years ago.
So we'd really like to take your recommendations, if that's okay.
We have a November 17th IQC meeting that Member Rucker and I will be at, and if that would be okay with you and your committee, we'll be glad to present on behalf of the students your recommendations to consider as far as the development of the Health Framework Committee, the new framework.
So thank you so much, and just a credit to you.
I know I've watched you all work in the past, and I know you probably worked very, very late last night to finalize your presentation,
To credit to all of you for just the thoroughness, both the data and the state implications for the recommendations that you're making.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Hello, honorable board members of the State Board of Education, Superintendent Torlakson and President Hurst.
I'd like to thank you all for taking the time out of your day to listen to our proposal.
I know I can speak on behalf of all of us when I say that we greatly appreciate it.
My name is Haley Holthausen.
I'm a senior at Mira Loma High School in the San Juan Unified School District right here in Sacramento.
I'm here today to present our proposal on behalf of the underrepresented students in the English language development program here in our California public schools.
According to its mission, the California Department of Education strives to assist in the development of listening, speaking, reading, and writing proficiencies amongst the ELD students.
These fundamental skills have been deemed the core of achievement both inside and outside the classroom.
California has the highest percentage of English language learner students in the United States at 22.1% of students or 1.37 million students total enrolled in the ELD program.
We aim to acknowledge and represent one of the most underrepresented populations in the California public school system by highlighting their academic needs.
Of the 1.3 million English language learner students in California, in the graduating class of 2015, only 69.4% met graduation requirements and were able to receive a high school diploma.
Compare that to the 82.3% of total California public high school students who received a diploma, the students in the English language development programs are falling 12.9% behind.
In the 2015 to 2016 academic school year,
1.1 million K through 12 students took the California English Language Development Test.
Out of those students, 41% scored as advanced or early advanced, earning them a passing score.
In comparison to the 2014 to 2015 school year, where only 18% earned a passing score, we can see that this number is substantially better than those in the past five years, where the average was only 18.2%.
However, the 59% of students who are still not attaining this passing score demonstrates a clear room for improvement.
Students in California public schools have both paid witness to and experienced firsthand the hardships of students in the English language development programs.
Students at Mira Loma High School in Sacramento have seen English language learner students not have equitable access to tutoring programs or extra help for their difficult classes due to these programs only being offered in English.
Students at Monterey Hills Elementary have been wrongfully placed in the English language development programs due to insufficient testing methods.
and this misplacement led to them losing valuable instructional class time and caused a limited choice in future courses even after moving out of the ELD program.
Students at Diamond Bar High School in Orange County have been denied access to AP math courses due to their status as ELD students, while students from Virginia Peterson Elementary have been removed from advanced programs such as GATE due to their status as ELD.
While the English Language Development Program has proved critical in advancing the English proficiency levels in students, it should not hinder their ability to receive the same education or opportunities as students not enrolled.
The California Association of Student Councils and the Student Advisory Board on Education is in full support of the current English Language Development Program being implemented.
However, due to these testimonies and statistics alike, we respectfully
we respectfully present that the administration of the English Language Development Program remains incomplete in many school districts.
As you can see, each school, and therefore each district, has their own challenges facing them.
This is why we are proposing that the California State Board of Education recommend that at least one current student and one former student from the English Language Development Program be represented on the English Learner Advisory Committee, or ELAC.
Subsequently, we recommend that in addition to one student from the ELAC committee within a district, that at least one student representative serve on the district level English Learner Advisory Committee.
We also suggest that parent representatives consist of at least one representative from an elementary school.
We recognize the current extent of parent involvement in the ELAC, though minimal in some cases.
Parents are not always completely aware of the extent to which their presence can impact their child's likelihood to succeed in school.
By requiring the inclusion of students, we may see a spike in parent involvement due to the increased ties they have to the committee.
We project our proposal to come at a minimal cost to the State Board of Education.
These minimal costs may arise should the districts decide to reimburse the additional students for their transportation, provide refreshments, or as a result of any other expenses they may see fit.
This committee will stimulate a positive and constructive dialogue surrounding the English language development programs.
These committees will give the students who need it the most a voice in their education.
With the engagement of these very key stakeholders, we hope to further the progress being made with the English language development program.
We hope to decrease the challenges faced by individual schools and districts by recognizing and catering to the different hardships facing elementary, middle, and high schools.
Together, it is our responsibility to give our community's students a voice, and I implore you to consider our proposal regarding the inclusion of students in both the ELAC and the DELAC.
Who else can better understand the needs of the English language learner students than them themselves?
Thank you, and I now yield myself to the chair.
Thank you.
Board member comments?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you so much for this presentation.
You know, my heart was just warming up and hearing the advocacy on behalf of students that are some of the most vulnerable that we have in our system.
And I think it's incredible that in, how long did it take you to do the research?
Well, we started on Sunday.
So within maybe four days, you were able to shed light on the inequities and differences and some of the challenges that EL students have to encounter through the K-12 system that we have.
So in four days, it's something that's pretty obvious, right, for anyone that does the research.
So I thank you for it, and I thank you for the recommendation, and I think it's a good recommendation to consider incorporating EL students and a reclassified student in some of the decision making.
As a reclassified student, I think that we are the ones that have the best perspective, because it's a personal perspective that we have.
So I want to thank you and your group, who could raise their hand or stand up so they could be acknowledged.
Go ahead and stand up so you can get a little camera time too.
Thank you, thank you for your hard work, and thank you for the presentation.
All right, we're ready for the next presentation, I think.
Good morning Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst and honorable board members.
My name is Qazi Ahmad.
I am a junior at Middle College High School in Loda Unified School District in the city of Stockton, California.
Accountability in education is essential to ensure that students are given the greatest priority in their schools and that schools continue to have continuous improvement.
Today, we are at a crossroads in our accountability system where our actions now will affect generations to come.
The academic performance index used a unilateral system that held our schools accountable solely with test scores.
Our schools are much more than these test scores alone.
And the student advisory board on education commenced this honorable board for their work in creating a new accountability system that focuses on a holistic approach when evaluating our schools.
Over these past few days,
While reviewing the frameworks of the new accountability system, we have realized that the system greatly increases the amount of areas and the amount of indicators that are examined in the system.
However, a factor that can still be improved upon is student input.
The new accountability system will not be truly holistic if students are not asked to contribute.
If the state does not know what the students are experiencing, then there is no way that the state can hold districts accountable for student performance.
Thus, the Student Advisory Board on Education recommends that the State Board of Education establishes methods of student input, such as through student surveys, under the College and Career Readiness Indicator and the Appropriately Assigned Teachers Access to Curriculum-Aligned Instructional Materials and Safe, Clean, and Functional School Facilities Standard, which is defined as a local performance indicator of the new accountability system.
We also suggest that the board recommends that local districts use a survey such as the California Healthy Kids Survey or the California Student Perspective Survey as a measure for the school climate standard of the new system.
Student input is valuable for the college and career readiness indicator because ultimately, students are the only ones who can assess how prepared they are for life after high school.
Surveys can include topics such as whether students are aware of the opportunities they have for life after high school, as well as if they feel knowledgeable enough to actually pursue those opportunities presented to them.
For the standard previously mentioned under the local performance indicator,
It is necessary to incorporate student voice because these standards are the fundamental and everyday experiences of students statewide.
Students are the ones going to school every day.
They are the ones directly receiving instruction from their teachers, and they are the ones directly using the school facilities.
These firsthand experiences of the students prove that student input under this indicator is one of the most meaningful ways to produce feedback from the primary stakeholders in the education system.
From a fiscal point of view, the costs of implementing this proposal are very minimal because you, the honorable board members, have already dedicated resources towards creating and defining these indicators and the measures that go into these indicators.
Thus, adding additional student voice through a student survey would not be a financial burden on the state board.
It is our shared responsibility to create an accountability system that represents all aspects of our schools, and our proposal calls for a greater student input in these specific aspects.
We urge you to include student input, especially in the form of student surveys, into the revised accountability system in order to ensure a completely holistic look into our schools and their performances.
It is a core belief of the California Association of Student Councils that equality of input and participation of all group members strengthens overall group performance.
We urge you to take action on this proposal and ensure the new accountability system is truly equitable and truly holistic.
Thank you for your time and I'll leave the floor open to clarifications or questions.
Thank you for that board comments.
So I remember.
Thank you.
I wanted to express my appreciation.
And also, I'd like to acknowledge the members of your work group, because clearly you spent a lot of time thinking about this.
So folks who worked on this, if you could stand up and as Felisa said, get some camera time.
Your recommendations are particularly timely.
I know in talking to a number of the students yesterday that you've been paying a lot of attention to our agenda and the very next item has to do with the indicators that we'll be picking for the accountability system, including a couple of the ones that you mentioned.
So we will certainly take those to heart and consider them very deeply.
I would also point out that Chief Deputy Price, I believe, is chairing a work group on the school climate pieces of it, and I know he's listening intently and will also be incorporating that in his work.
So thank you again.
Okay, thank you.
Next presentation.
It's on.
Okay.
Good morning, Superintendent Torlakson, President Kirst, Vice President Strauss, and honorable board members.
My name is Para Rowland.
I am a senior at South Pasadena High School in the South Pasadena Unified School District representing the California Association of Student Councils.
Students throughout California are afflicted by ineffective suspension and expulsion rates, veering them off the pathway to success and creating a negative feedback loop.
In an ideal world, all disciplinary policies would be clear and conducive to growth.
Instead of punishment for its own sake, discipline would serve as a tool to mold students into better citizens.
Though recent movement away from zero-tolerance policies and consequent statewide reduction of suspension and expulsion rates, we realize that both CASC and you all seek to eventually reach this same ideal state.
As a delegation representing the 6.4 million students of California, we felt that in our schools, there's sometimes apathy from our disciplinarians and deep-rooted mistrust from the students targeted by ineffective disciplinary policies.
To bridge this gap of misunderstanding, we, the Student Advisory Board on Education, would like the State Board of Education to suggest that district-wide committees that include but are not limited to students, administrators, and teachers
are formed that will meet annually to approve and, if necessary, revise the disciplinary policies for that school district in hopes of establishing common ground between students and faculty.
This, properly implemented, will have a threefold effect.
In the annual enacting of this process, students and administration must come to an agreement that the disciplinary policy is not only effective, but just as relevant as it was the previous year.
This ensures that actions taken through these guidelines are consistent.
In lieu of self-interpretation of the rules by individual staff members, a more objective, defined standard would be utilized to guarantee discipline is warranted.
Additionally, a yearly revision prevents potential disciplinary action based on antiquated guidelines, avoiding the confusion and miscommunication from irregular revision of policy.
Second, with the inclusion of student representatives in approving a district's disciplinary policy, all parties affected by it would now have increased awareness of its content, clarifying and informing the student body of all relevant changes with more efficacy.
The rationale is simple.
Students are more receptive to their peers, and they're more accessible to each other than administration.
Third, and most importantly, direct student cooperation with administration breeds a sense of trust between the two parties.
Knowing that their peers are part of the process and are therefore directly responsible for approving disciplinary policies, students accept the consequences from the disciplinarian's decisions partially as their own.
As a result, students have less resentment towards those in power and instances of disciplinary action, increasing trust.
Additionally, students who regularly interact with administration and whose voices is highly prioritized as the adults can serve as advocates for said adults.
prove to other students that those administering discipline do care about students' well-being and seek to invest in their futures.
Conversely, the presence of a student at this approval meeting will emphasize that the people affected by disciplinary policy are just that, people.
With that, I'm going to segue into a personal story of mine.
I met my best friend in middle school through our local competitive swim team.
He's a talented pianist, committed Boy Scout, and an excellent scholar.
He's also a recovering drug addict, part of a population often targeted by disciplinary policies.
In the past year, as his new drug use turned from casual social to something more serious, his loved ones and I watched him turn into this reclusive, angry shadow of himself.
By October, he was using crystal meth on a daily basis.
Though by January, he was actively on the road to recovery,
Finals were a hurdle, leading him to abuse Adderall.
He was caught and threatened with expulsion during his five-day suspension.
A counselor and assistant principal discussed alternative punishments with him and mentioned the possibility of addiction counseling.
However, the decision was ultimately up to our principal, who'd been relatively uninvolved the whole time.
After a cursory explanation on the final day, she announced the decision to continue the pursual of his expulsion.
For three weeks, he waited, not knowing what would happen to him, what would happen to his case.
Eventually, the school told him they were dropping it, and that he would be able to start school again next Monday.
Just like that.
We still don't know what changed their minds, but I am so glad to say they did.
Since then, he got a four on his AP Calculus AB test, which he had failed first semester.
The class finished his Eagle Scout project, started school at UC San Diego, and most importantly, he has been sober since the very first day he was called into the office.
His story isn't one that I share readily.
In fact, many of these details would be new, even to his parents and our close friends.
He's consented to my sharing it to emphasize the impact that an advocate can have on authorities, such as your all's view of a delinquent.
This isn't possible for every single case, and it's not what we're asking for.
But we know that a student representative on a district discipline board, at the beginning of this process, can serve to humanize victims of poor discipline,
poor discipline policies and remind administrations of the effects of their policies in the same way that I have shown their effects on my friend.
Those who commit the most drastic violations are often at the most risk to split between the cracks as a result of suspension or expulsion.
Removal of a delinquent from a classroom environment may improve classroom safety in some situations, but can also cause said delinquent to permanently remove themselves from the education system.
However, through my friend's story, it is clear that administrators, by listening to students, possess the potential to change the trajectory of their lives.
We want open dialogue, just like the assistant principal and the counselor provided, between students, parents, and administration in districts across the state to ensure that they understand where the other parties are coming from.
so that administrations have a greater understanding of what motivates students' delinquency, and that students and parents are not in the dark about action taken or its motivations.
The three main actions intended by our proposal, regular revision to remove ambiguity of disciplinary policy, a knowledgeable student representative to serve as a resource to students, and a bridge of understanding between stakeholders all serve one greater goal.
the continued reduction of delinquency rates.
By adopting our proposal and allowing students to have a stake in the disciplinary system, more effective policies are created and student satisfaction with disciplinary action increased.
Thank you for your time.
I now open the floor for questions.
Board Member Sandoval.
Thank you for a very well-researched and heartfelt proposal, you and members of your team.
Thank you.
I just wanted to mention this is clearly a very important critical issue, lives.
We're talking about human lives.
And I'm a volunteer.
I am a volunteer facilitator of restorative practices, restorative justice circles.
and those formats really have the power to start healing in communities and also open dialogue between individuals, not just students, but administrators, teachers, and it has the power to help make things right, to start to get things on a good path.
So I was happy to see that mentioned in your proposal and just wanted to thank you and your team for your work.
Board Member Rucker.
I also want to thank you for the work that you've done on this, and I really want to compliment the way that you framed this conversation.
It touched my heart, but not just because of the personal story, but because I too have seen how we have, as a society, created a norm that dehumanizes the policies that we are implementing.
And it cuts across not just what we do on school discipline issues, but in so many different ways.
When people talk about how many mouths they have to feed instead of children, and when people talk about hands instead of employees, we start thinking about how we can simply create and identify a statistic or a number.
And that happens when we call a student like your friend a delinquent instead of a student with special needs.
And so I think it's very important in the way you framed it
Not only that we understand that we need to take back how we identify, but we need to understand what it means to name the all.
So I really appreciate not only what you said, but how you framed it.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.
Board Member Sun.
And I just want to thank you on a personal basis.
Our school is going through a fairly large revamp of our discipline policies and looking at that.
And you reminded me how important the student voice is in that process.
So thank you.
All right, next.
Just same commendations, and could we see your team?
Could they stand up?
Okay, next.
Once again, thank you, Superintendent Turleckson, President Curris, and Vice President Stiles for having us here today.
My name is Nandini Patel, and I am the current Cass State President, as well as a senior at Vista Murrieta High School in the Murrieta Valley Unified School District.
For well over 30 years, the delegates of the Student Advisory Board on Education have identified the need for student feedback to teachers.
In today's society, our minds are geared to think that feedback is a negative term that is synonymous to criticism.
However, the students of the California Association of Student Councils, or CASC, have carefully crafted a system that provides important feedback to teachers regarding the climate of their classroom, the students' perception of the effectiveness of their teaching,
and the overall impact of their teaching style that it has on a student.
According to its mission statement, the Department of Education serves our state by innovating and collaborating with educators, schools, parents, and community partners.
As an organization that seeks consensus through collaboration, we would like to invite the State Board of Education to attend a meeting with the Association of California School Administrators, ACSA, the California Teachers Association, CTA,
California Association of Student Councils, CASC, in order to reach a probable solution regarding the concern of implementing a student-to-teacher feedback system in the California public education system.
We would like to discuss the student-to-teacher feedback system developed by CASC in addition to other surveys in order to streamline the students' perception of the classroom environment by giving teachers who are seeking continuous improvement in
the information they need to do so.
By implementing the system, students will be empowered as citizens who have an equal right to an opinion, while also receiving a platform to provide systematic and developed feedback to the people who have one of the largest stakes in their lives, their teachers.
One of the most important factors to note about this system is that it will not be used in the district evaluation of them, nor in the hiring or firing of a teacher.
Student to teacher evaluations are a simple and rather informal way to allow a teacher to gauge the student's perspective on factors that will influence their performance in class by allowing administration to tailor the questions they wish to see analyzed
in their school.
Some of the potential questions that could be asked include, does the teacher give a balanced presentation from different viewpoints?
Is communication between the teacher and the student encouraged?
And does the teacher give clear explanations and instructions?
The student's answers will be scored on a scale of one through five.
From there, the school is given back a comprehensive report that depicts the average score for each of the 25 questions through an overall class average,
the teacher's classes by periods, the class compared to the school's average, the class compared to the rest of the department, and a breakdown for each of the questions the teacher chooses to ask.
That being said, as we have not been able to properly explain the system to all of the parties involved, we have called for a collaborative meeting between ACSA, CTA, CASC, and hopefully the State Board of Education
to discuss the possible implementation of this system.
CASC is requesting the presence of the State Board of Education at this meeting in order to have them involved in the conversation and to discuss the feasibility of the student to teacher feedback system to be implemented at the statewide level.
I now open the floor for questions.
Okay, questions?
We'll certainly want to consider this and get help from our staff on how to, where will it be?
Most likely in Sacramento.
Okay.
All right, any, thank you.
Thank you.
We will.
One member left, Ortiz-Lacon.
I just wanna make sure that we equally acknowledge all of our groups.
I don't believe we asked the first group to stand up, so if you could please stand up, the first group that, I think it was a Berkeley Unified representative.
Okay, let's give them a hand.
Thank you.
And if we could have the last group that just presented, if you can stand up so we can acknowledge your contributions to the research that was presented.
Okay, thank you.
And that final speaker.
I would just like to thank you, Board and Superintendent Torlakson, once again, not just for hearing us, but for listening to us and actually pledging in that case to take action.
I hope that we can shortly turn some of the proposals presented here into actions implemented by you, the State Board of Education.
Thank you.
So I think we'll take the 10-minute recess.
We're going to take some pictures with the students, so come back in 10 minutes at 10 of 10, please.
We'll present this item, which is the accountability item.
Good morning.
My name is Cindy Kazanis.
I'm the director of the analysis measurement and accountability reporting division.
People are very excited about the previous.
Are you listening?
All right.
We'll keep moving.
This is the first time I've been presenting to you in my new capacity as the Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
I am grateful that Carrick and Jenny were, over the past several months when I was on maternity leave, were able to keep things moving along.
So we have a new accountability system.
Nancy Burnell is gone, so in her stead.
This is the new presentation with the department taking over.
So just to provide you a little bit of brief context for the item, previous board actions on this have started out, it's probably prior to the March meeting, but the March meeting is really when you approve the architecture of the accountability and continuous improvement system.
In May, you made a determination of how we created a
a single coherent local, state, and federal accountability system.
In July, you approved standards and performance expectations, and then finally, last meeting, you adopted the evaluation rubrics.
This agenda item has five attachments.
The first attachment provides an overview of the proposed performance standards for the academic indicator.
Attachment two provides an approach to how to determine progress for the local performance indicators.
Attachment three is an update and recommended action related to the application of the evaluation rubrics to charter schools.
And then attachment four is a draft timeline for the local accountability, local, state, and federal accountability system.
And then finally, as always, we include the education code.
So just to briefly sort of set a little bit of context here,
The items that weren't resolved by last meeting's action were the following.
The board did not set performance standards for the academic indicator.
We needed to take back to you how local educational agencies would collect and report progress through the LCFF evaluation rubrics for the local performance indicators.
And then finally, there was a request for clarification about how the LCFF evaluation rubrics would apply to charter schools.
With that in mind, there are several recommendations that we are asking the board to take.
The first was to adopt, as stated in the item, to adopt performance standards for the academic indicator based on student test scores for English language, arts, literacy, and mathematics for grades three through eight, which includes the results of the second year of Smarter Balanced tests.
The second recommendation in the item is to approve the proposed self-assessment tools for local educational agencies to determine progress on the local performance indicators for the following priorities.
Basics, priority one, school climate, priority six, coordination of services for expelled students, priority nine, and finally the coordination of services for foster youths, priority 10.
The third recommendation is to revise the approved standards for local performance indicators to clarify that LEAs must report the results of a local measurement of progress to their local governing boards at a regularly scheduled meeting of the local governing board.
And then finally, the final recommendation is to add language to the criteria to determine LEA eligibility for technical assistance intervention under the LCFF statutes approved at your previous meeting, and to clarify the applicability of the criteria to charter schools.
With those in mind, I have a couple things I wanted to talk to you about regarding recommendation one.
Recommendation one includes proposed performance standards for the academic indicator.
We base it on methodology of comparing the percent of students who are at or above standards on the Smarter Balanced assessments for English language arts and math.
As we discussed at the last board meeting, we all agree that using scale scores to determine school progress is a better method than at or above, but since we only received the final data file in September after the board meeting, there was not enough time to provide you a recommendation using scale scores.
I wanted to first acknowledge the work of Jenny Tseng and the Academic Accountability Unit in preparing this item.
They had assistance from the Technical Design Group, the CPAG provided input, as well as WestEd, with Eric Crane providing us input.
They've been providing data simulations that back up the recommendations behind this item.
They produced the data, again, that I just mentioned,
In doing so, we've had many discussions with board liaisons after the item was posted and are withdrawing recommendation one in order to give our staff the opportunity to review a scale score methodology and bring back a recommendation for you in January.
This will be a monumental task to accomplish in the eight weeks, with a couple holidays in between.
But we're committed to having all hands on deck to get this accomplished.
We want to take advantage of the opportunity to see what we can do with scale scores instead of adopting a methodology that would be temporary.
For today, we are only asking your action on the other three recommendations.
And with that, I'm gonna move to questions.
Okay, I wanna ask Board Member Burr to talk about the context for this change.
Well, first, Cindy, I just want to express my appreciation to you and Carrick, and especially Jenny, for thinking very carefully about how we can move forward in a way that we hope will be a long-term solution.
So I think the decision not to pull back from a specific recommendation is very much appreciated, and I'm thankful that you were able to do that.
Just a couple of comments.
I think, you know, it reflects what we've talked about over the last several meetings about scale scores in our view being a more appropriate
because it allows you to look at all student progress along the entire continuum and moves away from what I think was a flawed methodology, actually, of percent proficient, which focused schools on kids who were on the bubble, which didn't really serve us very well.
So really appreciate you doing that.
I think we probably want to talk a little bit about the scales core in the context of a growth model, because we've talked about growth again for many years.
I know the department's certainly been engaged in that, and look at different models that might work as we move forward.
In doing that, I would just encourage you to also seek the advice of some other entities that are already doing that work.
We've heard from the core districts who represent a substantial proportion of the
students in California.
We've also heard from the Charter Schools Association that they're working on something like that.
I will say in both of those cases, I want to be clear and on record that we're not interested in a summative rating.
We don't want one number to define LEAs, but I do think they're doing some interesting things with their test results and using them within a growth model.
So again, I really appreciate the withdrawal of the recommendation.
I think it's the smart thing to do rather than to act expediently because we thought we were up against some tight deadline.
but to really take the time and appreciate you and your staff's willingness to reprioritize some other work to be able to do that.
So thanks again.
Great, and I just wanted to mention that we are fortunate to have members of CORE and of the Charter School Association on our technical design group.
And so we've had a preview over the last several meetings of what they've presented to the public, and they've provided invaluable input through the process of looking at the second year Smarter Balanced scores.
Board Member Strauss worked on this also.
So, Cindy, again, thanks to you and the entire department and the continued work.
I think we are all really committed to trying to get this as right as we can and taking the time and understanding the urgency of helping districts use the data, but also wanting to get the best data that we can.
Particularly now as we look at the approach of how the academic indicator is going to report it for the English learner group.
So I think that's a key priority that we all share.
We heard this at our last board meeting and we've seen it in a lot of the comments leading up to this board meeting as well.
And we are very concerned that this be reflective of the actual practice and help us inform what we're going to do.
What we know is historically the students who are reclassified within the past four years were reported in the Yale group, and we know that you had originally incorporated that, but the ESSA state plans, ESSA will allow us to approach, give us some discretion on how we approach this, so we're gonna need to resolve this as we develop the plan as well.
So with the new timeline to incorporate scale, score, approach,
we try to blend this.
That's been our commitment all along, that the ESSA plan and our state work be integrated.
So what we're looking forward to in January, just to clarify, is that I believe that the department is going to run data in several different ways for ELs only, ELs including students reclassified within the last two years, and including students reclassified within the last four years.
So we can take a look.
and what the implications are.
Also I think it would be helpful because it is beginning to change the conversation from the percent proficient and the work that we did to try to move kids above into the next and look at the kids on the bubble and trying to move them in.
We're really going to try to look now at growth so maybe when you come back or actually requesting when you come back in January either you part of your team or maybe WestEd in support would talk
publicly to the board and to those watching us, what the change in using skill scores will allow us to do, using growth, what that means, how the conversation will change, and how it could be used in impacting both district and site practice.
So as part of the bringing back the data, we'd really appreciate it if you'd add the kind of professional development piece on
because we are moving and changing, but I think people are waiting to look at what we've got right now, and so I think it's gonna take a while, and I think that would help inform where we're going with this direction.
And I actually believe that Member Ortiz-Lincoln has one additional comment on ELs as you're thinking about the data, so if that's okay, President Kerst, maybe you could just add so that we stay coherent on our comments.
Yeah, I really appreciate that we're drawing this particular piece of the motion.
I did have some concerns with including RFEP students into the EL subgroup just because I anticipate that results would look very different when you include students who reclassified four years ago with students who are still considered English learners.
So I appreciate the request that member Strauss has requested.
And the other request that I had made is to look at the Latino students subgroup
take out the Latino EL students just to see how Latinos alone would perform if we don't have Latino ELs.
I know that one of the comments made was that perhaps Latino students were performing at that low level of meeting and exceeding because of the EL student population that's embedded into that student subgroup.
So I wanna see, I think that data should drive our conversations.
I just wanna see to what,
or to what impact are EL students having when we look at Latino students?
Thank you.
Board Member Rocker.
Well, first of all, this just goes to prove how flexible and agile our department staff can be in handling some of these concerns.
I also want to thank you, and I join my colleagues in saying I think that the work on the academic indicator created great concern.
And as we look at what will,
And I'm gonna be careful in asking the next question because it may be related to a different item, so I'm going to apologize ahead of time.
One of the concerns that I had in looking at how the academic indicator was proposed is in making the change from the percent proficient to the scaled score, I wanted to make sure we're all so clear on what the bands or the performance bands on the scaled scores are going to be because
It's not just adopting the use of the scaled score, it's understanding what's actually being reported by those performance bands that we currently have on those scale scores that define proficiency and all of those things.
And so what I want to understand is then, as it applies to those particular subgroups, particularly the English learner subgroup, because as we currently constitute that group, as has been pointed out,
That is the only subgroup that changes over time.
As an African-American, I'm always going to be in that subgroup.
And so is there a difference in the level of granularity that we can see in using the scaled scores and talking about the English learners as a subgroup so we can differentiate what the performance is among
subgroups of those students that we have clustered together into that one large, very generic term of art called English learners.
I also want to understand, because we're trying to create a growth model and we're also doing this reporting in the accountability system that has this two-dimensional grid on status and change, what will be the,
the post that define what status is and what will be the definitions of change because that's something, it was a one-line throwaway in the original item that just simply said we're going to move from percent proficient to this scaled score without really explaining how that will actually be analyzed and then reported for those two elements on our accountability grid.
And then finally, and this is maybe where I'm departing from discussion on this item to a separate item, so I'm going to apologize.
There is still, as it relates to the state plan, several items that have to be considered in making this change.
There is a requirement in the state plan for the state to have ambitious long-term and interim goals that define academic achievement as measured by proficiency.
So if we're changing the term of art to be what we're using on the scaled scores and moving away from the percent proficient, if the goal is still to maintain the single uniform accountability system, how do you make those two terms of art meet someplace?
Where is the overlap or where is the touch point?
Let me just interject on the question.
My understanding is the proficiency issue is still, you know, draft regulation and under a lot of consideration.
So it's possible it might be withdrawn.
So I don't think we want to spend a super amount of time
if it might be.
Okay, go ahead.
And then, again, going back to the relationship on English learners, because we're, again, going to use those scaled scores, is there a difference in what progress can look like for that subgroup?
In other words, I'm hoping that we're not going to write the definition of progress in the growth model with one broad brush stroke without considering if we have some flexibility to define progress for that subgroup.
And I don't mean differently as in with a lower standard, but understanding or identifying what that metric would mean.
And then there's a requirement also in the state plan that there is substantial weight given to this indicator.
So we want to understand both in the accountability system when you create this reporting on status and change, also what that substantial weight then would look like with all of the other indicators, including the academic indicator, and what constitutes substantial and what constitutes much greater.
You don't have to come back with that in January, but I'd like to know that there's some thinking going along with that to try to understand, again, how those things will meet together, where the tangent point is on those elements as well.
Okay, does someone have an easier question?
No.
Cara Cashly, Deputy Superintendent.
So I wanted us to say a couple things from a bigger picture perspective.
and that is there's a lot of different kind of reporting that goes on.
We've got individual student reports that go home to parents.
We've got data that we post on our website.
We've got the reporting that's required by the U.S.
Department of Education that we send to them.
There's requirements from the U.S.
Department of Education that we post on our own website.
They still have this
this requirement of looking at students, again, proficient or above.
So that data is posted with our assessment scores.
And we do have to address how we're going to meet those requirements from a federal perspective.
And then we have how we're going to use this data to measure schools in our accountability system.
And some of those may be separate.
And then we have the requirement of the school accountability report card, which has to demonstrate other information.
So we just need to be we need to separate out a little bit how we're going to meet these different requirements.
Right now we're talking about the evaluation rubrics, and we will get, as President Kerr said, you know, once we have final regulations and all and we finalize our state plan, we'll address how we're going to meet some of those federal standards.
The other point I wanted to make was that I don't want to
overly criticize or demonize the proficiency levels that we have with our assessment scores.
Those proficiency levels are very helpful for communicating to parents and to others where their child is, right, or where a number of groups of students are in terms of status.
That doesn't mean that that's the measure we want to use in our accountability system as we measure school's progress, but it's important information
for parents and for communities to take a look at.
But we want to use what's most appropriate for measuring schools in our accountability system.
The one difficulty or one of the difficulties with scale scores is exactly some of the issues that you've brought up in how are we going to communicate?
What is the meaning behind that, right?
We had proficiency levels, and we know what the meanings are behind those proficiency levels.
When we say, you know, the school or the student has a score of 2250, what's the meaning behind that?
And explaining that meaning to schools and communities as part of this accountability system will be a harder thing to do because the at or above proficiency is pretty easy to understand.
Scale scores won't be as easy, but we do need to come back with what the meaning behind those scores are.
So to that point, and I think Member Strauss mentioned working with WestEd, we have reached out to WestEd to help us develop a communication of sorts to our various audiences.
And again, we're on an aggressive time frame.
We're going to get to as much as we can in anticipation of a posting prior to the New Year's holiday.
But we may end up with the blue, who knows.
But there's going to be a lot of work going on over the next eight weeks to meet these needs.
Okay, other board comments?
Board Member Sun.
So I am in support of delaying the recommendation until the department has a chance to look at the sales score data.
What is the implication of this to getting information out, the first rubric out to LEAs and schools?
So we are in communication with the California Collaborative.
They have their first training, ironically, today across the street at the convention center.
You know, they are really focused on getting our professionals in the classroom and at the district level and I think members of the public familiar with
the evaluation rubric in general.
They are aware of this recommendation to withdraw this action from today's board item.
It could mean that the public release of the evaluation rubrics may be delayed.
I don't know.
There's a lot of moving parts right now, and until we really get our hands on the data, we're not going to have a clear,
a set timeframe ready to go.
But I think the intention is to get them out as soon as possible, but we want to get them out thoughtfully and not have what I think Board Member Burr say is drive the conversation.
So I've seen a preview of their presentation.
They spend a lot of time talking about the performance categories.
I think I saw 13 slides on the colors, which is great.
I think people will walk away from that presentation really understanding the elements of the rubrics.
And the data will come, it will definitely come.
And I think as Carrick also mentioned, districts have this data right now too.
So they can, they should be making decisions based on their Smarter Balanced data appropriately.
Yeah, and I would completely agree with that.
I know the department, we've been doing a lot of workshops around the evaluation rubrics.
I don't think we can do enough of them, because while we are very close to this, I think there's still a lot of information that we need to push out to the field and explain what this is before we launch with actual data.
Now, do you want to continue on the other items?
The other items, I didn't.
I was only asking for a question.
I think that the attachments really explain themselves.
So we're going to consider from the motion only two, three and four is now part of the motion.
One is delayed.
Board Member Burr.
I just want to more fully understand the recommendations relative to the local indicators.
And so that is for people who want to take a look at that.
Maybe you know it off the top of your head, Cindy, which attachment it is.
Attachment two, so page one of eight.
I'm not entirely sure what the recommendation is, I guess.
I know the recommendation is to adopt essentially what's embodied in this item, but I'll just state a couple things about the local indicators that I'm a little concerned about.
I think that
There's a lot of things unknown about many of the priorities, and we've got work groups going on about how to, particularly around school climate and some of the other priorities.
But I think that there is kind of an unstated expectation in the item that they will ultimately become state indicators.
And I just want to say, at least for me, that this is supposed to be a mixed system.
There are state indicators, there are local indicators.
We will ultimately have federal pieces that will all be part of this.
And with respect to local indicators, the reason they are local is because they're very contextual.
Remember, we have a district in Siskiyou County that's got five kids in it.
and there's no way that that district should be meeting the same expectation as the LA Unified School District.
We just have way too much breadth and geographic diversity, population density, et cetera.
So that's why a mixed system makes sense to me.
Having said that, we want to provide some guidance, which is what we did when we created the structure for local indicators about identifying the evidence, say whether or not you met it or you didn't.
But what I'm worried about in this recommendation is we're tightening the noose on local indicators.
And so I want to make sure I understand what the recommendation is, because I might be off base here.
But we're starting to make it look a lot more, as I told Carrie, the coordinated compliance manual, which we're desperately trying to get away from.
So I just want to make sure that embedded in this recommendation is the option for districts to choose their local evidence and their local tools for meeting these local indicators.
because the way I read it, it's making it sound like, especially on a couple of priorities, they're losing that option, that we're going to tell them what the instrument is, how often they measure, et cetera.
So can you help me understand what the recommendation is?
Dave's gonna help me understand the recommendation.
Hi, David Sapp, Deputy Policy Director with the State Board of Education.
The recommendation in this item addresses only four of the local performance indicators, so it's for the basics, which is sort of the Williams Settlement provisions, priority one, priority six, which is the school climate, the local climate survey local indicator, and then the two county office priorities, the coordination of services for expelled youth,
and coordination of services for foster youth.
There's still two local performance indicators that are not addressed as part of this recommendation.
Those have to do with the implementation of state academic standards and the parent engagement priorities.
Those, we're gonna come back in January with an update on those two priorities.
For the four that are addressed as part of this recommendation, the first has to do with the basics, the Williams settlement.
Those data are currently collected and reported through the SARC.
That's sort of something that districts have been reporting for years.
The proposal is that because the web-based system for the rubrics is the same platform as the SARC template that the department has developed, it's all in the same data system,
that the way to collect and report out that information through the rubrics is to basically take the same data in the SARC and report it through the rubrics.
So it's essentially transferring that data into this reporting platform.
For the local climate survey, which is priority six,
The proposal in the item is that there's a text box with prompts that an LEA would summarize what the findings from the local survey tool that they have used, and so there's flexibility for the LEA to use different survey tools.
So it does provide for that flexibility.
For the two remaining priorities, the County Office of Education priority areas, there is a proposed self-assessment tool which has between six and 10 prompts, for lack of a better term, that each have a rating scale.
And so the method of collecting and reporting information that's proposed in the recommendation for those two priorities is that the county would complete those self-assessments through the web-based system.
So it's basically like a web form, and the LEA would collect and do their own local collection of how they're doing on those elements, and then report it out using that self-assessment tool.
That tool, a staff from the department and state board staff
worked with representatives from county offices, and for the foster youth, went also with some foster youth advocates, and there was strong consensus from all parties that those were the right questions to be looking at, and that it would be a very helpful tool for counties to be using, because it tracks basically those statutory elements that are part of the priorities that are defined under LCFF for counties.
So for these four priorities,
proposed local assessment tools, the way that the information is collected and reported does differ from priority to priority.
So there is that sort of flexibility for choosing the different surveys for the local climate survey.
whereas for the Williams Settlement Priority One, there are specific parts that are required that are already reported, so it's pulling those out and just reporting it in.
And then there's a standard self-assessment tool for the two county office ones.
I think to respond directly to Board Member Burr's question about whether the recommendation as to these four local assessment tools
is sort of being used as a framework for the proposal that will come forward on priorities two and three.
I think just to be clear, we are continuing that conversation with stakeholders and that as you will see in these four proposed tools, there are differences in how it's being done.
And so there's no specific proposal at this time that there would be one approach or that it would be open-ended.
That's something we're continuing to work on and we'll come back with a recommendation hopefully at the January meeting.
So thanks, Dave.
That was very helpful.
I'll just say for me, I hope that as we come forward with the other two priorities, we provide as much flexibility as possible at the local level.
I know we're aware through CPAG that there are districts that have their own tools, they're comfortable with their own tools, they've been using them.
I don't think we want to come in and say, no, you need to do something different.
But I also, there's a recommendation on page three that I just, I don't think you addressed, and I just want to make sure that this is part of the recommendation, that we would be requiring LEAs to designate a representative to compile and coordinate feedback.
Is that part of the recommendation?
and present the results to the local governing board, and then determine the performance, which I think is already required.
But the first part about designating a representative to compile and coordinate, is that part of the recommendation?
So I'm gonna take this, because it's more of just a technical design of how you get information in the rubrics.
There is really a back-end coordinator, we're calling it the rubrics coordinator, to push up data.
So keep in mind for the local performance measures, we're not using CALPADS to pull data.
We're asking districts to put data in that is
you know, it's a self-assessment.
So this is just merely a technical person, but I would not send it to the CALPADS coordinator.
I'd send it to somebody who is maybe on the CISC, a CISC kind of person, a curriculum person to upload that information.
So I'll just say this is kind of my ongoing concern about
We're a policy board, right?
We're supposed to be setting policy.
And I know that we were given this big job about implementing LCFF, but I worry that what keeps creeping in here is very micromanaging.
And I get that you guys, you know, ask for testing coordinators and all that, but I don't know that in a board action we want to be embedding
Again, micromanagement that is going to be uniformly applied to a state like ours.
So I would just really guard against that if I could.
Yeah, point well taken.
And I just wanted to add on to Cindy Kazanis' comments in terms of the coordinator.
So this is the person that would be communicated with.
when it's time to upload something or to notify them there's a new survey that you can use or who's going to upload that local data for them.
Right now, they already have a SARC coordinator.
And since the SARC design is the same as this design, designed by the same people, in most cases, the SARC coordinator and the LCFF evaluation coordinator is probably going to be the same person because they're going to be the same one uploading the data.
This is the action.
It doesn't actually specify a person or a coordinator.
I think that we got into more detail in the attachment to allow for members of the public to better understand how this would occur, but this also points to the process in vetting the results through a group.
And that, I think, is appropriate, but here's, again, my concern, not to beat a dead horse, but by us taking action on this and referring to attachment two, I would assume that people could rightly say, well, attachment two says all of these things.
I'm sorry, the attachment two is my cheat sheet.
This is not actually in the recommendation.
the word attachment to is something I added as a reference point.
It's not in your recommendation.
Okay, so all we're being asked to do is the local governing board piece.
That's correct, as well as approving the tools.
Okay.
Okay, these follow up on these issues.
Okay, could Board Member Ruckers first, and Board Member Ortiz will come.
Okay, so I appreciate also, David, I want to thank you for giving the clarification on the issues related to the local indicators.
I agree with Board Member Burr about the issue of not only the flexibility for locals but
I think the intermediary agent on this is what will county offices who have the responsibility of vetting and approving these plans and understanding these local indicators, they will have multiple LCAPs that will have multiple different types of local indicators.
Somewhere on the continuum of flexibility, there's these mileposts of complete deregulation and salutary neglect and the type of micromanaging that Board Member Burr is concerned about.
I don't think the micromanaging, though, is coming at this level from the Board because I'm very clear that the policy that's defined in this action really is a policy.
I think that county officers are going to look at the notes that you have written in attachment to and see some unintended learning outcomes from what will be implemented here.
And so, you know, as a former classroom teacher, I understand those unintended learning outcomes.
The example I always use is when I taught my students about the American Revolution of the 13 colonies.
I had students who legitimately thought there was only one African American who lived in the colonies at that time, and it was a guy named Crispus Attucks, because that's the only one they saw.
So there will be some unintended outcomes from the notes that are provided without clear guidance to county offices, so they don't do the type of micromanaging and insisting, well, this is what I have to see and understand about your local indicators in order for us to say that you're doing the work or you've considered the evidence,
inappropriate ways.
So I think that that's part, I read the same thing, but I'm not as concerned about what the state is saying.
I'm more concerned about how the collaborative will be able to work with county offices to help them understanding, with their understanding about what they're vetting, what they're approving, particularly for the county office and their own two indicators.
So I do, I think I'm very grateful for this conversation.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I think I'm a little bit on the other side.
I don't believe in micromanaging, but I also don't believe in laissez-faire, because this item in particular, not this item, but this topic of the accountability tools and the local indicators lacked a lot of detail in some of the previous memos that I saw, and I want to thank the California Practitioners Advisory Group
for putting some systems in there that made it a lot more transparent and provided some inroads for stakeholders to provide feedback for the local indicators.
I think the first memo that I read, it was somebody was supposed to complete the local indicators.
Who that person was was unknown.
What that protocol was intended to do was unknown, and there was no stakeholder's feedback.
And so this really provides some guardrails so that it is understood that this is a collaborative process, a transparent process that allows parents, students, other community stakeholders to have an input on what we think our district is doing based on the local indicators and how we would assess if we're actually doing that.
When I looked at the accountability tool or the evidence,
I don't think it's evidence.
I think it's an accountability tool.
Evidence would be to look at this is what we're doing, and here's the evidence.
I'm writing.
I'm providing some evidence that we're actually doing that.
The accountability tool is simply a reporting tool, and it's a self-reporting mechanism.
It's not really
asking the districts to provide evidence, but rather to self-evaluate.
So in fact, I was a little bit concerned that it was too loose and not providing a lot of evidence for the rating they were providing themselves.
So again, I think that we do need to provide some guidance, and I want to make sure that this process really is adhering to the intent of having a collaborative, transparent process.
Thank you.
I also have a comment on the clarification just on the climate one.
As I understand it, we were going to help local districts by vetting some instruments and just saying these look valid and reliable or giving them some guidance.
That didn't emerge clearly to me in the attachment.
And what was repeatedly referred to as a healthy kid survey, as if that's the only thing that we recommend at this point.
And I have my reservations about that particular survey as inclusiveness for climate.
So can you clarify that?
What is our role in assisting in this development of these indicators?
Thank you, President Coors.
That's a great question, and we have put together a school conditions and climate work group.
It's a great team of people, includes some recognized experts in determining validity of surveys and other instruments, and that group has met three times.
We're gonna be meeting in person on November 28th, and in the afternoon of November 28th, we'll be having a
an expanded stakeholder meeting, so anyone that would like to attend and be part of that work is cordially invited.
And one of the tasks that that group has begun to take on is the vetting and kind of taking a look at what are the different tools that are out there in order to get some of that information out to the field.
Okay.
Yeah, the item reads like an endorsement of Healthy Kids Survey to me too much, and so that concerns me.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Mr. Price.
Do you have students in that work group?
We don't as of yet, but we're looking at ways to get students integrated, and I was also listening with great interest today.
Definitely, and I asked for some copies of that, of the report, so we could circulate that to members of the work group, but also maybe get the California Association of Student Councils involved, and other students as well.
We've been talking to Youth Truth, for example, is another organization that's doing some great work around how to incorporate student input.
Great, thank you.
Okay, other board comments, or I'm sure we have public comments, so maybe we'll have another round after public comment.
Okay, we're ready with the public comment then.
We have 44 public commenters.
Would the following people please line up?
Rico Tamayo, Doug McRae, Patty Scripter, Rick Miller, Daisy Gonzalez, Carlos Sanchez, Sarah Valencia, Keisha McGee,
Castillo, Cynthia Flores, Maria Guzman, Pastor Rick Alanis, Cecilia Villegas, Katana Valenzuela, Sergio Luna, and Brian Rivas.
Good morning, President Kirst, esteemed board members, Superintendent Torlakson.
My name is Rico Tamayo, and I'm president of the Early Childhood TK-12 Council for the California Federation of Teachers.
And real quick, to go full circle, President Kirst, I took a class with yourself and David Tyak back in 1988, so I blame you for getting me into this position.
In any case, the California Federation of Teachers urges the state school board to maintain its strong commitment to establishing a single, coherent accountability and continuous improvement system for all of California's diverse public school students, regardless of where they attend school.
The CFT
urges board members to stay the course and ensure that charters are subject to holistic and multidimensional evaluations, as well as to clarify that charter schools will be required to complete all applicable local indicators, including self-assessments.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired testing specialist.
I submitted a handout to your electronic folder last week with suggested revisions for attachment one.
Briefly, for the status points, the revisions are based on the percent met and above metrics using 2016 Smarter Mailings results as baseline, but increasing targets by two percentage points per year to reflect typical year-to-year increases.
This choice does not preclude use of scale scores for growth model analyses in the future with percent metrics used as the reporting purpose.
For change scores, the revisions are based on Bob Lynn's 2004 findings on change scores for statewide tests, and they recognize the need for wider cut score bands for medium and small school districts.
The handout provides specifics based upon these design principles.
I'd ask the State Board to evaluate these revisions, which appears to be what you are doing today.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Rick Miller, executive director of the core districts.
I want to thank the board for the conversation around growth and just sort of say we want to reiterate the importance from our perspective of adding growth for our measures.
And so we sort of call the power of two.
And frankly, the difference between scale and scale and proficiency is much less important than looking at one of them and growth together.
And when you combine the two, there's enormous power as we begin to roll this out to
The 1.8 million kids across the state of California, the conversation we're having at the local level has completely changed, and you find teachers and principals who have what would appear to be well-performing schools that are actually outperforming in meaningful ways, and it can change a conversation and allow you to really focus on where you need to put the most assistance.
So there's power of two.
can be critical in moving forward and that's also why we continue to think as we roll out our growth measures, we look at social emotional learning and culture climate in schools and our high school readiness indicators that being part of a research pilot so we can continue to try things, learn from them and bring them back.
We're also happy to have this conversation, look forward to it with the board around the policy decisions for a growth model because how you consider growth is a policy decision and then technically you want to implement but making the policy is critical.
Thank you.
Good morning, Dr. Gonzalez with Policy Analysis for California, PACE, based out of Stanford University, USC, and UC Davis.
PACE is just really grateful for all of the work that you have done, and today we're here to urge you to really consider how the core districts and our core PACE research partnership can help the decisions that you're making.
PACE recently released a report called Local Control and Action, which we mailed to all of you.
And one of the key findings from that report, what the report does is it evaluates the implementation process of the core districts and their ability to really implement an accountability system.
And what we found was one, to Member Burr's comments, was that flexibility was key to their ability to do their work.
Every school district implemented the core district's indicators, but flexibility was key.
The second thing is that school administrators really valued the emphasis of measuring growth and student achievement across multiple measures.
This was particularly important for low-performing schools.
And the last key thing from that report is really that in order to succeed and to build an integrated system, capacity building is gonna be key, particularly in helping schools understand and respond to data.
Thank you.
Patty Scripter, California State PTA.
We appreciate the move of scale scores to January.
I know it is a communication issue that was discussed, and I believe PTA would be happy to commit to working with you the same way we did on California Standards and Assessment in getting that important information to parents.
And also I want to comment on the local flexibility issue.
It is important and it is critical, but also I appreciate member Ortiz-Lincon's comment that we do need to set up some minimum standards of communication, and that's why we think it's really important that there's a clarification about the need to communicate the information at a board meeting where public comment is allowed.
We also think that the CPAC recommendations were great, but we suggest substituting should instead of could coordinate with.
Should is not must, but it is really a clear guidance to that this is really reflecting the way that the LCAP and LCFF should work, and that's through outreach and engagement.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Carlos Sanchez.
I am a leader with PICO California in the state of San Bernardino.
PICO has 19 federations across the state of California.
We are a multi-faith and multi-racial organization that strives to develop local leadership from our congregations, schools, and communities to work with racial, social, and economic justice.
Together, we represent over 480 congregations and 450,000 families of diverse economic, racial, and religious backgrounds.
rooted in 18 school districts across California.
We thank you for your commitment on parent engagement, and school climate has a key indicator for Rubik's, and we ask you to include parent engagement's menu of evidence-based measures in the adoption of LCFF Rubik's so it could be used this school year.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Sara Valencia.
Pico California would like to thank President Kurt, the State Board of Education and State Board staff for all your hard work and commitment to parents and students of California.
We would also like to give special thanks to board member Bruce Holliday, Dr. Nicolasa Sandoval and Dr. Eileen Strauss.
In 2012,
Pico, California, led the largest volunteer voter engagement effort in support of the passage of Prop 20 in this state, turning out 67,000 voters to support the passage.
Following its passage, Pico, California, has participated in the effort to pass the local control funding formula to ensure that LCFF achieves the goal of creating improved outcomes for low-income students, English learners, and foster youth.
foster youth.
Pico California's 19 federations are getting contacted over 250,000 voters to support Proposition 55 to ensure we continue receiving LCFF funding until 2030.
We thank you for your commitment to parent engagement and school climate as a key indicator for the rubrics and we ask to include parent engagement menu of evidence-based measures and adoption of the LCFF rubric so it can be used this school year.
Thank you.
Good morning to all.
My name is Cristina Castillo and I'm a leader of PICO with OCL and I come from the District of Santa Ana.
Many times parents are not listened to by the staff.
Cuando existen cosas muy serias, los estudiantes se sienten intimidados, olvidados, y los padres a su vez
There are many times when serious incidences occur at schools that students are not listened to and forgotten, and the parents feel threatened because we are not listened to either.
When I asked about the fact that a supervisor was yelling at my daughters, I immediately received a call from the police and I was treated like a criminal.
I felt powerless to advocate for my children by feeling powerless from the same school.
I'm asking that there be a center for parents at the school where their concerns can be attended to immediately.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Cynthia Flores and I am with Pico, California in Costa Mesa.
Our schools and our districts have a uniform way to measure on how well they involve parents and students throughout my, parents and students.
Throughout my years in public schools, I have had different experiences with parent engagement and student engagement.
A school is like a second parent.
Just like a parent, they care for us, or they should care for us.
They shouldn't be treating students this way, connecting to her story.
Parents should know what goes on in our education.
and they should be treated as important allies in our education.
That's why we need our schools to also be evaluated in how they invest in developing district staff and evidence based on professional development to better engage with parents and students in meaningful ways.
We thank you for your commitment to parent engagement in school payment as a key indicator for the rubric and we
Thank you very much.
Buenos dias a todos.
Mi nombre es Maria Rosa, leader de Pico, Conoco en Anaheim.
Estamos aqui en apoyo de crear centros para los padres.
en todas las escuelas de California que brinde la bienvenida a todos los padres sin preferencia alguna.
Preparando a los padres para adquirir el conocimiento de saber y entender cmo el sistema educativo proporciona y debe de dar todos los servicios que aplican
para que los padres, maestros y todo el personal de las escuelas seamos la voz de los estudiantes.
Y unidos en el mismo camino, todos los estudiantes y en especial los English learners, student and poster student, logren las metas acadmicas y emocionales en un ambiente de armona, por el bienestar de todos nuestros futuros profesionistas.
We thank you for your commitment and parent engagement in school climate.
As a key indicator for the rubrics, we ask to include parent engagement, manual evidence-based measure in the adoption of the LCFF rubrics so I can be used this school year.
Thank you.
Good morning to all, my name is Maria Rosa, leader of PICO California, C-O-L-L-O, in Anaheim, California.
We're here to support the creation of parent centers in all the schools in California to provide a welcoming site for parents without distinction at all.
To prepare the parents to acquire the knowledge and to understand the educational system.
so that our children can have the benefit of this.
I also would like the staff in the schools to give voice to the parents and United, because United, we are trying to seek the same path, to improve things for our students, especially for the English learner students, foster students, so that they can reach their academic and emotional goals in a harmonious environment.
Thank you to all.
Good morning, my name is Minister Keisha McGee and I am with Pico, California of San Bernardino.
I am a mom of two college, one sixth grade, first grade and preschool student.
I have shared my story with the board before about how my son was bullied in school and how that brought awareness and an awakening of the importance of parent engagement and getting rid of school suspension.
and in return having positive reinforcement to ensure a better school climate.
I would like to thank you for the work that you have done already to make sure these things are a success and I ask that you continue to make these key indicators for the rubrics and that you include parent engagement
menus as evidence-based measures in the adoption of the LCFF rubrics so it can be used this school year.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Rick Alanis, Jr.
I'm a youth and young adult pastor at Victor Art San Bernardino representing Pico, California, ICUC, and Gazzano into Now Generation.
Today we want to thank you for including suspensions as part of the LCFF rubrics.
We also want to ensure that we continue to keep students in class by replacing suspensions with positive behavior intervention support.
We believe that this will play a key role in seeing a higher graduation percentage rate.
We also believe that many students can benefit from a second chance mentoring and support program.
It is through this type of program that many of the students that I work with, including myself, have been able to learn to deal with the emotional and psychological stress that many students deal with growing up in an environment filled with gangs, drugs, and violence.
If not for a program like this, I would not be here today.
It was through this type of second chance program that I was able to turn my life around.
As someone who at one time was part of the problem, today I have become part of the solution because of these types of programs.
And my hope and ask here today is that we will continue to look at these types of programs and seeing how we can integrate them into our schools.
Thank you.
God bless you.
We'd like to ask the next group of speakers to please line up.
Sheila Whitley, Jesse Aguilar, Lorraine Richards, Angela Ramos, Ken Burt, Estelle Lemieux, Martha Alvarez, Holly Edds, Alicia Assara, Annalee Medrano, Lisa Morns, Christy Sinclair, Jason Henderson, Jackie Wong, and Martha Zaragoza-Diaz.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Cecilia Gallegos with PICO California.
As PICO California, we continue to organize at the local and state level to close academic achievement gaps.
We continue to organize in support of positive school climate and culture at our schools and districts across California, uplifting the well-being of students,
parents and caregivers through engaging in powerful shared decision-making and collective action.
Between parents, caregivers, students, community members, and educators, we would like to urge our State Board of Education members to please adopt parent engagement rubrics that include a menu of evidence-based measures to use well-researched evidence-based data to be able to compare experiences across schools and districts that is needed to achieve continuous improvement.
We ask to include parent engagements menu of evidence-based measures in the adoption of LCFF rubrics so it can be used in this school year.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Katana Valenzuela.
I'm with PICO California, and as PICO California, we believe that adopting a menu of evidence-based measures from which schools and districts can choose along with a self-assessment tool as evidence for the standard will provide flexibility to local schools and districts while maintaining high standards across the state with a focus on evidence-based practices.
Comparable data to inform continuous improvement and accountability in schools and districts across the state.
ability to correlate parent involvement to indicators in all eight priority areas and ensure that we are creating an integrated statewide system to support students to get success.
We thank you for your commitment.
We asked to include parent engagement menu of evidence based measures in the adoption of the LCFF rubrics so it can be used this school year.
Good morning board members, Superintendent Torlakson, I'm Estella Mu and I'm with the California Teachers Association.
In my limited time, I would like to bring to your attention the letter CTA and a broad coalition of teacher administrators, parents, students, and civil rights organizations submitted on this item.
We came together to urge the board to maintain its strong commitment to establishing a single, coherent accountability and continuous improvement system that is multidimensional and focused on supporting equity of access, opportunity, and outcomes for all of California's diverse public school students, regardless of where they attend school.
With continued appreciation for the engagement and evident hard work of your staff and the staff of the department, we respectfully ask that you consider our two requests.
Our first is to support the staff position regarding the reporting of charter school performance.
The long-awaited multiple measures dashboard for California schools should be equally available to students and parents in all public schools, including charter schools.
As detailed in our letter, the language and intent of the LCFF strongly support staff's statement
in this item that the reported argument by some charter school stakeholders is inconsistent with transparency and with the board's goal of developing a single coherent accountability system.
We urge board members to stay the course and ensure charters are subject to holistic and multi-dimensional evaluations
as well as to clarify that charter schools will be required to complete all applicable local indicators, including self-assessments.
Two, support timely development of local indicators and possible state indicators.
We are very concerned that the timelines for developing and finalizing local indicators for 2016-17
and possible state indicators for 17-18 continue to be delayed as identified in our letter.
These indicators ranging from parent engagement, school climate, to access to and enrollment in broad course of study are essential to ensure that rubrics are truly holistic and multi-dimensional.
For many of us, our support for the rubrics has hinged in large part on the board's commitment to developing and incorporating them.
Without the full development of these multiple measures, we do run the risk, once again, of relying on a system that is overly reliant and standardized test scores.
As a partner in many of the indicator development efforts underway, we pledge our ongoing support and ask the board to explore how additional resources may be provided to assist the department and the state board staff who are working so tirelessly to make the promise of the rubrics a reality.
Thank you.
Good morning, Marta Alvarez on behalf of ACSA, the Association of California School Administrators.
We're very grateful to the staff at the Department of Education and the State Board of Education for the extensive outreach over the last several weeks and months on the new system.
We at ACSA have been able to partner with the Department of Education staff and State Board staff on several webinars, three over the past month and a half.
on both the local performance indicators and some of the state indicators.
So we've been able to try to provide information to the field on the new system, and we look forward to continuing to be partners in this work since it continues to be evolving and will be changing over time.
We would like to encourage the State Board and the staff to do a memo to the field where it can clarify the different state indicators that have been adopted so far, as well as the local performance indicators.
The memos have been wonderful with the information provided, but typically you have to go back several months to understand each of the action items.
So if there is one comprehensive memo where there could be outline of what the state indicator is, the cut points and so forth, it would be really helpful to the public.
And that way we can provide that to the field as an official document from you all.
I will have my next colleague, Holly Edge, who acts as Vice President, to provide additional information.
Thank you.
Good morning.
As Martha mentioned, my name is Holly Eads.
I'm Assistant Superintendent for Educational Services in the Orchid Union School District, and I'm also Access State Vice President.
So it gives me great pleasure to come and talk with you this morning.
First, I want to commend the State Board.
You have done an incredible job with all of the moving parts of this process.
I truly feel like you've included us in the process, and I can't tell you how much that means, having done this job for quite a number of years.
The ability to provide input, the dialogue and the conversations that are happening back and forth between departments and AXA, they're pushing information out to us.
We really have felt like we've had a voice, and I want to thank you all.
So this isn't the first time I've come to speak with you.
I feel like we've been listened to, which is fantastic and very much appreciated.
So thank you very much for that.
I think our collective goal is to achieve a sense of balance and purpose with accountability.
and make sure we do it right.
So I appreciate the fact that you've tabled some of the decisions that were to be made today to make sure that we get it as close to perfect as we can, realizing it's not going to be there.
And it's a work in progress, but taking the additional time for that is very much appreciated.
On the issue of the self-assessment tools, I'd like to make a couple of suggestions with regards to those.
I do feel that we support the use of local performance indicators.
It's a very valuable tool that we can use to really holistically assess student progress and to take a look at it.
I do ask that you take a look at the current proposals.
They are rather lengthy.
to expect us to have conversations with our stakeholders, with them having so much depth to them.
It's difficult to do.
We pull our stakeholders in for meetings and have discussions about those questions and walk through them together as a group, and with the length and depth of those assessments, that would be very cumbersome and hard for us to do.
Also, some of the questions really need to have some rubrics with them to guide.
They were difficult to answer as we worked through the process the first time as well.
I actually am over here, I'm at the CCEE meeting today, meeting some additional briefing and information on the process and where we are, and I want to again thank you for that.
The information that's been pushed out has been tremendous, so thank you very much.
I'd like to call our next group of speakers, Sandy Mendoza, John Affelt, Liz Guillen, Tia Nguyen, Michelle Paracet,
Sergio Luna, Terry Burns, Sarah Lillis, Eric Premack, Brian Lee, and Elizabeth Robitaille.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, and I am representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
First, I'd like to say that we support not adopting the standards for the academic indicators until January.
We believe that there are some issues that still require
a more thorough vetting such as including the RFIP data with the EL data.
We believe that in doing so the true academic performance of both groups is not clearly shown.
We recommend that the RFIP data with the EL data not be included for this year and have the EL work group
provide a recommendation at the board January meeting.
Also, during this time, CDE should analyze, share, and discuss with stakeholders the impacts of including RFEPs in the EL subgroup and the pluses and minuses of considering different post-redesignation time periods, such as one year, two year, or three years after reclassification as compared to the current decision to count four-year RFEPs as ELs.
We believe that other thought through options could emerge through such a process.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Carson, Superintendent Torlakson, and esteemed members of the board.
My name is Jackie Wong.
I'm with the National Center for Youth Law.
We actually spearhead initiative to close the achievement gap for students in foster care, and I know, again, a lot of you have been supportive of our efforts over time.
I'm actually here to represent a broad base of foster youth education advocates.
the Children Now Public Council, the Alliance for Children's Rights, and the California Alliance for Children and Families.
We actually very much appreciate the efforts to engage our stakeholders in this conversation, but we actually remain very deeply concerned that the self-assessments for the County Office of Education only require that they mark that they did an assessment versus actually share publicly what those assessments entailed.
So to that end, we actually encourage staff, CDE, as well as State Board of Education,
to actually meaningfully engage us in the conversation about fully integrating Priority 10 into the existing rubrics.
So we also suggest that we also do not duplicate reporting with the Foster Services Coordinating Program, and as much, if we can align kind of the reporting requirements under the grant as well as the rubric would be really great.
Thank you again for your time and for prioritizing students in foster care.
Good morning.
My name is Sandy Mendoza.
I'm with Families in Schools, and we appreciate the opportunity for continued thoughtful conversation around parent engagement in the next couple of months.
But we want to assure you that we support the recommendations offered by CPAC, and in particular, what Board Member Ortiz-Ligon just raised, that while flexibility is important, it is important also to have
guidance that directs LEAs in such a way that we don't have or support a culture of complacency, because that's what I'm afraid we'll end up with.
And also, last Friday, there was a webinar hosted by WestEd, which raised a question at the end, asking if it would be a good idea to create a workgroup on parent engagement, and we would like to
support that because I think it's important that we have experts at the table, especially parent leaders in that conversation.
And finally, we also urge the board to consider expanding the requirement that LEI must report the results of local measurements outside of the board meeting, but also in the other important committees.
Thank you.
Good morning, John Eppfeld from Public Advocates and the LCFF Equity Coalition.
Number one, we support the move on the scale score issue and getting that right in January.
Number two,
We agree with the Caltog recommendation that you defer adopting today the EL proficiency issue, and whether or not that indicator should include two years, three years, four years of RFEPs.
It's really a more complicated issue, and I think like with the scale score and some of these local indicators, you should push that over to January and look at the data.
Number three, we agree with the notion, Public Advocates does, of making sure we have a timely broad course access, standards implementation.
We're getting a little worried about some of these other indicators slipping from even being into the 17-18 rubric.
I mean, we need recommendations in March for adoption in September, and we hope that you'll stay on that timeline.
Thank you.
Morning, Terry Burns, behalf of California School Boards Association.
I first want to say that we support the clarifications on the charter school and the applicability of the rules to charter schools so that that's clear to everyone.
One of the comments deal with communications.
I want to thank members some for raising the issue of the implications of the delay.
We've been telling folks are going to get their data in February.
We need to be as clear as possible about when they'll get it, what to expect and how they can start planning to address their rubrics with that.
Additionally, we still have the concern about including 11th grade assessment data, not including it in the assessment item.
We think it's gonna be very difficult to explain to parents and reporters and the community as a whole why there is nothing in the assessments item for high school districts.
Finally,
We have concerns about clarifying to which years the data applies because your data is different in different indicators.
And so please be clear on what folks are getting.
Thank you.
I should have put that on.
Hi, Brian Lee on behalf of Fight Crime Invest in Kids, Mission Readiness, and Ready Nation.
I wanted to make one point, and that is that we strongly believe that the local performance indicator on school climate should require reporting climate survey results annually, not every other year as currently proposed.
This is very important.
We had a letter submitted by 12 different organizations.
We've appreciated the commitment to school climate survey that we've heard from the board.
But the local performance indicator does not match that commitment.
Basically, it sends a message.
This is the one indicator singled out that you don't need annual data just every other year.
That basically says it's not nearly as important as other things.
Also, it's inconsistent with the annual requirement of LCFF, which is about annual reporting on how are you meeting goals.
And in practice, what happens if you did your survey,
The year before the LCAP, it means you only see results once in the three-year LCAP, which really does not give us a chance to see what's happening.
It's also just an outdated relic.
20 years ago, when we first started having Healthy Kids Survey required due to federal law, we said every other year comes a new thing, but now it's no longer a new thing.
Thank you.
Good morning, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
I also wanted to thank the board for delaying the action on the academic indicator.
Moving to scale scores actually allows us to see the continuum of performance for kids, so it's the right direction.
We're also appreciative around the work on growth and trying to create a growth model.
A little concerned with the staff memo, though, about putting growth and cohort status, cohort data in the academic indicator together, because it's measured different things and conflates things.
So as we have that conversation about the growth indicator, how we bring that into the system will be important.
I want to echo Brian's point about the local surveys and also expanding that to parents and teachers that their point of view is very important and needs to be integrated.
Then finally, I want to raise an issue that I hope the board will address at the next meeting,
and this is around alternative education.
The decision in September was to remove alternative education from the overarching accountability system, and we get that from a school perspective, we need to think about those indicators in a thoughtful way, but from a district perspective, it creates a really challenging context where we're actually making those kids invisible in the system, and it's a real issue for seniors because one out of every five seniors goes through an alternative ed system, and so they're not being captured at all right now.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
Sarah Lillis with Ed voice.
I also want to reiterate Miss Burns comments both about our appreciation, the clarification on charter schools and their different statutory construct as it relates to the rubrics and renewals and also again reiterate our the need to have 11th grade assessments, both in the C C I and as a separate measure.
And in anticipation of January's discussion, I did just want to talk about, um
thinking about transparency.
When we talk about transparency, what we really mean is about having an honest conversation both about where we are and where we want to go.
And we were very concerned about the performance standards that we were going to be approving today.
When we talk about masking low performance in the yellow
group, but also setting that green target as something that we really want as a state that want to be our goal.
If the green is our goal, then what is the message that we're sending?
The proposal that we're not talking about today was 51% proficient in math, and we at EdVoice don't feel like that is actually the message that California wants to send, that that's good enough and that's our goal.
So we look forward to that conversation in January.
Good morning, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I do want to thank you for your shifting the emphasis to scale scores.
That's something we've been talking about for a long time and it's great to see that moving forward.
Also want to thank the board staff and department staff for meeting with us and discussing some of the more detailed nuances about how this system applies to charter schools.
We're very pleased with the recommendations that came forward in attachment three.
and we believe they reflect an alignment with the law as the law has stated on those issues.
A little confused at some of the comments today because we, as you know, charter schools have been working with an outcome-based accountability system for many, many years, so we are not afraid of that accountability, we just want to make sure that it's aligned to our goals and the outcomes that we're seeking to achieve for our students.
So with that, I also want to just note that we are also a little bit confused about what the recommendation is today, mostly on the attachment three, or attachment two, because the recommendations are in the item, but they're not in the, they're in the attachment, but not in the item, so it would be great to get some clarity on your motion to your point, Member Burr.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We very much appreciate some of the clarity here on charter schools.
We do remain concerned, though, that they seem to be subbing in criteria, alternate criteria relative to what's in the statute.
We're also especially concerned about the language does not reflect the fact that we have
We do have some serious technical concerns about.
Separate charter renewal threshold language during the suspension of the API and the memo and the proposed language to you ignore that we've suggested an amendment to address that issue.
whether SBAC can actually do that given the severely truncated adaptability of the test and the long gap in time between grades 8 and 11, whether you're going to get any valid growth information at the high school level we think is quite questionable.
Finally, we're just very pleased to see that the
coalition is so very concerned about charter school parents and equity now and we look forward to their support in the upcoming legislative session to get equal funding and facilities for charter schools too.
So thank you.
Okay, that's the end of the public comment.
So now ready for more board discussion before we consider the motion if there is more board discussion.
So, Cindy, would you clarify the motion now before the board since the issue about the attachment.
Yeah, just just clarify.
That'll be helpful.
I can clarify.
So the attachment specifically, attachment 2, page 3 of 8, has a subtitle that says recommendations, and the first sentence says that the CPAC provided input.
So these are recommendations from CPAC.
What you are taking action on is the actual recommendation that is included in the board item.
which is on the screen here.
This is number two, and then number three, which we reviewed, as well as is the action you are taking.
Does that make sense?
Member Burr, then Member Williams.
You were showing number two a minute ago, I think.
Yes.
So the proposed self-assessment tools I get for the number Priority 9 and 10, and Dave talked about Priority 1, which is essentially what LEAs have had to report for a long time around the Williams condition.
And school climate, then, on priority six, as I understand it, is a narrative.
An open text box.
Open text box, lots of flexibilities for LEAs.
That's correct.
And that's all we're being asked to approve.
Okay.
This on top of the local governing board would bring these forward in a public meeting.
So I actually have two questions.
One is actually on the other priority areas.
We heard a lot of concern about the timeline for the ones that we haven't yet completed, and I'm looking at the timeline attachment, and it's not clear to me when those are gonna come forward.
So if you could clarify that, I would appreciate it.
And then, Cindy, more to the other substantive conversation, that when we talk in January about growth models and scale scores,
I think we really need to have a very clear discussion about whether or not grade 11 can be included in a growth model since we have no testing in grades nine and 10.
We had this conversation before when we talked about the college and career indicator and said it's more appropriate to include it in college and career indicator model.
But so I'm not sure people are, I don't understand, I'm not gonna attribute to other people
whether or not it can be in a growth model.
But I think we have to talk about it and also make crystal clear, everybody who's listening, the test scores are available to every LEA that tests 11th grade students and they are obviously available to parents.
So nobody's hiding grade 11 test scores.
The question is whether or not they can validly be included in a growth model, given the fact that we don't test in the earlier grades in high school.
So I think we just want to be real clear about that, and also back to the communication thing.
Make sure that we're clear to LEAs what they're getting, what they can do with the information.
But my specific question is about the timeline for the other priority areas.
Board Member Williams.
We're looking at January of 2017.
I just wanted to follow up on what Member Burr said earlier about her concern that at least on this slide attachment to is down there in parentheses which you were concerned about because it sounded like it was
So I'm assuming that the recommendation we can scratch out attachment to, and that is not part of the recommendation.
Please do.
That was, again, my edit to provide you some guidance on where to find the details behind it.
So I apologize.
This has been a confusion in presenting the motion.
And just to clarify, the item, the recommendation is found in the item, which does not include the parentheses attachment to reference.
So just clarify what the motion will be if someone moves the staff recommendation.
It's from the item itself.
It's on the top of page two.
To withdraw one.
Okay, Board Member Rocker.
I also, in listening to the public comment, there seemed to be a lot of ideas or some mental models about how the growth model itself is going to operate.
And so I think it's very, I go back to what Carrick Ashley said at the September board meeting, and that has remained the one question that stays in my mind on the conversation about the growth model.
you have to decide what it is you're asking the growth model to do.
And so there are different types of growth models and there are different types of data that can be included in those growth models.
And what is happening today in taking a lot of the conversation about the scaled scores and the attention to proficiency, percent proficiency off the table with this item is to give
our staff and the technical design team, the opportunity to answer the question that Carrick Ashley put in front of the board in September.
There has been no decision about what the model is.
There has been no determination about how the model will operate.
The goal is to figure out the best type of model that will give us the types of data we believe we're asking for.
And so I think that the mental model many people have are about some assumptions about what the growth model will tell us.
is a divergence from what we're actually tasking the staff to do right now.
So I think we are getting ahead of putting the cart before the horse and having the conversation about the assessments and about what is included and what is not included.
Because again,
The question is, what are we asking the growth model to do?
That's not a conversation we have had.
We know we want a growth model.
We have a statutory requirement to develop a growth model, and that is clearly in front of us.
But again, I want to remind you, the staff has already asked the board, what are you asking of the growth model, and what is it we believe, what kind of evidence or information do we believe a growth model is going to give us?
That is not a conversation we have had as yet.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
Again, Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent.
So thank you, Member Rucker.
So let me just clarify a couple of things, just to get it off the table, I guess.
Smarter balance scores between eighth grade and 11th grade can be used in a growth model.
They can.
We need to have the discussion about whether we think that's appropriate to do or not, but they can be.
And whether you want to, we can start the discussion, whether you as a board would feel comfortable making a decision about doing that without actually seeing the data between grade 8 and grade 11.
is a question for you to ask yourselves.
I can say that we can start the conversation in January, but let's separate out the two.
Jenny Singh and her staff have plenty of work to do just to talk about scale scores, and so that's one discussion.
But we can start the discussion in January, too, about what is it that we want out of a growth model in the future.
Go ahead.
I know we haven't had a conversation, but we did have an initial conversation about what do we want to see from this growth model.
And I was very excited when President Kurz mentioned we want to see how we can narrow achievement gaps.
And that was a conversation that began in September, how the growth model could be a way for us to really, if we're committed to that, to see how we can narrow achievement gaps.
So I would like to see that conversation resume in January as part of the larger dialogue about this model.
A couple of other questions going back to Board Member Burr.
The timeline for some of these indicators, we know we've had some delays.
I know that we have work groups, and because we want to be as thorough as possible and have a lot of input from different stakeholders, that causes the delays.
So in an effort to be accommodating, we're also causing delays.
But we want to be fair to our schools and our LEAs rather.
So I think that the memo that shows what state indicators we adopted, what local indicators we adopted, if we could also see a timeline to see if we're giving LEAs sufficient time to complete their LCAP templates with indicators that we have adopted and we're requiring.
parent engagement, some of the other indicators that folks here in the public have addressed.
If we could also incorporate that information, because I'm personally losing sight of all the timelines as well.
They're all overlapping, thanks.
Board member.
Go ahead.
Thank you.
First of all, I'd like to thank the members of CORE that came today to speak to us, and in particular for your energy and efforts in sharing all the good work that you've already done with the CDE staff and with us.
I think there's a lot of learning we can gain from what you've already been through.
That's terrific.
I have one clarification about
the recommendation as regards to foster youth.
We heard from a speaker today who indicated that this was merely a checkbox reporting regarding foster youth, and I did not read it that way.
I read it that the self-assessment would be shared, that it would be made public, that in terms of the foster, I forget the number, is it 10?
Priority 10.
The intent is for... Priority 10.
I'm sorry?
It's priority 10, and then this is the piece that I think brings it to the surface of requiring it to be in a public forum, the discussion about the evidence that they are using to show that they've, how they've assessed their performance in that particular area.
Not just a checkbox, but how they made this assessment.
That's the intent.
That's the intent and that I would agree with, of course.
I do think that Mr. President Kerr's comment about not providing soon enough, perhaps, as many
good examples of ways that schools and districts can better assess parent engagement, student voice, climate, school climate.
Yeah, is a concern, is a problem at this point.
We heard from speakers today who feel as though they're still not being listened to in their schools, parents who feel that they're still not being heard.
I remember Ortiz-Lacombe talked about the potential of some districts or schools having a laissez-faire attitude about school climate assessment.
I think it's really helpful if this work group that Deputy Superintendent Price mentioned can move as quickly as possible to disseminate as many good examples, not just the Healthy Kids Survey, even if
Some of the examples are not perfect, and we know they won't be.
I think the laissez-faire attitude comes when they don't know what to do.
They don't have something that is recommended.
I agree with the flexibility.
I agree with not
demanding one methodology here.
So we need to give them plenty of options.
Because I know if I were running a school right now, I too would be scratching my head.
Now, what's the best way of doing this?
How could I possibly do this well?
So let's help.
Thanks.
I just want to echo the sentiments of a lot of the speakers who also talked about parent engagement like other members of the board have stated.
I am strongly in favor of this incorporation to be definitely part of this accountability system just because speaking as a student, parent engagement is something that is
very, very crucial to a lot of different schools and the fact that some schools have a huge amount of parent engagement and some just don't is unfair for the students and I think a way to quantify that information would be very important and able to help us make future decisions on this board too.
Okay, I guess that concludes board comment and we're ready, no?
I move approval of CD's recommendation.
Want to clarify one more time?
Well, I just want to make sure, because again, the slide says something different than what people see on the screen.
It's the recommendation that's in our item on page two, and it would be, help me with this, items two, three, and four.
Item one was withdrawn.
That had to do with the academic indicator.
That's correct.
Okay.
All those in favor of the motion, raise your hands.
Second.
Is there a second?
All right, raise your hand.
Thank you, that's unanimously approved.
I just wanted to say in closing, today's actions by the board ensures that the academics performance data included when California's new accountability system launches early next year, provides a complete picture of how all students in a school or district perform on the state English and mathematics assessments.
It is important to get this system right from the beginning so parents, educators and the public will have the information they need to see how their schools and districts are doing.
Rather than approving the short-term use of an outmoded approach, the board's action reflects its commitment to leveraging the strengths of our new assessment within our accountability system.
So thank the board for that and
I think we can start on item four for a while, and so why don't we have the presentation on that?
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I'm Jeff Breshears, the director of the local agency system support office.
Item four, the adoption of the proposed revised local control and accountability plan is an action information item.
The CDE recommends that the SPE adopt the proposed revised LCAP and annual update template, which is attachment one, and allow the CDE in collaboration with the SPE staff to make any necessary typographical or formatting corrections as the document is prepared for posting on the CDE website.
As part of the adoption process,
CDE staff and SBE staff will work in conjunction with the Office of Administrative Law to complete the requisite procedures to repeal California Code of Regulations, Title V, Section 15497.5, Local Control and Accountability Plan and Annual Update Template, which is our current LCAP template.
The proposed revised LCAP and annual update template reflects the collaborative efforts of SBE staff, our office, CDE's LCAP support team, CESA, WestEd, and it incorporates suggested revisions from numerous stakeholders, education coalition, and advocacy groups, and builds on input received from the SBE at previous meetings and via CDE's LCAP redesign survey.
Revisions to the LCAP template include both changes to the content and format of the change.
of the plan.
The proposed LCAP is consistent with the design principles approved by the SBE at its May meeting, shown here.
The LCAP sections have been reordered, as well as moved the instructions and guiding questions to an addendum.
The new design promotes ease of reading with more white space and the addition of color, helping to improve the user experience.
And also for clarity, revisions were made to prompts, headings, and instructions, with headings hyperlinked to the applicable instructions.
A plan summary has been added and has been revised from both the drafts presented at the July meeting and also from the revised draft LCAP template provided in the September information memorandum.
The planned actions and services table within the goals, actions, and service section has been modified, and the section three, use of supplemental and concentration grant funds and proportionality,
has been changed both in name, demonstration of increased or improved services for unduplicated pupils, and in the prompts and in the instructions.
These next few slides just show the progression of changes to the plan summary from July to September to the proposed revisions now.
In July it was just one prompt.
In September it moved to more prescriptive prompts.
to the proposed draft now, which includes the ability for LEAs to tell their story, to highlight any aspects of their LCAP, and then review performance, looking at their greatest needs, their greatest performance and performance gaps.
Responsive to the direction given by the SBE at its July meeting, the LCAP template specifically ties to the evaluation rubrics with prompts in the plan summary, as part of the analysis portion in the annual update section, and within the instructions as school districts, charter schools, and county offices of education articulate identified needs to develop specific goals.
Also, in response to concerns raised in the July State Board meeting, our office met with Member Sun, SBE's charter staff, and representatives from the California Charter Schools Association, Charter Schools Development Center, and as a result of this meeting, instructions have been clarified in these areas specific to charter schools.
Within the goals, action, and services sections, LEAs will identify those planned actions and services that will or will not contribute to meeting the increase or improved services requirement.
This identification will facilitate the responses
in the demonstration of increased or improved services for unduplicated pupils in that section and allow reference back to the actions and services rather than having to cut and paste or list those actions and services to meeting the increased or improved services requirement as part of the response in the section.
Besides formatting, the expected annual measurable outcomes and actual outcomes, as well as the planned actions and services and actual actions and services have been placed side by side for ease of comparison.
In the analysis section of the annual update, prompts have been changed to allow LEAs to reflect on the overall implementation and effectiveness of the actions and services to achieve the articulated goal, and it also refers to the evaluation rubrics as part of the analysis process.
In the stakeholder engagement section, this was changed from four narrative responses to two, and a change from vertical to horizontal orientation.
The expected annual measurable outcome table has been reformatted to specifically identify the metrics associated with the goal to identify the baselines from which expected outcomes will be set, and they've been arranged in columns for ease of reading and comparison of the expected growth throughout the three years of the LCAP.
Checkboxes have been added to identify goals and or planned actions and services as new, modified, or unchanged from the previous year, again, as part of the annual update and analysis process.
This will facilitate transparency and accessibility for stakeholders by clearly identifying any changes made to these goals or planned actions and services, particularly during the second and third years of the three-year LCAP.
For actions and services that are not identified by the LEAs contributing to meeting the requirement to increase or improve services for unduplicated students, the LEAs will indicate which student group will benefit from the actions and services and the locations and or grade spans of those actions and services.
Students with disabilities has been added to align with the federal state systemic improvement plan.
For any action the service identified by the LEA is contributing to meeting the requirement to increase or improve services for unduplicated students, the LEA will identify the unduplicated student group or groups being served and will identify the scope of service by indicating either LEA-wide, school-wide, or limited to those unduplicated student groups already identified, and they'll identify the location and or grade spans of those service.
The last section of the LCAP template is demonstration of increase for improved services for unduplicated students.
The section has been revised to allow LEAs to describe how services provided for unduplicated students are increased or improved by the percentage required.
And if the overall increase for improved services include any actions or services being funded and provided on a school-wide or district-wide basis, the LEA will identify each action and service and include the required descriptions supporting that action or service.
Again, I'd like to thank all the stakeholders that have been involved in taking the time to give us input regarding the revised template and for participating in the process.
We certainly have endeavored to make this project a collaborative process.
And while this isn't a perfect template, we believe it's a marked improvement, and we'd be glad to answer any questions that you have.
Okay, thank you for the presentation.
Board member questions.
I think we've been improving this over time, and it's an example of the continuous improvement idea.
We've heard a lot, and this is definitely a step forward.
Right.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
I wasn't part of the original process for designing the first couple of LCAP templates, but I have heard a lot of complaints, so I think that this is addressing some of the complaints that we've heard from our school leaders.
I think that this is a huge improvement, though, from what I've seen, and I appreciate all the work that has gone to redesigning the LCAP template, and that effort to really align it with the evaluation rubrics.
I do have a couple of questions regarding the plan summary.
And again, I appreciate the intent behind the greatest progress and making sure that we highlight some of the best practices and outcomes of our LEAs and the greatest needs.
as well as the performance gaps.
But I have some concerns and some recommendations.
For the greatest needs, it mentions the red and the orange category, which we know is aligning it to the evaluation rubric, which we know is aligning it to the equity report.
I would like us to spell out the word overall performance was identified in the equity report, parentheses, red and orange performance category, so that we have consistency of terminology, and it really shows an intent to align both of these tools.
We're essentially saying it by identifying the red and the orange categories, but what we have that under is equity report, so why not use the terminology that we're using for evaluation rubrics.
Under the performance, I think, again, I had a concern, and I think that this addresses the concern of what happens to those students in the yellow.
They're not really mentioned in the equity report, and we want to make sure that we're able to also move them towards the state target, which is right now the green, and I think we need to be very explicit when we say what is the target that we're aiming towards, and it's that green performance band.
But for this performance band, I think that intra-district gaps, we need to be aware of those, but we're also assuming that that particular district has students in each of those bands.
So if you have students in the blue band, in the green band, looking to performance levels below,
is a good practice because we want to move them to the state benchmark, not the district.
If we have a district that has all students in the yellow, the goal is not to push those students to the yellow.
We need that information to know where the intra-district gaps are happening.
But the goal is to bring them up to the state level, to those state targets that we've identified.
And that's not clear in the performance gaps.
This reads more as an intra-district,
gap analysis versus let's look at our gap analysis and then move them towards the state target.
So that needs, I don't know if that was the intent or if it just needs clarification.
So was that the intent, just to move them to all students?
It is to evaluate at the district level, interdistrict, as far as the performance gaps within the district itself, yes.
So then at what point do we move them towards the state targets?
I don't,
I don't know.
As far as within the LCAP itself is reflective and is a tool of their progression toward continuous improvement, and I don't know how that would be articulated to then move, and the expectation is to move within their plans to move or articulate that expectation within the plan summary.
And I think that's gonna be one of the tensions that I know we're gonna talk about the S.S.
State Plan in January, but there's so many things that we do need to be mindful of, because this is geared towards LEAs, and moving towards that state target, we'll have to identify that timeline in our S.S.
State Plan for schools.
That's different than districts, but,
isn't the goal also to move our students towards a state target at the LEA level?
And if so, that's not explicit here.
But moving our students towards, to narrowing achievement gaps in intra-district analysis, where the district itself may be well below our state target, I don't know if that's what we want to encourage.
Thoughts?
Member Burr, you have your liaison here.
Do you have any thoughts about this?
I think we just sort of have to go back to the original premise of the accountability structure and the status and growth is within LEAs.
I don't know, candidly, I'm gonna look at Dave here, because I know there are people assume that we have picked a target.
I don't know that we have picked a target.
So we're sort of back into this conversation about, and I know my friend Feliz and I disagree about the importance of ESSA, so we won't get into.
And baseball.
And baseball, Dodgers and Giants also.
But we're much friendlier about that.
So, again, I think we probably have to have a more robust discussion back in the accountability.
We'll do that again in January as we talk about growth, et cetera.
And I don't know that the LCAP is necessarily the tool for that conversation, I guess is kind of my thought about it.
The question is whether or not, for purposes in my mind, Feliza, is at the local level
Is this an improved tool?
Does it help walk LEAs through the kinds of considerations they should be thinking about with respect to their goals and their improvement?
I think your question is a bigger one that probably demands more conversation.
Can you clarify the target question though for me, Dave, because I'm confused too.
David Sapp, Deputy Policy Director with State Board.
The concept of a state goal or target is part of the ESSA, the federal law, and so that specific in question, which is several of the indicators required under ESSA, that's a statutory requirement under federal law to include long-term goals for, this is for the assessment indicator and the English learner progress indicator in particular.
And graduation rates, sorry I left one out.
So that is part of the state plan conversation that's actually included in, this will be part of the next item that's discussed, sort of when that part of the conversation will occur.
In terms of the approved methodology for the state indicators in the evaluation rubrics,
the sort of framework for talking about this idea of getting to green that I think that Eric Crane from West said in presenting some of this information, that if you look at progress and improvement over time, that that can serve as sort of the overall performance framework, but the idea of a specific action that this is a state target or goal, the Board hasn't taken that action, and there will need to be some discussion of that in the ESSA context for at least those three indicators.
Go ahead.
So putting the ESSA requirements and mandates aside, I think that as educators, as policy makers, as stakeholders, I think it's to our benefit, or we should be concerned, where are we going?
So we have additional funding, we have an LCAP template, we have students that are underperforming, some students that are overperforming, and that's great, but when I, as a parent,
looking at an LCAP template, where is my district going?
What is guiding our decisions?
Shouldn't it be, where are we heading?
What is our North Star, right?
And so for me saying that, well, that's ESSA, okay, that's a conversation that could be deferred, but when stakeholders are looking at this and they're looking at their performance levels, what is the goal then?
Where are we moving towards if we have no direct,
we don't have a target that they have to meet, what is the direction that we're hoping to, what's the vision, what's the direction here?
Because just saying, hey, we just have to move students, we could be moving them from red to orange and from orange to yellow, and that is continuous improvement, but at some point, we do want to make sure that students are also at the higher end of the spectrum, and if that's not,
stated anywhere, I do worry that continuous improvement does not actually, will take us to achievement.
But it seems to me partly that this is an interaction between the template, which we were considering today, and the rubric, and how those two interact with each other.
Now that we have the rubric, when we did the template the first time, we didn't have the rubric, and that was inherently a problem.
So can you talk a little bit more about how the template and the rubric interact in this draft?
Well, I think it informs their both tools and it informs the development of the tools or development of the LCAP and the goals at the local level based on their evaluation and based on their performance of where they are and where they're going to go and how they're going to get there in incremental steps.
This plan is a three-year plan which allows for some
strategic planning long term, looking where they are and where they want to be in three years and how they're going to get there and evaluate that through both a local evaluation and the evaluation rubrics.
The evaluation rubrics and attorneys can talk about how they will also trigger any technical assistance as far as growth or lack of growth.
But they're tied together to inform at the local level what their needs are and how they're going to progress forward.
Well, where's that on the form?
Can you go back to where that is?
Because you went through it.
It's in the plan summary on page two of the plan summary.
It talks about
Yeah, well, page two, where it talks about the review of performance, the first section is the greatest process.
The second one, progress.
The second one is, it explicitly ties to the LCF rubrics.
Identify any state or local indicator for which overall performance was in the red or orange.
I think Feliza was talking about that a minute ago.
That's the idea, to call it out.
You've looked at your rubric.
In the plan, some.
Yes.
Okay.
Go ahead.
I think you added to my case.
If that is the plan to make it more streamlined, then we should be more consistent with our terminology and our vision.
If the evaluation rubric will be that tool that will help us identify where we want to go with our students and move them towards that state, and right now we just have that green category, then that should be a little more explicit here.
And if somebody picks this up and doesn't know that they're related, that's a problem too.
And other board member comments?
Board member Rucker.
Well, so let's take a look at what it is we actually are doing by approving this template and how we've gotten to this point from where we started.
When we first implemented the LCAP, I remember the most important statement that board member Burr made was that, and I'm going to not say it correctly,
was that we're kind of giving LEAs a pass on what they're doing in developing these LCAPs, not only because it's new, but because they're being asked to write a school plan using a different frame and without the accountability that the rubric would present to them.
to inform some of the goals that they would write, and even in doing the revision from year to year, how that would be informed by evidence developed from the rubric would not be present.
What's different this time is we're going to have an LCAP template and a rubric together, and the idea, or at least the mental model that I have, is that
The rubric will be populated with information that has been developed both by the department and from the local indicators that districts are beginning to begin working on.
and that rubric and those local indicators are now going to inform a better written and better defined set of goals and priorities that are aligned to what the rubric says or indicates and the evidence indicates from their local indicators they should be paying attention to.
That's the big difference this time between how the LCAP was originally developed when we first did the rollout of
the first three-year LCAP and this new one.
And so are districts going to get better at writing the LCAP?
They've had a few years of practice.
And that answer is yes, they're going to get better at it.
Are they going to have the same pass on what they're allowed to pay attention to or not think through?
Well, no.
It's kind of like when I was an elementary teacher and I had a colleague who liked teaching a unit on dinosaurs, even though we taught the sixth grade and our standards were something else.
We have to now be informed by what the evidence says we ought to be paying attention to.
So for all those LCAPs I've read where they wrote these amazing goal statements that 80% of their students are going to be proficient on the assessment by the end of the year,
they will have data in that rubric that says, here's what the evidence is telling you about the assessment itself and about where your students are.
So they will write a better goal statement and they will better identify among their students and their subgroups where their priorities are.
So I'm not as worried about what is going on because our original experience has been they were writing LCAPS uninformed.
Oh, that was not a good word.
They were writing LCAPS without the benefit of a rubric to help them understand what they should be looking at.
Yeah.
Can you go to the end?
Go ahead, comment on that then.
I think also just in terms of the action that the Board is taking is that this is a statutory, the Board was given the responsibility by statute to approve a template for the local accountability plans.
And part of that statutory mandate includes that it is locally determined goals and identifying the actions and services to implement those goals and the supporting expenditures.
There's that separate part of the law when it was passed in 2013, which is the state accountability tool, which is the evaluation rubrics, which the board has approved, that includes these performance standards, requires that data be analyzed at the student group level, and ultimately for purposes of assistance and support within the state accountability system, student group performance is what's determinative for state accountability purposes.
And so in some ways just sort of to focus on the plan summary itself, this was I think responsive to some feedback at the July meeting from the board members saying these are two tools that are required by statute.
The statute didn't necessarily from an implementation perspective explain how they will be useful and used together to support this local improvement process and to also support state accountability.
So this is responsive to that direction, to try to provide some coherence in terms of the use of these two tools at the local level.
But also, I think, and just to add to what Jeff said earlier, to respond to a number of the concerns or criticisms that I think were expressed over the last several years of implementation, and in particular, this question about performance gaps is directly responsive to a number of concerns that have been expressed
is there differentiation in terms of setting goals or tracking progress on metrics where there are disparities within districts?
Is that inquiry occurring locally, and is that conversation occurring with local stakeholders?
That's sort of a preliminary step to then, if there is a disparity at the local level, then there's this question about what's the goal of getting all students, including narrowing or closing that disparity over time?
So this prompt here, this performance gaps prompt, is actually getting at a different question from the equity report in the evaluation rubrics, which was looking at individual student groups on the overall performance standards.
This is specifically prompting the inquiry about at the local level, are there disparities that we need to look at in terms of how we're planning our actions and services?
Because if all students are doing poorly,
the response to how you do it in terms of your action services might look different than if the overall performance is looking pretty good, but there are a handful of student groups that are really far behind.
So there is a difference.
This is not intended to duplicate the equity report from the evaluation rubrics.
And in fact, some of the feedback that stakeholders provided on the earlier September version
that used a label that was equity here, was that that was in fact confusing because it is not the identical inquiry.
It's actually prompting a different inquiry that can support the planning process.
So I just wanted to provide that clarification that it's grounded in the statutory responsibility that the board has
that this is the local accountability plan, which is separate from the evaluation, which was the state accountability tool.
But the board has provided direction to staff to provide some linkage and coherence for local implementation, and also to try to be responsive to some of the concerns or critiques to some of the challenges in implementation thus far.
So I hope that provides a little clarification, but I just wanted to provide it.
That was very helpful.
If I may, Mr. President, just say we can look into January as to how to clarify or further develop some of the questions and responses.
I was going to ask Glenn Price if you had any thoughts to add to that great report we just had in terms of the multiple goals and structures.
Before he speaks, can you put the annual update up there?
You went through this really fast.
That's another place you can get at these issues.
Okay, so, Jesus, I can't read any of that.
I mean, that's why I didn't get it.
What's in there?
The bottom prompt reads, describe any changes made to this goal, expected outcomes, metrics, or actions and services to achieve this goal as a result of the analysis and analysis of the data provided in the LCFF evaluation rubrics.
as applicable, and then identify where those changes can be found within the LCAP.
So again, it leaks back to using the evaluation rubrics as a tool, looking at the data, where are you as an LEA, where have you gone, where are you going, and what are the evaluation rubrics showing you, and then how are you taking that into effect to inform either a revision of a goal or to write a new goal to get where you need to be.
As Member Rucker said, now they have this information
to be able to.
Provide that map to get to move forward.
Seems to me Glenn wants to comment.
It seems to me that's more where this interaction might take place, and we had some concerns with the.
Prior past effectiveness of the annual update.
I had a lot higher expectations for
So just wanted to further comment a little bit on the proposed plan summary and the questions from Board Member Ortiz-Licon, and just to compliment the comments of David Stapp, which I thought were tremendously on point.
What we're trying to do in the plan summary, and let's recall again that this is a new feature in the LCAP.
Many LEAs have already been doing plan summaries very effectively, but now we're asking for every LEA, when they complete their local control and county building plan, to include a plan summary which we think will be
an excellent communications device for broad segments of the public that may not want to dive into the entirety of the LCAP.
In terms of the North Star, I think we're providing that opportunity in that first box, the story, which we're basically saying, tell us your story.
Tell us what your North Star is for your community.
and how you plan to respond to that, and what are the highlights in your LCAP where you can be addressing that?
So providing that capacity to really articulate for the community and for the state at large, where are you headed?
Then in the second part of the proposed plan summary, and I think it's important, as Dave was getting at too, to view this as a totality, as opposed to the different components.
Starting out, tell us where you've made your greatest progress, because we know that it's important to be celebrating accomplishments and celebrating successes as we move forward.
And then to look at the greatest needs and the performance gap,
as a combination, so as Dave was articulating, in the greatest needs, we're specifically asking LEAs to reflect back to us, and it's not abrogating any of the responsibilities that Dave articulated around the use of the LCF evaluation rubrics, but tell us where your greatest needs are in terms of those areas where you have red or oranges on your evaluation rubrics, and what you intend to do about that.
But we knew that then precisely the equity issue wouldn't get entirely addressed unless we added a third box, and this evolved over time in terms of the performance gaps.
And it's equally relevant for those districts that are performing very well and that have many greens and blues as those that have a lot of yellows and oranges.
because even in the greens and blues, tell us where you have groups or areas, indicators that are trailing behind and that you want to improve on through your actions in the LCAP.
So I think when we look at it all together,
It provides that capacity for LEA to tell the story.
As Jeff mentioned, is it perfect?
No, it's not.
We recognize that, and we know that this, we want to be continuing to look at it, but we think it provides a great step forward for our LEAs.
I continue to think the annual update is where this concern ought to be located, not in a planned summary.
I mean, that's, if you look at the plan update, and it,
You know, I guess the issue is it seems to imply what you're talking about.
I guess what you're concerned about is, uh, the lack of state targets in the plan update because what I read is the local set local goals and then they and the update they consider how they how they did on those.
And so it is, uh, there are, you know, the update should produce that kind of thing around the local goals and whether they're reaching them.
And there is that capacity in the annual update, and I know it's not legible on the screen, but the full template is included in your packet as an attachment at full size.
And within the actions and services, there's what you proposed, and then as you update, an update around how did you do?
What was the actual performance in relationship to that?
The other piece here that we probably also want to keep in mind is the tremendous opportunity that we have as a state right now through the investment that's being made in the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence in terms of a lot of the support and actual continuous improvement that will be made will come out of the professional learning and development that takes place as part of the collaborative's work with LEAs around the state.
Board Memorandum.
I, too, want to thank you, Dave, for your explanation.
It's great.
So you're going to give your phone number to every principal and every superintendent so you can give that sort of level of clarity.
I'm joking, of course, but at the same time, I do think this is a real concern, a real problem, that as we sit here, we need Dave and Glenn and all the rest of you to explain this to us, and I'm thinking about the poor school administrators out there that are going to have to somehow, as I think it was Martha from AXA said, pull from,
weeks and weeks and weeks ago, months ago, all these different iterations that we've been through.
I think the department did a wonderful job when SBAC came out of explaining what this creature is.
And I suspect that now's the time that we've gotten far enough along with the accountability system, with the LCAP, with LCFF and all the rest, it's time to have a concise,
informational packet that parents and the students and the administrators could all sort of refer to in a clear way.
How do these pieces work together now?
How does this vision come together?
And once again, I think it was Martha that suggested this.
I think that's a brilliant idea.
And it's been, I know that within the,
the LCAP template, you've got all sorts of instructions, right, and all sorts of information.
But at the same time, something sort of overarching that pulls the pieces together, I think could really be answering a lot of these questions for a lot of people that don't have the benefit of data and all the rest of you.
Thanks.
Point well taken, and we definitely intend to do that.
We also intend to reconvene the Superintendent's Accountability and Continuous Improvement Task Force, which brings together many stakeholders in order to be able to push out and problem solve around those kinds of issues and communication strategies as they develop.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
And again, I want to emphasize that I think this is a huge improvement.
I know a lot of work has gone into this.
It's been a collaborative process.
I think that my only concern remains that even if a district has the flexibility to set their own performance targets,
how do we ensure that students across the state of California are all held to some level of high performance and that they are actually moving towards that, not just making some improvement, but making substantial improvement so they're well prepared for college and career from K-12, that we have those high expectations and that something's driving this.
Now, maybe it's just my concern, if you agree, wink twice as you come.
because I'm not hearing any echoes, but I think that it's a concern that I don't know, and maybe I'm just thinking in terms of the previous system, there was, for good or bad, there was a state target, and a lot of the work was emphasized in how do we move students towards that target.
And in the absence of that, moving students, in my opinion, is great, may not be enough.
Thank you.
Yeah, just just to clarify this, you know, my own edification here as well.
I mean, the annual update says use actual annual measurable outcome data, including performance data from the LCFF evaluation rubrics as applicable.
And there's several under that.
But one of them is
describe the overall effectiveness of the action services to achieve the articulated goal as measured by the LEA.
So it is, you know, that's really, we never had anything like that before because we never had a rubric.
So the annual update was sort of toothless.
It really didn't do much.
So it has at least we have here for local goals, not state targets of this linkage that we've been seeking.
So I just want to clarify that for the board.
All right.
Any further board comments or Yeah, I know there's public comment, but it's five after 12.
So maybe we should we should adjourn for lunch.
Okay, if we want to take the public comment, let's go ahead.
Could we have the following people please line up?
Kelly May, Doug McCray, Patty Scripter, Brian Rivas, Sheila Whitley, Jesse Aguilar, Lorraine Richards, Ken Burt,
Angela DeRamos, Estella Mu, Martha Alvarez, Sandy Mendoza, John Elfeld, Liz Guillen, Tia Nguyen, Michelle Parise, Sergio Luna, Eric Premack, Terry Burns, Sarah Lillis, Colin Miller, and Samantha Tran.
Ready?
Good afternoon, I'm Doug McRae, retired educational measurement specialist.
The words local control and accountability are fundamentally in conflict.
The LCAP template is essentially a strategic planning process, not an accountability exercise.
The title LCAP is not unlike the title SARC, for School Accountability Report Card, which is a data transparency program rather than an accountability program.
In this country, we don't allow students to self-assign grades.
We don't allow employees to self-determine compensation.
Rather, these accountability functions are carried out by people responsible for judging student employee performance.
Strategic planning programs are good for districts.
Both financial decisions and curriculum instruction decisions should be left to local control.
But statewide assessment and accountability require decisions at the state level, not the local level, to generate required comparability for districts and schools for the entire state.
The sooner we accept these distinctions, in my view, the better.
Thank you.
Patty Scripter, California State PTA.
Regarding the stakeholder engagement piece, we believe that the additions to the template are an improvement, but we suggest that the description for stakeholder engagement include the process used for the PAC, the DAC, and the DLAC.
That's the question we get most often at the local level because of the confusion between the LCAP committee and the statutory requirements for the PAC, DAC, and DLAC, and we think this would contribute to a more transparent
process.
We also think that you should add a box between the process and the impact about what the feedback was.
This is a great communication tool and it's a way to value the input received is to report that out as part of the process.
I led with that, and I'm going to go back and say we think this has been a great process.
It's definitely an improvement.
The reordered process is more accessible information.
We support the addition of the plan summary.
Again, that's more accessible to parent.
It's a great way to communicate the story.
We think for the performance gaps that the wording should be strengthened to actions that narrow and close gaps, not just address gaps.
And we also think the addition of the budget summary is key to having parents and stakeholders understand how the funds are spent, and it increases the transparency of the process.
Thank you.
Mr. President, Brian Rivas on behalf of the Education Trust West.
Couple of points.
We want to thank you and your staff for continuing to work on this.
We see improvement.
We know it's been a challenge.
But I know that, I think Member Holiday was being a bit facetious, but I do want to lift up that I think it's a problem that you all didn't understand the template until Mr. Sapp explained it to you.
I think that confusion and lack of clarity has been a problem that has plagued the LCAP.
and I think it's representative of a problem that we all should continue to work on.
And with regard to this gap section in particular, I think we agree with Member Ortiz-Licon that it's a problem to have something in here that suggests if you had a district that was made up of white and Latino students with a very low level of achievement for everyone, thus having a small gap, that you don't have an equity problem and that everything's okay.
So we would ask that you try to align this with all the other stuff that you're doing on equity and send consistent messages.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We're extremely appreciative of the work that CDE staff, Mr. Brashears in particular, spent a good deal of time with us looking at very detailed comments and made a lot of helpful clarifications here.
And we're super appreciative of that.
We think that this is a significant step forward.
We think that additional clarity, if you really wanna make a leap forward, you gotta go back and open up Pandora's box and look at the 22 priorities and sort through those.
Absent being willing to do that, I think they've pushed this about as far, pretty close to as far as we're going to get.
And we're really very much thankful for that.
Thanks.
President Kurse, Superintendent Torlakson, board members, Estella Mu with the California Teachers Association.
On behalf of the California Teachers Association, I want to thank the board, the department of your respective staffs for the continuing efforts to engage all stakeholders and improve to the LCAP and the annual update template.
We have known from the inception of the LCFF that this
This effort will take, in the words of President Kurz, patience, persistence, and humility.
Overall, we believe the revised template is improved in many respects and worthy of approval.
In particular, CTA believes the new plan summary will help districts, charter schools, and county offices of education tell their stories succinctly and highlight strengths and areas in need of attention.
The new instructions will prompt reflection on LCAP goals, local assessments, stakeholder feedback, and the evaluation rubrics, with attention to the results of increases and improvements in services for our students from low-income families, English learners, and foster youth.
The graphical improvements and streamlined layout of the template should also make it easier for stakeholders to read and understand.
As the new template is implemented, and we collectively strive to meet the needs of all of our students, we expect additional refinements may be needed, particularly to ensure stakeholders receive feedback on how their input was considered.
We believe that the template before you is a good starting point.
If paired with high quality training, capacity building, and stakeholder engagement, the improved form and instructions should result in more effective planning and continuous improvement practices.
We thank you very much.
Good afternoon, Sandra Morales with the County Superintendent's Association.
First, I'd like to echo the comments from Stela Vieux in expressing appreciation for the stakeholder engagement during this process.
When the CDE set up to revise the template, the one thing that we ask is that it was practitioner-driven, that let's learn from those experiences and improve this template as we expect that this will continue to improve over time.
So much of what you see in here in this template reflects a lot of the feedback that we received from those practitioners.
So we just want to let you know that county offices stand ready to support districts on their development of the template, working with the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence to ensure that
Our messages are aligned, that there's no confusion in the field, and just like Board Member Holliday mentioned that when the SBAC was rolled out, the communication was successful and everybody understood what it was, that is our goal here too.
County offices with the collaborative and with the help of other management education associations, we hope that we can achieve that as well.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Marta Alvarez-Axa.
So similar to other speakers, we want to thank the staff and Jeff Breshears and everyone else who was involved over the past six months in developing the revised LCAP.
As it was indicated by prior speakers, even though it's not perfect, it's an improvement in the layout and the content.
We at AXA appreciate the better integration and alignment between the evaluation rubrics references and what needs to happen whenever there's a stakeholder process in talking about goals and priorities and services.
I do want to point out two comments from AXA and two recommendations for your consideration in the future.
One is we ask the board to have commitment to not make any changes for at least the next two or three years.
This is the third LCAP we have seen.
Our members need time to be able to really embrace it, to be able to work with what we have, and so at least try to, we'll learn from the field as they continue to work on the revised LCAP for 17-18, but please stop making changes to it.
The second piece is in order for our members to embrace the LCAP as a planning tool, thinking about continuous improvement over the long term,
It really needs to have, you need to have a conversation about the streamlining of other plans, LEA, school site plans, SARC, because that's a bigger monster to tackle, but it's really problematic if we have this as more of a compliance tool instead of being able to streamline everything.
Thank you.
Afternoon, Terry Burns with the California School Boards Association, and I'll associate myself with all of Ms.
Alvarez's remarks.
We believe this is an improved template.
While likely no shorter than the current version, we believe that the inclusion of introductory sheets that summarize the focus and the vision will be really helpful.
to communicate this to our parents.
We appreciate the inclusion of a section that allows us to celebrate successes, as well as recognize areas in need of improvement.
We believe that it meets your principles of transparency, simplicity, clarity, and efficacy for planning.
And we appreciate your timely adoption so that we can start doing the data transfers that are necessary.
Capacity remains a concern, particularly in small districts, to complete the document.
and for all LEAs to effectively communicate what it means to stakeholders.
I must take issue with Member Lincoln's, Ortiz-Lincoln's concern, expression that schools have more money.
LCFF is still not sufficiently funded.
Funding is likely to be flat for the next three years, and we're facing incredible costs from instructional materials, adoptions, and retirement costs.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Sarah Lillis with EdVoice.
I want to thank member Ortiz-Lacogne for raising up these issues, because I think fundamentally the LCAP, the LCFF rubrics are tools to meet our constitutional obligation to ensure an equitable opportunity to learn, and that's sort of where we keep coming back.
And I think remembering when we're talking about gaps, fundamentally we're talking about gaps from where we are and where we want all of our students to be.
And so while we recognize the importance of looking at intradistrict gaps,
Fundamentally, by defining that section of the performance gaps only as two performance levels apart, we're losing an opportunity to highlight subgroups that have huge gaps between where they are and where we want them to be, because the previous box is about overall performance, rather than, again, highlighting subgroups that are red and orange.
So we appreciate the conversation, and hopefully we continue to use this as a tool for equity.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
First of all, I want to thank Jeff Breshears and the staff for modeling the type of stakeholder engagement that we expect from all our LEAs.
He's been very collaborative in this process, and I think the resulting template and instructions reflect that in a very positive way.
So we're very pleased with the new improvements to the template.
Obviously we'll know more and have more feedback as we start putting pencil to paper and working with the tool, but we're very encouraged with the work that's been done so far.
So in the interest of good policy and lunch before you, we encourage you to move swiftly to adopt the staff recommendation.
Thank you.
Hello, Sandy Mendoza, Families in Schools, and I appreciate hearing that earlier comment about not changing anything anymore because it is important for people to get used to what we're working with, especially for parents so that they get accustomed to what they're dealing with over time.
But at the same time, if that's what we want to do, we need to really make this work and make it right getting out of the chute here.
So let's make sure it's right before we start messing with it.
The other thing I want to say is that we are appreciative of the instruction to call different committees, such as the PAC, the ELAC, and SSC for further input.
We also appreciate adding a citation for making sure that translation of materials are in the language that they need to be for other materials, and also that the LCAP
includes instructions for, well, we think there should be instruction for how would parents address getting the material if they don't have internet.
So what kind of instructions would that include?
Thank you.
Samantha Tran with Children Now, and I want to echo the theme of appreciating Jeff and the team's work to really engage stakeholders on this process.
We like the design elements, it's moving in the right direction, and also appreciate the intentionality of trying to connect it with the evaluation rubric.
We'll see how that unfolds as it plays out at the local level, but you know,
As we've seen from previous plans, the data is not always grounded in all the different gaps that are present in a district, and this gives us an opportunity to look in more standardized ways across districts about how kids are doing and to elevate equity in that conversation.
We continue to have concerns about whether or not we're
ultimately going to be able to understand how supplemental and concentration dollars are being used in their totality and know that there's some conversations about, you know, how do we think about the account code structure?
How do we integrate that and link that?
And that I think that's an important conversation for us moving forward as a state.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, John Apfeldt from Public Advocates and the Equity Coalition.
Number one, we appreciate the budget summary and hopefully we won't see any more instances where districts have
9% of their LCFF dollars reflected in the LCAP, but have a much greater percentage, and we appreciate maintaining the language.
This is supposed to be a comprehensive planning tool, not a sliver of what you're doing as a district.
Appreciate the identification, the notion that every, each district-wide and school-wide,
Supplemental concentration expenditure needs to be identified and justified in the LCAP.
These instructions make that much clearer.
We agree that we don't still have enough transparency around the supplemental concentration.
It's not a one-to-one categorical get that, but it's also not a get out of proportionality free card, and that we do need a better tracking of
the effort that was spent and not spent and that needs to be carried over.
Thanks.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, representing CABE and Californians Together, and I just want to support the comments that John Ethold said with regards to identification of supplemental and concentration funds.
The information that is on page 11 regarding those funds should also be carried over to page four within the budget plan summary under the projected LCF funds.
In addition, I appreciate Ms.
Ortiz-Lincon's comments regarding state targets for subgroups.
We need to know.
where we are and where we want to be, not only intradistrict, interdistrict, but with regards to whether we're meeting state goals.
We need to highlight subgroup academic performance, not only in the red and orange, but perhaps also in the yellow.
Thank you.
Okay, that completes the comments.
Board Member Sun.
I just want to make a,
maybe a final comment before we move forward.
I've been severely silent through this item, not because I haven't had a lot of thoughts, in fact, so many thoughts.
And filled it out.
Yeah, that I've had trouble thinking about what to say.
So I think the tact I'm going to take is from someone who actually has to do this LCAP.
I think I'm the only one around here.
And in hearing, I really appreciate David's description of this, because I think as we are talking about wording and wordsmithing pieces of this, I think we need to step back and think about we are building a system here to get at our constitutional obligation to serve all students.
And I will tell you that this system that we are creating as one person who operates a school, this is,
making me, my school, more transparent, our information more transparent than it has ever, more transparent than our charter, more transparent than our WASC report, more transparent than our annual audit that we have, this really outlines to our stakeholders what we're doing.
And this system we're creating between the rubrics and this LCAP plan is truly a
great system for getting us to that accountability pieces of it.
So while we're working on all the little bits and pieces, I don't think we need to not lose sight of that we are, we dismantled another system and we are rebuilding it to be stronger and to also allow LEAs and schools,
some flexibility to be able to achieve those goals.
And I think that balance of setting the standard, and we have a lot of work still to do that, but at the same time, allowing that local flexibility is really the system that we need.
And I think we should look at that and be very proud of the progress we have made in that area.
Thank you.
Yeah, I wanted to comment on this financial transparency issue, the supplemental and concentration grants.
I don't think the solution to finding out, you know, what's going on fiscally lies with the LCAP.
because I don't think the LCAP can do it.
The underlying systems are, in my view, broken.
The budget and accounting systems are in huge categories.
Administration, student services, instruction.
So if we had a really good accounting system that underlies the LCAP,
we could do much better, I think, on where the money actually goes.
And so I think the way to really get at this is not more fiddling with the LCAP, but trying to address the underlying accounting and budgeting categories called SAS and so on that are out there, because they are really opaque.
And I don't think we can remediate that problem through, you know, LCAP stuff.
And so I disagree with some of the presenters that that is the way to go.
I would ask them to help us think about broader financial changes.
WestEd is working on this, and there may be ways to advance it and make it work.
But it's a deeper problem.
In my view, the LCAP is taking the rap for the fact that the accounting systems and so on we ought to tie to are really very general, very opaque, and to me, hide the ball in ways that we're suffering from.
So that's my own observation.
There are some people, as I say, WestEd is working on this.
Others are working on this issue.
And my view is there's limits to how much we can do through the LCAP without more fundamental change in the budgeting categories.
So with that, any more board comment?
And then we're ready.
All right, so just two comments.
One, thanks to the department and Jeff and all your leadership and input and watching this process, and I appreciate the stakeholders coming forward and support the CTA comments about with additional capacity building and articulation and engagement.
This is a much improved process.
I think nothing is perfect, but I'm hearing from lots of people that we need to move forward.
do what we've, use what we've gotten and then do it for a couple years and see how that works.
I just would say some of the extra boxes that for explanation which are really going to help I think in sharing what Member Sung is saying about transparency and sharing with the public what this means.
I just want to support Ax's comment to continue the work.
I know CED is working on trying to align SARCs and SPSAs and LEA plans and having written many of those and knowing some are looked at more than others.
It'd just be nice if all the things connected as we're moving toward a coherent single system
and I appreciate that all of us are committed that way.
Deputy Superintendent Price has assured me that it's an ongoing process and there are some progress toward it, but I think we need to keep moving that ball down the field as far as wanting this to work and be connected and guide all of the work, so just a support.
And with that, I move approval of the CD recommendation.
Second.
Second by Burr.
Okay.
All right.
Any further?
No further board discussion.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Thank you.
Approved unanimously.
And so the board will adjourn for lunch.
We'll be back in three quarters of an hour.
So it is 1.15.
Okay, the board will reconvene.
I have 636.
Right.
So we'll begin now with item five, which is the update on the Every Student Succeeds Act.
So good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson I think is probably coming.
You're not on.
I am on, but it's been super low all day just from the audience I've noticed.
There he is.
All right, good afternoon, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, board members, I'm Barbara Murchison as the state lead here at the Department of Education.
The CDE recommends that the board give authority to Superintendent Torlakson to submit with President Kirst a joint response to the proposed regulations for Title One supplement not supplant to United States Department of Education on or before November 7th.
The CDE also recommends that the board take additional action as necessary and appropriate.
So before we talk about the plan, I want to spend a few minutes providing you with a brief update on the status of ESSA proposed regulations.
Long story short, we are still waiting for all three sets of proposed regulations to be finalized.
Proposed regulations on Title I Supplement Not Supplant were published in the Federal Register on September 6th and are open for a 60-day public comment period that closes on Monday, November 7th, 2016.
This is the third of three sets of proposed regs that the U.S.
Department of Education plans to finalize before the end of the year.
The first two sets of regulations addressed accountability state plans and data reporting and assessments.
In July, the board authorized President Kirst to sign joint letters with Superintendent Torlakson to provide the state's response to those sets of proposed regs.
The response to the proposed accountability state plans and data reporting regulations was submitted on August 1st, and the response to the proposed assessment regulations was submitted on September 9th.
Both of those letters are available on the department as a webpage.
Department and board staff have been working together to review and analyze the proposed regulations and are preparing a joint response to be submitted upon your approval to again authorize President Kirst to sign on to a letter.
As noted in the agenda item,
Staff believes that the regulations exceed federal statute and that the elements contained in the proposed regulations are contrary to California's shift to greater local control centered on providing LEAs the ability to better meet the needs of their most vulnerable students.
Further, ensuring equity and resources for high-need students and ensuring that Title I funds will be supplemental to state funds can be achieved under the state's current structure without federal intrusion.
So again, those letters are available on the CDESO webpage, as are all the proposed regulations.
So, as we've discussed previously, we can't finalize a plan without final regulations, but we continue to move forward with plan development using the information available to us.
Recall that our current understanding of the structure of the ESSA Consolidated State Plan is based on the proposed regulations around submission of state plans.
The draft plan provided in this item is built around those proposed regulations.
We don't anticipate that this structure will change once the regulations are finalized, though it is likely that some of these elements may be removed.
So as the regulations change, the template and the structure of the plan may change.
Still, our current understanding is that states will be required to submit a plan using a template organized around the six sections listed on this screen.
Long-term goals and measurements of interim progress, consultation and coordination, challenging academic standards and academic assessments, accountability, support, and improvement for schools, supporting excellent educators, and supporting all students.
I'm making a point to share this with you again because as we're talking to our colleagues around the state about this plan, some folks are under the impression that there will be a Title I plan, and then a Title II plan, and then a Title III plan, and California's Consolidated State Plan is obviously going to address all of the programmatic requirements under each of these titles, but it will do so in a consolidated, coherent way organized into these six sections.
So I'm sure this will come as a great surprise to all of you, but the plan development timeline has changed again since I last saw you.
I think this may be the last one, though.
I'm feeling confident.
I left the asterisk up.
No.
Just in case.
But this new timeline does plan for a July submission date.
Again, we are waiting for final regs, and we just can't finish a plan without final regs.
So this timeline lays out for you, and I'm gonna explain just briefly, our plan is to bring three successive drafts to you over the next few meetings.
So this meeting, we have the very first draft of the state plan, second draft coming in January with new elements as we have more information, and then a complete plan will come to you in March.
By then we anticipate that we will have final regulations and we will have had lots of time for robust stakeholder engagement and more board conversation.
We like this new strategy because it allows us not to spend too much time with hypothetical information.
Although we originally wanted to bring a plan to you in November, why would we spend your time in the time of stakeholders talking about things that may or may not actually happen?
As you saw in attachment two of the September ESSA item, the plan requires us to address a lot of material.
This new strategy allows us to chunk that entire plan into three separate drafts so that you and all of California stakeholders can learn as we go about the different elements and have more manageable pieces of information.
And this also allows us to have much more time for good stakeholder engagement.
So for each draft, the CPAG will first hear the elements in the draft and be able to provide feedback.
We can take that into account as we prepare the item to come to you, which is a draft.
We get more feedback from you and then we put the plan up.
Each draft of the plan will have its own little public comment period so that we can engage folks in the work that's happening and seek their feedback about what they think is great and what they think might need a little updating.
So the expanded timeline in attachment one of this item actually shows that detail for each draft.
CPAG first, board then sees the plan, and then a public comment period so the public can comment on the plan.
By March, we will have a complete plan with all of the elements presented, and then we will get your feedback, and you're okay to go ahead and start the 30-day public comment period on the plan, and then we'll convene the CPAG, and they will provide comment or feedback to you on the comment, and we are optimistic that in May, we will be able to bring to you a final plan, suggestions for what of the stakeholder feedback should be incorporated,
And then we'll clean that up and send that to EG in July.
And then we'll all go on a nice long vacation, right?
Okay, I will.
The other thing we like about this, it gives us a little extra time to spend more time with some of the more challenging elements, like how are we going to do our technical assistance?
What are our state systems of support?
How are we going to use ESSA resources to support state priorities?
Those will be coming later rather than sooner.
So building upon that strategy and timeline, the plan, the draft plan that's been provided to you is attachment two today.
contains the consultation and coordination section, the challenging academic standards and academic assessment section, and a number of the program-specific requirements that ESSA requires us to address.
The other state plan sections that will be coming to you in January and March are also listed here on this slide.
I should be super clear here, though.
We are not asking for approval of any of these drafts.
Nobody needs to, well, no, the final one, of course.
We're not asking for approval of today's draft.
All of these elements that are shared today and in the item are subject to change as we get more information and as we do a little bit more work on pulling the programs together.
So as I mentioned, we will have opportunities for stakeholder engagement throughout these next few months.
For this draft and for the January draft, we will be making available a toolkit for local use.
One of the things we heard from stakeholders when we did phase one of stakeholder engagement is they thought it would be helpful if they had the tools available to do the engagement around the plan with or without CDE staff.
So our toolkit will involve plan excerpt,
a narrated PowerPoint about that section of the plan, and then some survey questions that are tied to that section so we can gather feedback.
We'll do a webinar each time, letting people know that the toolkit is available and showing them how to use it.
and we will bring that feedback with you throughout this process.
In March, after we have a complete plan, we will again make the toolkit available, do all of those activities, but we will go out and do a full face-to-face push with the regional meetings that we did in phase one, so we have the opportunity to hear from people and talk through those questions in person.
So last time we met I talked a little bit about ESSA providing states the opportunity to think big across programs and use resources to support the larger state vision.
The plan is not, you know, we refer to this as braiding of funds.
The plan in front of you right now doesn't really represent a lot of braiding because we don't really have enough information in here to really braid things together.
Those of you who are familiar with braiding know that if you braid with just one section of hair, that's actually a ponytail.
But I want to make it really clear for people who are concerned that we are not like putting one, two, three, and four and using these ideas more coherently and in a more holistic fashion right now.
That is coming, it is our intent, and we're working very hard to figure out how to make this work, to as much as possible have integration across the programs, because we think that will probably result in better outcomes.
And then another thing that we talked about last time when we talked about the strategic direction, I think it was member Holiday who said perhaps if we concentrate our efforts in a one direction instead of in eight directions or ten, depending on how many state priorities you're thinking about, we are likely to have more maximize our in our output.
and our results.
So building upon that board discussion in September, we've been in conversation with various stakeholders around how we might use ESSA resources to build the capacity of teachers and leaders to successfully implement state standards.
Of course, implementation of standards is not a one-size-fits-all proposition.
As we laid out in our state systemic improvement plan, we know that our students are multi-dimensional people with multi-dimensional needs,
So given the equity focus nature of the ESSA, we propose to leverage ESSA resources to build the capacity of California educators to address the needs of these complex children that come to school every day and support the success of each of them as individuals to attain state standards.
A memorandum that describes this emerging strategic direction and offers three of the models that were shared in attachment three of the September ESSA board item was posted to the CPAG October 13th agenda webpage.
Thus far, feedback on the memo has been very positive.
We plan to continue to share this memo with stakeholders over the coming months, and we'll bring more information to you on this topic in January for feedback and direction.
Unless we hear differently from you between now and March, the complete March draft of the plan will reflect a focus on supporting the implementation of state standards.
So,
All of that said, this slide lists the elements included in the first draft of the ESSA State Plan, provided as attachment two of the item.
Again, this is a first draft.
We're not asking you to take action on this draft, but we are looking for your feedback and any inputs and thoughts, knowing that it is likely to change in small ways as we move towards that complete plan in March.
Information on these plan elements was presented at the October 13th Joint CPAG State Board Study Session, and a number of my colleagues are here with me today ready to share information regarding the plan elements or respond to your questions.
So I'm going to stop there.
This is a much longer presentation, but
We want to make sure we have enough time for your questions and comments.
And if you have specific questions about specific programs, obviously our directors, I think they're probably half dozen behind me, are ready to help and perhaps do many presentations upon request.
Okay.
Ortiz Lacombe and then board member Williams.
Hi.
Can I ask a couple, we have this in thing about being from Southern California, so when I looked at you, I just, I remembered.
I'm going to be very light with my questions here.
So my question is more on the protocol of how we receive the feedback.
So for example, there's so many elements to this plan, and when it's presented to different stakeholders, is it presented by their area of expertise, where the ELI work group would be commenting on Title III, and where others would be providing feedback on Title I.
Again, because there's so many little pieces that we have to consider, I'm also concerned that if we wait until March to have discussions, and some of these discussions, really, if the regulations stay, some of them will stay as they are.
I know that we want to table the conversation because there are draft regulations, but there are some regulations that I anticipate will still be
in some form present some tension between what we have in California and what's being asked.
And again, I'll go back to the example of this being a school-based or school-level accountability system where the California system is based on the LEAs, and this having a state-determined timeline where our LEA plan doesn't.
So I don't,
see how a system, a coherent system of accountability where the schools have to adhere by a timeline but not the LEAs, how that would work.
And so I want to make sure that we do have sufficient time where as a board we're able to discuss what are those tensions or potential tensions and how do we resolve them.
There's also some information that I didn't see here.
We're doing a lot with the LPAC.
We're doing a lot with our integrated frameworks.
We do have a Spanish assessment that's under development.
I didn't see that included here, so I'm wondering if that's coming later or if there was a reason for not including that at this point.
Thank you.
So I think we will actually bring to you in January some more information around our way forward with plan alignment.
As you know, this is a sticky piece where how do we really make a single coherent system.
where folks aren't doing one thing over here and another thing over here, but here are these expectations here and here.
We've got to really map that puzzle out and put those pieces together and bring that to you for your consideration, and I am optimistic that that will happen in January, or the conversation around where we think we are, right?
in January, we'll be able to share something about that with you to begin that conversation before March, where we're actually going to have to say this is what we think and put that out for public comment.
Regarding the LPAC ELA ELD standards, one of our design principles, I think the assessment section and Michelle Center, who I think is behind me, will probably nod if that's true,
Our standards and assessment section probably does talk about the LPAC.
The last time I saw it, there was some conversation about it.
At this point, things about standards, one of our plan design principles was to try and not go too far above and beyond what is requested.
All right, so this draft plan is organized using the structure of the draft template, which is organized around the draft regs.
You see how many times we're already in draft?
But I was just speaking with someone about the challenging academic standards and assessment section doesn't really ask us to go into detail about tell us about your curriculum frameworks or how you plan to get there.
At least in its current state, it doesn't.
So if there are pieces missing, it's likely because the plan hasn't asked us to share about that.
Board member Williams.
I'm going to be interested in what we do with science and NGSS and the need to support professional development for teachers at each grade span with NGSS.
And in addition, especially since my understanding is the Math and Science Partnerships opportunity we don't have anymore, and that was used pretty extensively by districts.
So this is now the time when we're gonna pilot in 2017 the,
in GSS state summative test and over the next four years roll that out.
So if we don't put some investment into professional learning for our science, teachers of science, I mean this is the time that it becomes critical from here through there.
So I'm gonna be interested in how we address that, because there are plenty of opportunities, as I see it, within ESSA for science in terms of it being part of a well-rounded education, 21st century education, all of that.
In addition, even though this is newer, computer science is now explicitly mentioned in ESSA as part of STEM, a well-rounded education.
And so we are just starting on what's going to be probably a two year process starting in early 2017 with AB 1539 and 2329 in terms of a strategic advisory body for computer science implementation in California and looking at
the possibility of computer science standards.
So since that's just now happening for California and it's just now in the federal law for the first time, then I'll be looking to see how we leverage ESSA for that as well as in GSS.
Thank you.
Okay, Board Member Strauss.
So Barbara, I just want to thank you for taking us carefully along the path and for really incorporating lots of outreach and input from stakeholders.
So I know we have a long way to go to get a fully coordinated plan, and I think what we're hearing through our state and our federal efforts, we really do want a coherent, coordinated plan.
So I want to build on what Member Williams said and talk about
the challenging state academic standards and academic assessments, and also the piece about supporting excellent educators.
I think that's a really good opportunity, and we know from school district work that the benefits in using federal money to coordinate efforts in a local district can really make a difference.
I think we really want to be clear
that it should be in support of what we're already identifying through our LCAP process, and I think you're trying to be really clear about trying to coordinate it.
But I think when we look at how to maximize the impact, the challenging state academic standards and academic assessments are really critical.
And those of us who are working out in the field know that this is a long-term process, that we're early in our full implementation to touch all of our classrooms.
So I'm really interested in, as you develop it, to take a look at building the capacity of teachers and leaders over time and incorporating English language development strategies.
It's one of the things we're seeing in our framework.
Those are embedded in all of our frameworks.
It's going to be a connection across all of our schools.
We're going to need to really address that to support the large percentage of students who need that.
And that we need to support the leaders, both at the site and district level, to connect.
Because what we're finding in our collaboration work is without working with leaders, it's not fully getting implemented.
And so criteria that we would put in around
multi-level, multi-year process, not a single, not a sit and get, not a information session, but how do we embed that in our implementation to meet these state requirements?
So I think it's really important that we coordinate coherently to say,
supplement and enhance what we're doing, and to maximize the flexibility for local districts.
So again, I'm looking forward to, I appreciate you breaking into the parts for us, and so what I heard is that January, March, and May, we're gonna hear more and more information, and in between, CPAG will give feedback to you on the parts as well.
Thank you.
Board Member Sun.
So just also want to reiterate a lot of what Member Stroud just talked about.
I really appreciate the strategic approach overall in implementing the challenging academic standards and as we're talking about maybe the computer science standards or the LPAC or the language standards is
How does that relate to that implementing of our state standards overall?
And while I understand that we don't want to go into a lot more detail necessarily than what is being asked in our plan, that as we implement that plan, though, in California, we have an understanding that we're folding all of these pieces in.
And as you're bringing the different pieces and parts back to us over the next few months, it would also be helpful then to tie it right back again.
So this is one component, how does it tie back to that strategic plan?
How will the different departments, divisions that have been in charge of titles, all the different titles, how will that work together in this new state plan that we will have?
Okay, I'll ask a question and then board members may have some others.
The frame of the application is helping schools and districts attain the high academic standards.
And that's really what this is organized around.
And we're taking an approach which has a large measure of building local capacity in order to do that.
We're reexamining, for example, the application.
We'll be reexamining the application process and criteria.
for the overall plan and then for example, title one.
So that brings me to the old local education agency plan, which was formulated in 2006.
And I downloaded it, nearly broke my computer printer.
I mean, it's huge.
And I haven't had a chance to read it, but glancing through it,
I mean, this is a real beast of a forum, and I just thank God I didn't have to fill that out, you know, in my whole life.
You know, my impression superficially was I don't know what this has to do with what we're currently trying to do here.
I don't see the thing as relevant at all.
We have to start over.
And how are you going to do that?
I mean, what is what is the plan?
you know, the group to do that, because you can't just adapt something from NCLB for this.
So we're really starting de novo.
And was the local education plan on 206, was that the bulk of the application for Title I in those days?
And that was the key thing you looked at?
Right, so we are not intending to build the new LEA plan based on, our new LEA plan for ESSA starting with the old NCLB plan.
There are specific provisions outlined in the law that districts need to address, and there are about 35 of them that start with describe how you're doing this, describe how you're doing this.
And then there's a separate set of things that we ask districts to do regularly, provide assurances.
So the assurances can all go into the consolidated application reporting system.
That's relatively easy.
What we're working with now is how are we going to
We already have LCAPs which ask districts to explain what they're doing in some detail.
There's some concern that what ESSA asks districts to explain is a little more detailed than what LCAPs do.
So our charge, and you're asking what are we doing over Christmas vacation, because I just said I was gonna try and bring you some preliminary thinking in January, is to try and figure out how we can streamline that planning process.
LCAP is where we start.
What do we need to do to address those LEA plan provisions across Titles 1, 2, 3, and 4?
Can some of them go into the consolidated application process?
Can some of them be covered through the LCAP process?
These are the questions that we're asking and trying to resolve to at least bring you some preliminary thinking about that in January.
Obviously, another piece of this, I had the pleasure of presenting at CASFEP, our state and federal program directors back on October 13th,
These are folks who actually build LCAPs and LEA plans, right?
So I use them, I didn't warn them in advance, and I apologize to all of you now, as a bit of a focus group.
You know, because I think everyone is very much desirous of streamlining this planning process and having a single planning process that makes sense, right?
We don't want one over here and one over there, and they're certainly invested in that as well.
And they have experience with both of these planning efforts, so I'm trying to use as much district input as possible to make sure that whatever we come up with makes sense.
And yeah, we'll get that together.
Okay, well, I'll use this opportunity.
This pertains to the federal aid.
Since we met in September, I would do what normally would be done in a state priorities discussion we're going to have later, but this was focused on Title I. So the Gates Foundation and Achieve called a conference in Palm Springs, California,
of several states, including California, to focus on thinking about the new federal aid initiative.
And I saw a report out.
Many people from California attended.
I attended.
Glenn Price attended.
Robert Linquani of WestEd attended.
Janelle Kubinek attended.
Mike Hanson, superintendent of Fresno, attended.
Mike Smith attended, formerly of the US Department.
Jennifer O'Day of AIR attended.
A person from the Carnegie Foundation for Improvement at Stanford attended.
And it was run by Achieve, Mike Cohen of Achieve.
And it focused on what was called at the meeting.
the front end of ESSA rather than the back end, which is so much discussed about in terms of the accountability provisions that tie into all the discussion we have at accountability.
The topic of this was, let's not talk about that much here.
Let's talk about which instruments you have to use federally to improve the system on the front end and what is the front end.
The front end is the LEA applications.
All of these applications are now defunct.
They have to apply, they the locals, to the State Education Agency for approval for all funds.
So you can improve the quality of things not just by hammering at the back end of accountability, but improving the front end of what the applications are.
And from what I saw, that LEA plan is an example of how you don't do it, and we're seeking a way to do it.
Another instrument you have are the reporting reports, if the board wants to be active.
For Title I, and you list them here in Title III, we receive annual reports under these federal aid and we could look at these reports and say,
you're not doing well enough.
So we would like to talk with you about before, you know, we approve the next batch of funds, what you can do.
So that was also discussed there.
So and then, of course, a third angle was building local capacity, and that is included in the
in the draft that Barbara sent around to the board members that's been released after CPAG on what are called the state set-aside funds.
If we set aside everything we could set aside under the law, it'd be between $150 and $200 million.
at the state level.
I mean, that's a high-popping number.
We must withhold 7% of Title I. That is $128 million.
Now we have to re-grant that amount, but we could run competitive grants.
We could do a whole number of things.
So we can withhold 3% of Title III.
That's about $6 to $7 million.
So the general view of the conference was to not think about this title by title.
That means you probably wouldn't organize your state education agency, title by title, to administer this, to focus on what is really the big thing in the plan, which is a big thing in the law, which is students attaining the state high academic standards.
And we sure have those in all four subject areas now.
So how would you do that?
And so how do you then frame an application in a federal strategy to do that?
While there are a lot of federal restrictions on the back end, what I'm calling back end accountability, there are very few on the front end.
That's really where the flexibility is in many ways.
And so we have a lot of authority to
set up the application, to approve set up criteria for approval of local applications, and how we think about those applications from localities in terms of meeting the highest state academic standards.
So this was more of a
It was sort of around a conference around if states really wanted to exercise leverage on the front end of it, how would they do that?
What are the restrictions in the law?
Very few.
So we just have a lot of design things to think about.
which is very different than the discussion which was carried on in the letter we sent to the federal regulations, which was basically about the back end of accountability, because we had no objections with the regulations in the front end.
So that's sort of the conclusion of the conference in that regard.
We had an exercise, I guess,
and that each state would suggest that the group would work on.
And I hadn't been primed on this.
Right out of the top of my head, I don't know why, I said, what I want to work on for California is what's causing the big difference between English language arts and mathematics?
This is, you know, on our Smarter Balanced assessments.
And the other states chimed in and said, we didn't have it.
Why do we have it?
I don't know.
So, you know, we got to talking about that in an intense way, and I won't dwell on the conversation, but it was pretty interesting from that standpoint.
So there's my report on this Gates conference.
and some of the thinking, and what I reflected was what came out of the conference.
Glenn and Barbara are aware of that, and their thinking has been generally along the lines of the conference outcomes.
I don't know whether, Glenn, you want to add anything to this.
You were there, and if you care to.
I think President Coors, you described it in broad terms really well.
I think one of the take-home messages for me was, we've been talking a lot about this integration and braiding that Barbara has put forward, but really bringing that down to a concrete possibility, and I would suggest that,
and others that are interested, take a look at that memo that's posted on the October 13th CPAG site.
It's kind of the next step in our thinking coming out of the conference in Palm Springs where we kind of sat down and said, okay, if we're looking at this front end, what would be the best way for us to be thinking about utilizing and investing these resources to be building the kind of capacity that we need to see to implement the standards in the way that we'd like to in California
The three items that are listed out there address building out our regional support resources to something we've been calling the California Support Network, to be thinking about bringing back some of the kinds of infrastructure that we've had in the past in California around capacity building for educators, which were reframed in that memo as the California Leadership Initiative.
And then lastly, how can we be looking at and providing the best possible resources for standards implementation.
It's fleshed out in conceptual form in that memo, and so it takes this thinking about this overarching priority of standards, which has been something that we've all obviously been committed to for a bit now, and makes it concrete in terms of how could we be thinking about this in terms of this opportunity that we have in front of us.
So that was some of the momentum building out of that meeting kind of jettisoned us into some of that thinking.
and the board members got that CPAG memo, which was the department's first cut at thinking about this.
Not definitive comments, very welcome.
The department stressed this was just to illustrate and demonstrate some initial thoughts about this, but the board will have these state set-aside decisions in front of it.
I think that pose some some alternatives that are quite reasonable for the discussion.
Board member Rucker.
Well, Barbara, first of all, I want to thank you for what I know has been a lot of work among multiple divisions in the department to start putting together this draft.
And I have to also say I appreciate that since ESSA was signed into law last year, the multiple times that you have come to the board meetings to give us an update about what the department is doing and what it is you're looking at,
and what it is you're thinking about.
And so when I got the draft plan and I read it, what I was hoping, as board member Lacombe pointed out, that this would be the opportunity for the board to start talking about in the totality of all the decisions we have made and the decisions that are still under development and decisions that have to wait until the regulations are done, you know, have we as a board actually
given to the department what we believe our priority should be or what we think the frame of the plan should be.
And I have to tell you, unless I've missed a meeting, I'm not sure we've had that conversation.
Because in reading all the five different parts of the plan, I heard five different purposes.
I read five different voices.
Is this supposed to be a spending plan?
So I've heard people talk about braiding or blending the funds, and so is the plan in some way going to give a narrative about how the state is going to use all of these different funds?
That's not a conversation we've had in this meeting, and again, unless I've missed a meeting.
The second thing I've read very clearly in the plan was about this notion of capacity building.
That's the conversation in all the memos we've received and all the information items and briefings we've received.
The focus of my attention has been on this capacity building piece with the goal of figuring out how to create this single, coherent, and uniform accountability system
how we're going to blend those elements together, but also what it means to build the capacity for the local education agencies to do that.
Having that part of the conversation, we've only focused in one area, on the accountability.
So that's the third voice I heard, and that was probably, for me, the strongest part of the plan, because there were some things we have definitively done.
Those are conversations we have definitively had engagement on and done a lot of work on.
But some of these other pieces are still missing, and I'll tell you where the balance wasn't for me.
In Title IV, in talking about the 21st century learning communities, as Dr. Kearse pointed out, there's both funding requirements and some program-level requirements, but there are also some things that districts have some flexibility to develop in their own local education plans.
And so the local, the LEA plans, the local plans, there's 13 activities and seven assurances that have to be addressed in their plans.
I was hoping that there would be some overlap in developing, for example, in Title IV,
some guidance or some things that we would be guiding districts to consider or to understand so that there would be some consonance between what the state priorities are and hopefully that would inform and guide districts in the development of their LEA plans, knowing that we have to write or help develop or consider developing a new template for writing that LEA plan.
So that's one voice
or one idea in developing the plan that I didn't hear.
The last piece is not only are there the state formula grants that have to be addressed, and that's what the bulk of the plan really requires the state, as a state plan, to look at, but there are also a number of different competitive grants
that also either the state can apply for or LEAs can apply for, and that informs some of the other work that is done.
For example, in Title II Part A, I'm very clear that those are formula grants that come to the state, that the LEAs are going to apply to the state and receive,
We're going to have some idea in writing that plan what it is we're asking them to do.
And I've heard already from some of my colleagues on the board, we want the professional development money out of Title II Part A to focus on these things.
In Title II, Part B, there are all of those multiple types of grants that consortiums of districts or the state, even in collaboration with districts, can also apply for.
I'm not clear that we're looking at those competitive grants or having an idea, casting an idea about looking at those competitive grants as well.
So I'm not sure I read that, and it could be something I missed in looking at some of these other parts.
So that's something I'm hoping would come through.
in looking, and then finally, the last piece that I wanted to talk about is, at some point, as you've said, you're going to get this feedback from stakeholders, and you all are gonna have some process for vetting that feedback.
What I didn't hear, and what was missing for me is, so when do I get to say something, or when do I get to add some feedback, or are you telling me I'm supposed to go to the portal and add my feedback there?
I think that there has to be,
Yeah, so I'm thinking there has to be, because I went to the CPAG meeting and I really enjoyed listening to that and I learned a lot, but I haven't figured out yet, and it's not clear to me yet, when is my work or when is the work of my colleagues here
supposed to inform what's being written into the draft.
So, as I said, particularly with Title I, I see where some of that work is, but in some of these other titles, I don't see where our conversations have actually informed what's in the draft narrative right now.
And I don't mean that as a criticism, I really mean it more, I think we need to look at the step we're missing in our own process because we haven't had that conversation as it relates to framing what the board's priorities would be in being written into the state plan.
I hope that makes sense.
It absolutely makes sense, and I think you've just clearly articulated the danger of bringing one chunk of information without all of the chunks of information.
Yet I still am really reluctant to bring 300 pages of state plan to you in March.
Right, so part of this, I think we talked about the Title II-B grants back in May and that they were available and we intended to apply for them as soon as we had more information about them because there are a lot of opportunities.
The STEM Master Teacher Corps is in there.
We're hoping that that can begin to fill the shoes of
the math and science partnership grants, there's the literacy for all, results for the nation grant, there are all kinds of grants.
And I think I signaled, we don't have clear information about these, they haven't been funded, the RFAs haven't gone out, but we intend to keep an eye on them and apply for them as soon as more information is available.
Okay, so what I guess I'm suggesting is that in writing out and developing, because the state plan asks you to identify what the state is doing to create this well-rounded education.
And so while this is both supposed to be a plan for developing capacity and a spending plan, I think that the work on explaining what our state's plans are for developing and implementing a well-rounded education
should be developed irregardless of whether we're figuring out if we're going to apply for any of those Part B programs.
Because we know we're going to be doing work to write a new state assessment in science.
We know we want to have this statewide plan for doing a rollout on professional development.
So it needs to be written in there and developed.
Okay, so now I'm channeling my parents, and I'm going to say, you need to just go ahead and figure out the plan, and we can figure out how to pay for it later.
That's not quite what I mean, but I do mean I don't want this to be, I'm hoping we're not, we're writing a narrative about building capacity.
and in some way figuring out how to braid in the conversation about the funding and about the other elements because I think that that's the part that was missing.
I'm not seeing in the development of what's there right now that full attention to building the capacity and building out that well-rounded education.
I'm not sure in all of those four or five parts right now it's in there.
It is not very well articulated in these five parts.
We anticipate, we are confident that we will be bringing to you in the January item our supporting excellent educators section, or at least as much of it as we can in the absence of regs, and we also still have the supporting all schools, supporting all students section.
So those sections, because they are a little more complicated and benefit from this kind of conversation about well how
do we want to support all educators?
Do we want to focus on implementation of standards?
Do we want to use that 3% allowable set aside in Title II?
How are we going to be supporting the schools that are identified for comprehensive and targeted supports?
Those are conversations that we need to have with you.
That's why we're sort of deferring a lot of that till the latest possible minute, which is March.
But the conversation we're having now in terms of like when you all provide feedback,
Every time I'm standing up here, I am taking your conversation as feedback, and that helps us to move forward with what we've got so far.
Okay, so if that's the case, then I'm going to give you the three little words, career technical education.
So I think there's an opportunity in title four to think about how to make sure that that remains a priority and gets the attention in a statewide focus.
I think this is our opportunity to make sure that that happens.
So I will say that there and figure out how to give some how to write that out or give you some information on that later.
So I'll just say it that way.
I appreciate it.
Other comments?
Board member Ortiz will comment.
I appreciate your comments, Board Member Rucker, because I also had some questions about just the protocol, and I was trying to get at, I didn't have coffee, though, I was trying to get at, at what point are we also part of that conversation?
So in looking at Title III, the last time there was the use of RFEP students in the EL subgroup, and there was some pushback on that.
I'm looking at the reclassification criteria right now,
And I know that we are waiting to see how the LPAC, once upon implementation, to determine the cut scores.
And so for me, it's still a little unclear.
Are we saying that once we remove the SBAC outcomes from the criteria, that that is the reclassification criteria that we want?
and that we're going to wait for the LPAC implementation to determine the cut scores.
I don't know what we're saying based on the item because it lists what we're currently doing, but are we also then saying that those three criteria points are good enough for us to consider our reclassification criteria?
Well, I'm asking.
I don't know if that's what it said.
And I'm wondering who made that decision, if that's what we're saying, who has input.
And that's what we currently have in place.
But again, I'll reiterate the point that what we have in place has not been a standard program or a standard practice of reclassifying students.
It really varies by district.
So why would we?
establish that as our criteria to reclassified if the goal is to make it standard across the state.
And I'm sure that there's other folks that could really weigh in.
So just understanding what is it that we're proposing, for me there, because it outlines the criteria that we currently have, I'm not sure if we're saying that that's what we want to go with, and if that is what we want to go with, then that merits a discussion.
Well, fortunately,
if she's still here.
Veronica Aguilar, Director of our English Learner Support Division is here, and she can talk about the specific elements in those sections of the plan, but I think this is a good example of those concerns were raised in September, and we took those concerns and said we're going to look at this more closely with our English Learner Indicator Workgroup.
Right?
So when we hear concerns and feedback from you all and from the public, we actually try and move that concern forward.
But if you want more information about what we're doing in terms of the reclassification, Veronica is certainly here and can come talk about that for a minute.
So I think I want to reiterate, good morning, members of the board and Superintendent Torlakson and President Kerst.
The portion of Title III, it's actually addressing just the entry and exit criteria.
And for us to, we have to state to the federal government, how does California currently have a standard process for entry and exit criteria?
So what you see there is our process currently in place, which is an indication code.
And the Education Code currently does have four areas.
It includes the Language Proficiency Assessment, which currently is the CELT, teacher input, parent input, and then academic achievement.
Now ESSA calls only for the English Language Proficiency Assessment.
That's what ESSA calls for.
So the regulations, if they pass, that's what we would have to comply with.
So the statement there is that we're starting conversations with you and the legislature as to what should that criteria be for the exit.
For the entry, I think it's very clear.
The LPAC already is going to address that with the screener.
So once we have this LPAC in place in 2018, the entry is done.
The exit is where we have to have those conversations.
And I think the item for the federal government, we have to say we're looking into it and we will address it.
And the statement right now, it talks about the fact that once the LPAC is in place and we have the cut score, we would have the ability to move in that direction.
Now whether or not we continue to include teacher evaluation and parent input, I think that's up to, of course, the decision that is made.
But it's the conversation that we need to have.
So that's what I was trying to get at.
Is this a conversation that's pending and we're just reporting on what we currently do?
And how do people from the ELA working group, what are their thoughts on the reclassification process?
Do they feel that having the proficiency rate and the LPAC, the student teacher recommendation and parent input, is that sufficient?
Will that guarantee some standard process across the state?
Have those conversations happened?
There's a few conversations.
I mean, reclassification for those members that have been on board for a while, reclassification has been a topic of discussion for many, many years.
Ed code has not changed, though, even though those discussions have occurred.
What we're seeing with ESSA, it's giving us
if the regulations pass, as they are, we are definitely going to have to remove the academic performance, item four.
The other two items, the teacher evaluation and parent opinion, it's really up to the state, because we would have to actually push back to the federal government, saying that we think multiple measures are needed.
The federal government is saying one measure, which is the language proficiency assessment.
reclassification.
So we have what's in the Education Code concerning the four criteria for reclassification.
We also have some things in our state regulations.
If the federal regulations as proposed remain unchanged, are there going to have to be any changes in our statute or in our Title V regulations?
Are you anticipating, can you identify what those, okay I don't mean to put you on the spot, can you identify what those would be aside from, I know the academic piece would have to change, are there other things that would have to change also?
The reclassification, that's the only section, that's why it's mentioned.
Okay, so of the four criteria, we know that the fourth one would have to come out, and that would take a change both in our regulations and in the, and it would take a legislative change as well.
Yes.
Okay.
Thank you.
Okay, other comments on this, yeah.
Okay, we'll take some, pardon?
All right, we'll take some public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Doug McRae, Brian Rivas, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Sandy Mendoza, Eric Premack, and Terry Burns.
And Jessica Sacco.
Good afternoon, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing CABE and Californians Together.
And I'm very, very concerned about the fact that we would be deleting that fourth criteria from the reclassification.
Court case and law states that we need to know whether English learners are acquiring academic content while they are becoming proficient in English.
And we don't know what the LPAC is gonna look like.
We don't know if that assessment is gonna be able to measure that.
So I would recommend that this be more thoroughly vetted with other stakeholders, especially the EL community, in order to really think through what the long-term consequences are gonna be by eliminating this fourth criteria.
So that's one comment.
The other comment is,
We would like to have included in the state plan at least a narrative in reference to the language arts assessment in Spanish.
We're having this assessment for students who are being instructed in a language other than English.
Why not state that in the state plan?
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired educational measurement specialist.
I'm going to talk about the draft plan for academic standards and statewide assessments only.
For academic standards, there's only a single sentence in the current draft material that says that material is in the peer review material.
Well, peer review materials are not available to the general public.
And that's a problem for your upcoming public comment period.
Also, the peer review material does not cover actual implementation of Common Core standards in California since adoption in 2010.
For the assessments, I have about 10 detailed comments I'll likely submit in writing during the upcoming public comment period.
Most of those comments involve descriptions that reflect marketing promises for the assessment program features rather than statements of actual implemented features that address ESSA requirements.
Thank you.
Mr. President, I'm Brian Rivas speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
And a couple of comments for you first is, so as you turn to your work on accountability under ESSA, and you're gonna be talking about school accountability related to schools, we would ask that you give some thought to doing some focused, deliberate outreach to parents and communities.
This is really where the rubber hits the road,
And I worry a little bit that unless you do some firsthand information gathering, focus group work, you're gonna be left to sort out what we advocates argue parents want, or what the interpretation that advocates give you trying to support their respective positions.
I think the debate could benefit from some firsthand information from real parents when you talk about school ratings, what information is available and how it's presented.
Secondly, we don't know what the final regs will say, but when you get to that point on differentiation, please keep in mind that multiple measures and a summary rating don't have to be mutually exclusive.
Other states are looking at different ways to incorporate both.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
Two things with respect to charter schools in the state plan.
First off, we asked to what we call do no harm.
We've had some long simmering issues over how charter schools fit into the current state plan that evolved since 2002.
over teacher credentialing issues, over whether you use this template or that template or that template for the LEA plan and so on and so forth.
Those continue to be unresolved currently and we don't want to have that happen all over again with this plan and see it as an opportunity to try to fix those.
Second, with respect to funding, you're not talking about that a lot yet today, but it did come up in the practitioner's advisory group with a lot of talk about recreating the school leadership academies or taking money off the top to do this, that, and the other thing.
As a general rule, we like to see local control over those funds.
We often find that these state-level initiatives may work for some districts, but often don't work for others or for charter schools, and we want to maximize local control.
Thank you.
Good afternoon President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
My name is Jessica Sacco representing the California Science Teachers Association.
I'm really grateful for the opportunity to be here today as well as to hear your discussion that took place earlier.
We're really pleased to hear about the current direction to support the implementation of state standards that the state is currently proposing.
The letter that we submitted does outline several opportunities within ESSA in order to help California provide the well-rounded education that's inclusive of science for all students TK to 12.
We feel that doing so is not only in service to our students but it also helps support the state LCFF priority to offer a broad course of study as well as implementation of state standards.
We feel that leveraging ESSA to support science, to offer professional learning is really critical for our science educators and educators, both administrators, elementary school teachers, all teachers of science.
This is critical with the loss of the Mass Science Partnership grants, and we look forward to continuing to work with the department in order to support science.
Thank you.
Thank you, Terry Burns, on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
We share your concerns about the regulation language on supplement not supplant.
We will be submitting a similar letter this week.
We also appreciate that you have taken the ESSA plan
in pieces so that we can share it with our members, get comments, and address all of those concerns.
Member Rucker talked earlier about the discussion on substantial weight for academics.
We would really love to have you have that conversation and engage in that as soon as possible, because I think that's going to drive a lot of this.
And we encourage you to be bold.
This should be our plan.
This should not be the Fed's plan that's given to us.
We've done a lot of work to develop an accountability system that has great promise, and we should submit the California plan, not a plan that's simply tied to regs and requirements.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Martha Alvarez from AXA.
We'll be providing more comments in the letter in January to the State Board, but I'll just mention for the time being that we have been engaging with our members about the Title II funding and the set-asides if the state was to pursue the $150 million to $200 million that Dr. Kirst mentioned.
sort of what would our members like to see in that capacity building.
We have heard a different definition of what they think needs to be the capacity building, how that looks like at the local level.
And so I think it's important to consider where we can better enhance the funds, whether it be at the local level through grants.
given to school districts directly or more of the state support.
Where we would be helpful from the State Department of Education would be if we are able to get any specific questions where you need our feedback, it is a very massive plan to tackle.
So as we go to our members asking for a lot of feedback on that accountability system, local performance indicators, and many other measures,
It's difficult to sort of ask them for their feedback when they have full-time jobs without not understanding what are those key points that you need to hear from us.
We'll be identifying the priorities on behalf of AXA, but to be able to help you, it would be helpful to know the questions that you have for us.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public testimony.
Board Member Sun, do you want to make any comments as federal liaison on this?
No, I think the process of how we engage stakeholders in something so massive, and I think that last suggestion about help frame it a bit, right, so that you can get useful, constructive feedback.
Very helpful.
Okay, I think we're ready for a motion then.
Okay.
Yes, approve the letter giving authority to the President and State Board and the State Superintendent to do that.
So I will move the recommendation of the department.
Because we didn't talk about a supplement versus a plan.
So can you give some general comments as to what your feedback would be to the department?
Let me ask our Council Dave Sapp to speak to that.
So the item that was posted with the materials on this included a summary of the basic thrust or focus, which is on the statute underlying the supplement not-to-plant regs, specifies that the federal government can't prescribe particular methodologies or tests for it, whereas the proposed regs identify three possible options that states must use.
So the general thrust of the comments is reflected in the item.
would be to sort of stick with the statutory framework and to allow states the discretion to develop methodologies that are consistent and will work to meet that statutory requirement.
The letter is still in draft form, it isn't finalized at this point, so it's not ready to be presented publicly for that reason.
This is a very important issue, I wanna make sure the language is as precise and clear as possible, but that's the general thrust of the letter as identified in the item.
Yeah, I haven't seen a draft of the letter, so I can't comment.
Second the motion.
All right, second.
Okay, all those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, that's passed.
So thank you, Barbara.
Oh wait, did we make a decision about how board members were supposed to give feedback or to pass information on to the staff about this draft?
Did we come to an agreement about that?
That's not what I'm asking.
I didn't ask when it was coming back.
I asked, did we come to an agreement on how board members would give feedback to the staff about what's contained in this draft?
No, that was not part of the motion.
No, I mean, I did not.
The answer is no, we did not.
Okay, I guess we're ready then for item six, the CASP recommendations.
Good afternoon.
Michelle Sutter, Director of the Assessment Division.
It really doesn't sound like these are on, but
The action before you today is the release of up to 10% of the withhold of the 2015-16 CASP contract with ETS, Educational Testing Service.
As with any state contract, a withhold of 10% is applied to every invoice that we receive from our contractor.
The CASP contract with ETS also stipulates within that contract criteria by which each task is reviewed to be deemed successfully completed.
As part of an annual process, the department reviewed the contract requirements, the deliverables that we received against the successful completion requirements outlined in the contract.
In doing so, during that review, we asked that the board approve the following.
The release of a total of $8,369,960.24 from funds withheld during the 15-16 testing administration.
Please note that this amount is almost the entire amount of the 10% funds that were withheld, an indication of the successful year that we had testing.
The CDE is also asking the board to approve the recommendation to withhold $271,952.56, a relatively small portion from the contractor for specific components of Task 3, which is technology services, and Task 9, reporting results.
And I have been asked to be very brief in all of my presentations, so I am open to President Kirsten.
Board member, questions on that brief presentation?
I don't hear any questions.
I think we'll proceed to public comment.
We have one speaker, Doug McRae.
Yes, good afternoon.
I'm Doug McRae, retired assessing specialist.
The threshold score part of the California Alternative Assessment Test should be subject to non-release of funds.
Last week I submitted a six-page handout
to your folder, focused on the extreme differences between the CAA threshold scores and the model NICSEC threshold scores.
Today I have a handout addendum, which I think went around this morning, one page on green, that
has further questions on the validity of the threshold scores as well as the adequacy of the test question data used to establish the threshold scores.
These two handouts present evidence that the 2016 CAA tests were, in a word, too difficult for the students, particularly the math tests.
Page one of my initial handout suggests how a non-release of ATS funds might be handled until the flaws of the threshold scores are evaluated by an independent expert with resolution by January.
Finally, ETS is preparing a flawed test scores distribution to 35,000 students this month.
Time.
Those reports should not be distributed while important validity and credibility concerns are evaluated.
Thank you.
Okay, further board discussion on this item?
Seeing none, all those in favor, raise your hands.
I don't think we have a motion.
Oh, motion, sorry.
Okay, I'll make the motion.
I'll second.
Recommendation?
Okay, thank you.
Okay.
All those in favor, raise your hands now.
Okay, that one's done.
Okay, now item seven on LPAC.
Okay, you're looking at yourselves, right?
Okay, so item seven is the LPAC regulations.
This is an action item before you today.
This item asks the board to approve proposed changes to these regulations, approve the commencement of a 15-day public comment period for the proposed regulations,
If no relevant comments are received during that 15 day public comment period, the regulations would be deemed adopted.
If relevant comments are received, CDE staff will respond and be directed to place the proposed regulations on the January agenda.
The motion also asks that the board to authorize CDE staff to take any ministerial or procedural actions that may be required to address any concerns from the Office of Administrative Law during their review of the rulemaking file.
Most of the proposed changes that you see are based on feedback that was received during the 45-day public comment period.
We received written comments from three parties.
Responses to those comments are provided in the final statement of reasons as attachment three to this board item.
Other changes were also made by the department to improve clarity on procedures.
So there were several changes made, but I'd like to just highlight three of them in my comments.
One would be the change to make sure that it was clear that these regulations apply only to LPAC.
We wanted to make sure that there was no confusion out in the field, that these regulations apply to CELT.
It also clarifies that these regulations are operative when Superintendent Torlakson reports to the legislature that the LPAC assessments are ready for administration as required by Education Code.
That's one important change.
The next change I want to highlight to you is the regulations also address the correction of classification errors for English only students.
This has been amended to require local educational agencies to notify parents at least 10 calendar days prior to administering the initial assessment to the pupil.
The last change that I want to highlight is we clarified the amount of time an LEA has to administer the initial assessment, locally produce the official score, and notify the parents or guardians in writing of the results, and that is within 30 calendar days after the pupil's date of initial California enrollment.
So those are the three changes within the regulations I wanted to highlight.
There are others, but mostly I would say classify them as clarification.
Okay, board member comments on these changes.
We had three comments on this and now it's going out for another 45 day period.
Not a 15.
15, not 45.
Okay.
Okay, Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
I was telling Board Member Strauss that this is going to be a new common for you.
I'm going to thank you for all the work that you've done and for really listening to some of the input and the feedback, not only from the public, but also from some of the liaisons, including Board Member Strauss and myself.
You worked really hard, you and your team, and you should be commended for that, because you really, we had some discussions, there was a lot of back and forth, and at the end, I really felt that the input was considered and, when possible, included.
I know that one of the comments was around a primary screener, and it is beyond the scope of this process of the regulations, but I'm happy
to hear that it will be likely included in the guidance that goes out to the school districts.
So again, thank you, and I wanna thank your team for all the hard work.
Okay, other board comments on the LPAC regulations?
Not public comment.
Doug McCray.
Good afternoon.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired testing specialist.
I submitted a one-page handout to your electronic folder on this item last week.
In July, I suggested a revision for the summit of LPAC test administration window in the draft regs from a recommended February through May window to a January through April window tied to individual school calendars parallel to the current CASP regs on test administration windows.
I supported the revision with seven reasons why the January through April window should be preferred.
CDE rejected this suggestion with a non-responsive reply, citing only LPAC statutory language.
My suggested revision window is consistent with LPAC statute, as detailed in the one-page handout.
I'd ask the state board to hold open this issue until the CDE provides reasons for maintaining the February through May window, which overlaps and conflicts with the CASP test administration window.
Thank you.
Okay.
There's no further board discussion.
I'm ready for a motion on the CDE recommendation.
I move approval, CDE recommendation.
I second.
All right, all those in favor, raise your hands.
We're done.
Okay, now we're on the S. P. E. Priorities agenda item eight.
So let me start with asking for taking up the minutes, uh, and ask if there's any public comment on the minutes.
No public comment on the minutes.
Do I have a motion to approve the minutes?
Okay, approved and seconded.
All those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, now I'm ready for member bird to review the S. P. Screening committee's recommendations for appointments.
Thank you.
You should have a copy of the item addendum in your baskets for item eight.
This is the time of year.
In addition to the fun time we have select making recommendations about the student members is to repopulate our advisory committees.
So if you bear with me, I'll go through them one by one.
We had one vacancy on the advisory commission for charter schools.
The county superintendent slot was vacant.
And thanks to the assistance of member Williams, we'd like to recommend that John Gundry, the county superintendent for Santa Clara County be appointed to that position.
In addition, there are three members of the advisory commission that we would like to recommend be reappointed.
Atiyani Howard, who's the parent representative, Brian Bauer, who's the charter school representative, and Curtis Washington, who is the teacher representative for the ACCS.
And in the item, you'll see their terms that we're recommending they be appointed from January 2017 to December 2018.
And I think I can do these all together, yeah, so we don't have to have separate votes.
The next committee, we're actually, these are all reappointments upon the advice of our liaison, Nikki Sandoval, for the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
We're recommending reappointing Keila Rodriguez, who's the parent on the committee, of a parent in a charter school.
Sarah, I'm not sure I'm pronouncing her last name correctly, Jochum, who's a district administrator, and Summer Harding, who is a parent and also a school principal.
Those terms are from January 2017 to December 2020.
The Child Nutrition Advisory Commission, we recruited for two new members, and then we also are recommending reappointment with the help of my colleague Feliz Ortiz-Licone.
We're recommending Patrick Trainor be appointed as the curriculum coordinator on CNAC, and that Maria Elena Gallagher be appointed as the teacher on CNAC.
We're also recommending reappointment of Barbara Rohrer, who's a school board member,
Lucy McProud, who is a consultant, and Lawrence Herrera, who's a school administrator.
Those appointments are from January 2017 to December 2019.
Maria Elena Gallagher's term is from November 2016 to December 2017.
And then for our last committee at the California Practitioner Advisory Group, again with Feliz's assistance, we're recommending appointing Linda Kaminsky as the superintendent representative.
we're recommending.
Nancy Laura as a teacher representative and John Damien Huntley as a teacher representative, and we're recommending reappointment of Neva Rowden, who's the para educator serving on C peg.
Those terms differ a little bit because we have staggered terms and you can see the terms that are there for C peg.
So I would like to move the recommendations of the screening
No.
All right.
Any no further board discussion?
All in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, that passes.
Now we're on to the updates on board member liaison reports.
And let me start with IQC Mathematics, Rucker and Strauss.
Any update?
So I'm going to do some of the IQC academics all together if that's okay around the communities.
Well, I'll just do my piece and then maybe you can add on as well.
Okay.
All right.
So there's a coordinating effort through the Department of Education, the success of the county school superintendent and state board to coordinate the implementation of academic standards.
So there's a standards coordinating committee.
and there's some really thoughtful, exciting work going on.
So I'm just gonna talk about, I'll talk about math and science, ELA, and then you maybe can add on the history piece as well.
So we've had separate meetings.
There's a Bechtel grant that's funding the rollout, continued rollout of science and math of 1.3 million.
Bechtel's been very excited about the work, and the idea is to take the 58 counties
which is now divided into 11 regions.
You should know L.A.
County, which serves about 25% of the students in California, is one region, but all the other regions are multiple counties to try to build capacity across the state.
And so they've had a collaboration committee, and starting in December,
There'll be three two-day meetings where we'll build capacity of networks and these leaders in science and math and ELD have been working on the curriculum and content of it.
And so we've actually asked at some point in our state board if we have time in January to give an update on what our efforts are statewide for the continued rollout.
And so very exciting, December 15th and 16th are the math and science here in Sacramento.
It's a very, very exciting work on that.
So I think I'll stop with that and see if, because I had some other areas, but if you wanted to add anything, Member Rucker?
I forgot to turn on the mic.
Since our board meeting in September, there was an IQC meeting on the 22nd, and there were a number of areas that were covered.
The science framework activities, I know that Board Member Williams will cover that.
But there is some additional work that's being undertaken now to develop the new health subject matter framework, the health education framework.
That work is being undertaken now and that is just now beginning.
And so we'll be continuing to do the reporting out on that from the IQC.
The History-Social Science Committee is now undertaking the work to update, to begin the instructional materials adoption process, and so a timeline was adopted for that process, beginning with training the people who will be the reviewers in the spring,
and we anticipate, according to the timeline, that they'll begin receiving the materials that are being prepared by publishers in the late spring, and they will be reconvened in the summer to go over their reviews and to submit their recommendations.
So, an adoption recommendation will be coming to the Board at some point next fall.
One of the things that was unique to this process, Stephanie Gregson's staff convened a publisher's forum that took place the day following the IQC meeting.
So the IQC meeting itself was on Thursday the 22nd.
On September 23rd, there was a publisher's forum.
that was convened, and a number of publishers participated.
It was their opportunity to ask questions about not only the framework and the changes in the framework, but also to discuss the criteria.
It was a very collegial, very jovial, and jovial is a good word for it, because there was not a lot of controversy that arose.
But all of the people who participated, all the publishers who came, were very happy to be there.
And I saw earlier today there were some people who came to the publishers' convening.
who did share their feedback that they were very happy about that convening and having that opportunity to be there for that activity.
The other element that came up, and it's a conversation that's going to continue, you may recall, and Board Member Sandoval and I have talked about this,
and the IQC is also looking at it.
The issue separate from the framework itself is to take a look at how we will monitor or make sure that members of the public who had a great deal of concern about how the content would be rolled out, particularly concerning the development of curriculum about the history of South Asia, how there will be an opportunity for them also to participate in that vetting process.
and to give some of their feedback as well.
So that conversation is still an ongoing conversation, and we'll see how that folds out.
But the publishers were very satisfied with the opportunity to have that conversation and to meet and do some work on reviewing and developing that.
IQC, ELA, ELD, Strauss.
Well, just to follow up on the rollouts is that we are looking for additional grant money to continue ELALD and history, social science, and continue with our framework.
But there's a real strong discussion about ELD as a common thread and literacy across all of our contents.
We all know that we put in those strategies in all of our frameworks, and we're going back to put that in math.
So again, the specialists worked really, really hard on planning what we need to do to build capacity.
But again, I'm hoping that some of this will be connected as well in our statewide efforts on our ESSA plan as well.
Okay, IQC Science, Williams.
Most of it's been covered, except the curriculum, no, no, it's totally fine.
The Curriculum Framework Committee and the IQC finished their work on the Curriculum Framework, which you'll hear about tomorrow, and they finished that with a final public phone call that several of us were on, and it went really well, and everybody's so happy that it's over.
and it's really, really done very well and everyone is really satisfied with that.
So I'm glad that that piece of the work is finished.
We still have several other pieces in terms of the assessment and how it fits into accountability and the instructional materials review, but this was a huge effort and they did a really great job.
You'll hear about it tomorrow.
Okay, IQC Computer Science, Williams.
Okay, so far there's nothing with IQC exactly on computer science, except that the CDE, which I guess means this IQC, is convening three focus groups in November to obtain feedback from the public on what they might want to see from the state on either standards or some kind of guidance on implementing computer science in the classrooms.
And those are in Sacramento, San Francisco, and San Diego.
I will be at the one that's in San Diego, since that's where I live.
And I'm really looking forward to hearing what the public is interested in.
I have a couple of more things on computer science that I'll go ahead and announce at the same time, because this has been a big, a lot of traction and a lot of momentum around computer science just in the last month.
There was a new national first ever of its kind consensus framework developed for bringing computer science education into K-12, and that was released on October 17th.
I represented the state board as a stakeholder in that process and attended several meetings on that, as did Tom Adams and Dean Reese, who's the chair of the Ed Tech Committee for the IQC.
and we have met with them since then.
It's getting quite a bit of national recognition, and people are very interested in seeing it, and an example of, or hearing about it, and some examples of that are that,
I and Hadi Partovi, who is the CEO and founder of Code.org, have been invited by AXA to present at the Superintendent's Symposium in February on Computer Science Education.
President Kirst and I are presenting November 15th at the Silicon Valley Ed Foundation on Computer Science Education.
It's a three-hour symposium with three panels,
and they have invited every superintendent in San Mateo County or Santa Clara County and their staff to attend that meeting.
And in addition, I will be presenting with Pat Young Prattett, who was the lead for the new National Framework on Computer Science Education, will be presenting a centerpiece session at the California Charter School Association.
So there's already a great deal of excitement around computer science.
It's kind of organic and really unusual to see, and I wouldn't have expected it, given everything else that LEAs have been asked to do by the state board over the last couple of years.
And finally, just to add to that momentum, the new computer science principles AP course, which has been piloted the past two years in California and several other places,
was approved and the exam approved by the College Board and it is live this year for the first time.
And the College Board reports that they're getting tremendous interest in it from around the country in schools wanting to offer it.
It's a broad access course intended to attract a more diverse audience to computer science.
And so far, just in the first two months of this year, over 200 high schools in California have submitted a syllabi to get approved so that they can teach that course.
And I was told by the College Board they'd never seen that kind of interest in a first time released new AP course by them.
Okay, good.
Board Member Holiday, Environmental Literacy.
Environmental literacy is not going to appear on the State Board agenda anytime soon, but I thought you might be interested in hearing what is going on with environmental literacy in the state and how connected many of the things that we're doing are to the efforts on behalf of environmental literacy.
In 2015, Superintendent Torlakson and 47-member Environmental Literacy Task Force created the Blueprint for Environmental Literacy.
And that blueprint is a rallying call for all administrators and school classroom teachers to infuse environmental literacy into and throughout all academic disciplines.
The goal is to ensure that eventually every student develops the knowledge, the skills, and the abilities necessary to make sound, informed decisions about environmental issues that face our society.
Superintendent Torokson, in collaboration with the California Environmental Protection Agency, the California Natural Resources Agency, and a range of educational and nonprofit organizations, has convened an Environmental Literacy Steering Committee to create an implementation plan for the blueprint and immediately pursue many of the highest priority recommendations.
I am on that steering committee as well.
And so far in 2016, here are some of the accomplishments of this group.
The steering committee has already secured $3.6 million in funding from private foundations to advance the work of the environmental literacy blueprint.
The committee has collaborated and worked with three California subject matter projects, history, social science, science and international studies to create new professional learning modules that incorporate environmental literacy into the frameworks.
The committee has partnered with the Lawrence Hall of Science to expand their STEM LCAP toolkit to include environmental literacy as part of that toolkit.
The committee has engaged in a re-envisioning of the California Regional Environmental Education Community, known as CREEC, to bring that network to scale so that all educators in all communities will benefit from the services of that organization.
And the committee is in the process of identifying pilot districts that will develop district environmental literacy blueprints that will fully support
that district's LCAP goals as well.
So, as I said, this is not a part of our work necessarily, but I thought you'd be interested in hearing about what that steering committee is working on, the success they're having, and how it does blend with a lot of the things that we do here.
And this committee's working under whose auspices?
I mean, who's appointed it and so on?
Okay, could you describe that, the origin of it?
I'm sort of getting in the middle of the movie here.
Well, we had the task, thank you, and thanks for that great report.
Yeah, the idea had come from a long time back.
About three years ago, we convened this task force, and we didn't want just another report to sit on a shelf.
We wanted to actualize it and sought a great team.
Will Parrish from Ten Strands and Terry Tenement's been involved in giving advice.
really got a good team going and they have found philanthropy interested in funding this.
And some of the work is already gonna be reflected in the science standards as they unfold tomorrow.
And it's to integrate it throughout all curriculum and make sure our schools produce good consumers who make good choices and good voters who make good choices at the ballot box that understand the environmental issues and the science issues and the politics of it all.
And one of the things that excites me the most about environmental literacy and the approach that this steering committee is taking and that the blueprint outlines is that environmental content, environmental topics work.
They work for math.
They work for English.
They work for history and social studies.
They work for science.
They work across all disciplines.
relate to them, understand them, get excited about them, and do well in all disciplines when environmental literacy at the right times is a part of that curriculum.
Okay, now we're ready for the Advisory Committee on Special Ed.
Okay, the Advisory Commission on Special Education met for two very full days last week, and the first thing I'd like to do is commend the CDE staff, the different divisions.
What's happened is there's been a real active seeking of counsel from commissioners related to special education issues, so as we're working towards one coherent system.
There's really evidence of that moving forward, and of the task force report recommendations actually being implemented.
So that I think is a really promising development, and it's taken a lot of good thinking and reaching out early in the process.
So I want to acknowledge that, the department staff for that.
And we're seeing people in the disability community engaging with these different efforts simultaneously.
So that's a great thing.
We heard a presentation also from the California Education Resources Center for the Blind and Visually Impaired, and that's part of the California School for the Blind.
And this entity supports students with visual impairments, not just at the School for the Blind, but local education agencies through assistive technology.
orientation and mobility instruction and staff development.
And the roots go back to 1860 with a one-room schoolhouse in San Francisco.
So this has been going on for a very long time.
We also heard about another promising initiative that brings different agencies together.
Representatives from CDE, the Department of Rehabilitation, and the California Department of Developmental Services are working together on a blueprint for competitive integrated employment.
And what that means is competitive is a customary wage and benefits.
Integrated means a location where employees are interacting with other persons who are not individuals with disabilities.
And employment means paid work.
And the quick phrase for that, real work for real pay in the real world.
And the blueprint is the what, and the next step for implementation is the how, how this is going to roll out.
We also heard student voices.
We had a very compelling testimony from a young leader, and she was talking about the need for including disability history for youth empowerment and how that has been very influential in her own development as a leader.
and very powerful student voices there.
Another recurring theme that I think is important to mention, and it also I think connects with the student voices we heard this morning relating to mental health issues, social and emotional learning and mental health is an emergent focal point in the disability community, and that came through loud and clear throughout the two days.
And we also heard a presentation on the health education framework revision,
And again, the team that presented from the department were very proactive and specified ways that commissioners and other members of the disability community can engage in the process so that it can be as inclusive as possible from the get-go.
And I also want to acknowledge the great work that Kristen Wright is doing, formerly of state board staff.
She's already connected, she's just jumped right in, and she is connecting with leaders in institutes of higher education, deans of schools of education, to talk about teacher preparation as it relates to special education.
So a lot happening, and I also want to acknowledge, finally, the commissioners are very active members in the commission work that informs the state board, but also the various work groups, stakeholder groups, everything that's happening simultaneously right now in the field and in Sacramento.
They're a very dedicated and hardworking group of commissioners, so I want to acknowledge them publicly for that.
Thank you.
Do you want to have any update on the Summer School for the Arts?
Yes, thank you very much.
The California State Summer School for the Arts will be celebrating its 31st year and the application is active now on the website and the deadline for submission is February 28th.
So if for high school students or people who are going into high school, we encourage you to get your applications in by the deadline of February 28th.
Okay, a footnote on the special ed on preview of coming attractions on November 29th, the Public Policy Institute of California will release its report on overhauling special education finance during the formulation of the local control funding initiative, special education finance, which
it's quite a significant part of budgets, maybe 15% or more, was not addressed in that or in the subsequent legislation.
And so some California foundations gave money to PPIC to do this study.
It'll be interesting, and I think the latest term from Silicon Valley is disruptive will be.
So that's to come, and I will speak at the unveiling at that time.
Okay, CTC Strauss.
So, on October 19th, Tom Adams, Deputy Superintendent, and myself, and Jose Gonzalez, who's the Superintendent sitting on the Credentialing Commission, participated at the California Deans Colleges of Education Conference.
It's actually only the second year in about 20 or 25 years that the Deans of the Colleges of Education have been in the same room.
Superintendent Torrekson was there last year.
and we were the policy maker panel.
It was very exciting talking about recruitment, how to engage young students and even in high school into college in their undergraduate years to be excited about teaching, how to inspire them, how to look at different pathways through community college, what skills we're gonna need in our new workforce in 2028, 2030 when our current little kindergartners are graduating and going on, what we need to do to help be relevant.
We talked a lot about pre-service, and thanks to Tom Adams, a very strong suggestion that as you teach curriculum, we have free frameworks and materials on our website that would be wonderful in teacher preparation so that teachers entering our workforce would actually have been exposed to the most current frameworks.
We talked a lot about needing to have a workforce that was reflective of our current student body, a lot about bridging the academic gap, restorative justice practices, which we talked about a little earlier today, and needing teachers to have skills to have students literate by third grade, on grade level, what we need for math skills, and just looking at the changes we're gonna need for teacher preparation.
So it was a really exciting conference,
I think you'll hear a little more about it, but it was just really a wonderful move ahead to what collaboratively we need to do in helping inspire and improve teaching practice.
Then CTC met last week.
Just a couple things.
Thanks to the Science Teacher Association and a lot of our colleagues, there was a collaborative effort by CTC and the science community to update the subject matter requirements for elementary school to align within the legal requirements.
to revise so that our cross-cutting concepts in science and engineering practice and disciplinary core ideas are integrated now, so it was really wonderful to appreciate all the collaboration there.
Also, special ed induction program standards are updated, so we're gonna be talking a lot about the need to update special ed and the new skills that teachers will need with evidence-based practices to support students with differing needs.
Also, there's an update on the administrative performance assessment on a pilot, and trying to update those as well.
So just a lot of effort in those areas to align our practices.
Those are a couple of highlights.
And there was a literacy, so we'd all appreciate those of us who were committed to LAELD.
Our writers, Nancy Bernelson and Hallie Sloak, did a presentation to the CTC, and they passed out our executive summaries of our frameworks.
And so there was a great quote on their slide from our framework which says, the most promising futures await our students and our society when we ensure that all individuals acquire strong literacy and language skills in every discipline.
So I thought that really says a lot of what we're about.
Just two more things.
The Concurrence Commission, which is our subject matter projects, have been pretty low funded, very limited budget, but I liaise onto that.
There was a state conference the beginning of October at UCLA, and they were very, very interested.
I spoke at lunch about where we're going with professional learning and improving practice, so of course they're very interested in ESSA and where we're going on that and would love to help be part of expanding the content support for building teacher capacity.
And then just to support what we're talking about, social emotional learning, our state is now, lays onto this new group that CDE has applied and was part of seven states and 10 more are joining.
We had our first meeting on Monday on social emotional learning and what that ought to be, where that ought to be as part of our practices.
what are elements that we need to help students be fully competent as they graduate school.
So we'll hear a lot more about it, but it was the first meeting and clearly trying to integrate all these concepts as well.
Thank you.
Do you want to comment on the federal teacher preparation regulations?
Were you there for that talk or not?
Okay, well I did confer with the chair of the CTC, Linda Darling-Hammond,
And these are final regulations, and they have quite a bit of required teacher testing after teachers complete their program and go into the schools.
So I would ask you to look into that and report back to the board on that, because there's, as she described, the new regulations for teacher preparation, there's quite a bit of overlap to our work.
And this isn't just a teacher preparation work.
So, um Yeah, and it's quite a controversial thing, and these air completed regulations.
Um, not in that regard, so we would have to create a lot more testing to satisfy these federal regulations.
So so we'll get a report on that next time, because I think that's in December, so I can get that.
Yeah, December.
That's what I mean.
Yeah.
December, no, our January meeting.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Good.
Okay.
Finally, the CCEE member Burr.
Thank you.
I'll start with our October meeting.
At our October meeting, we approved the professional development plan.
You recall that the collaborative was awarded about $24 million in the budget to do the capacity building we talked a lot about this morning.
So we approved the major professional development plan.
The first piece of that is happening as we speak.
The first training is taking place over at the convention center.
But there are nine total workshops up and down the state between now and November 19th.
If you go on the collaborative website and click on workshops and trainings, it lists all the trainings, but there's also a link to the actual PowerPoint, all 152 slides of it.
So if people were asking about how does this all fit together?
I think if you look at that slide deck, you'll have a very good sense of that.
So it's very helpful.
It's a good resource for people who are interested in looking at that.
So also at the October meeting, as part of this overall capacity building, we also approved around 40 early adopter peer-to-peer networks.
Those are intended to be
sort of one level down from the workshops where, and mostly in the early adopters, the counties are organizing their districts in the county to have these ongoing discussions about how do you use the rubrics?
What does that mean?
What do we do with this new LCAP template?
So we approved those as well.
We also approved four pilot districts.
Turns out three districts in one county
who really want to get into the deeper work where they will be, the CCEE staff, will be working right alongside those districts to provide the technical assistance and support that they need, and that we'll be trying out that we will then have available in subsequent years.
The three districts are Sausalito, Marin City, Palo Verde, which is in Riverside County,
Woodland Unified, which is over here in Yolo County, and then the Kern County superintendent actually volunteered to be a pilot for all the districts within her county.
So lots of work going on with CCE right now.
Our next meeting is December 1st.
and we will be meeting in San Francisco at San Francisco Unified, and we're doing that in collaboration with the CSBA meeting.
And related to CCE work, and obviously the work I'm doing here, I'm on a panel at the AXA annual conference next week, and then at the CSBA annual conference in December.
Okay, uh, so we're obviously running ahead of schedule.
No, no, sorry.
One more.
I have two more.
These are, uh, you know, that one of the other elements that people weren't talking about yet, but they soon will be, uh, the elementary, every student succeed that added a requirement for state for leas to collect information about students who are military family members.
So that identifier has to be added.
That's something the legislature has been trying to work on adding to as an update to our CALPADS system.
Now it's become a requirement.
There is confusion about whether or not that is going to be a student subgroup.
No, it's not.
But that is a requirement.
I bring that up because the other liaison capacity requirement function that I have is I serve for this board on California State Council, the interstate compact for educational opportunity for military children.
We had a meeting yesterday.
here in this department.
Just a couple of things that are going on.
There is a new executive director now.
Her name is Sharice Imai, and her term began on June 1st.
She's replacing Kate Gavlock.
Kate Gavlock is a superintendent at Travis Unified School District, and Kate had been serving in that capacity up till then.
I'm sure she's very happy to give up that responsibility, but Kate has represented California and the commission very, very well.
The commission's work continues to be to look at all the issues that relate to all the states for students that come into our schools or transfer from our schools to schools in other states to make sure that they have an easy transition.
When I began this assignment, we had about 25 to 30 states, including California, that were part of the commission's work.
Now the interstate compact covers all 50 states, and all 50 states have a commission and have commissioners.
Our next meeting is in April, April 25th in San Diego, and we're being hosted by a local school district, but there will be members from both the military installations down there who will be part of the work that we'll be doing, and I'll come back to report that.
The second thing I also want to report to you is you may recall with the permission of the board president, I've been working with the Smarter Balanced Consortium to develop an online interface for a teacher guide concerning the Smarter Balanced assessments.
We've been having regular conference calls each Thursday just to work with the computer engineers and all those people who do the programming stuff to work out all the nuts and bolts for the online activities.
But the next big phase is they're actually convening a survey, a group of folks to participate in a survey to talk about what the logic model will be to look at what the end user interface will look like and how to build this idea about this online workbook.
for teachers.
And so again, I want to emphasize this is a model that Smarter Balanced intends to scale up for all the consortium states to have access to, but they have contracted in a very large way with a number of design team members on the design team in multiple states to put together this idea of this online workbook based on feedback they received from California teachers.
So the project
They hope to bring it to scale and implement it at some point this spring.
They have initiated a very aggressive and I would say very, very impressive group of folks to put this together.
So it's very exciting work.
Okay, thank you for those additions and one more, yeah.
Okay, so the Child Nutrition Advisory Board had two vacancies, one for teacher, one for curriculum coordinator, and today they were appointed, so then now they have a full board.
They have been very proactive in trying to make sure that they have a good understanding of the nutrition and fitness standards, and for that reason, they invited the CDE to present on the health framework.
I will be attending the meeting on November 29th in Long Beach Unified around the health framework.
And one of the things that I want to make sure that I voice is the mental health piece that students brought up today.
I think that's, I'm not sure if that's already part of the standards, but I think that's critical for us to discuss.
They also presented on the September 12th meeting the newly revised CDE Nutrition Education Resource Guide, and that's really aimed at bringing some effective practices around fitness and nutrition, K-12, to the schools.
So that's CNAC.
I will also be part of the EL Blueprint workgroup that's meeting next week, November 10th, here in Sacramento.
So I want to thank the department for that invitation.
And let's see, there was one more thing.
Can't remember, so I guess it wasn't all that important.
Thanks.
Okay, no more reports.
We can take up today, since we have time, the regular proposed consent calendar.
That's our items 11 through 17.
So I can... So move.
Is there a second?
Is there public comment?
No.
Okay.
All those in favor of regular public consent?
All right.
And finally, do we have anybody who wants to address the board under general public comment on items that are not part of our agenda?
And we'll also do that tomorrow as well.
No, we cannot do waiver consent.
I have an observation.
Okay, you have an observation.
Fantastic levels of involvement you all have and various committees you're representing.
I see you all over the state and various conferences.
I don't know, sometimes I think you clone yourselves, but you're doing great, great work there.
The observation is that
You said we were running ahead of schedule, and I want to say I think that's due to the really hard work, great teamwork between your staff and CDE staff.
I know Dave working with, you know, Jeff, Cindy, Barbara working on sort of big chunks of work, complicated the evaluation rubrics today, the LCAP.
the ESSA planning, and again, it's great teamwork.
All the workshops, all the meetings, convening of stakeholders, involving practitioners, resulted in no overflow crowds, but really great reports and great momentum.
So I just wanted to commend the staff, your staff, all of them involved, Jeff, Cindy, and Barbara, who sort of led the three major efforts today for CDE.
I was remiss in my STEM report in not mentioning CDE's STEM conference last month, and I apologize.
I was there.
I did a presentation where I hosted, organized and hosted, moderated a presentation.
I don't have a computer science background, so I don't do the computer science part of it.
But we had Alice Steinglass from Code.org, she's vice president of engineering, and three educators who are implementing computer science in their schools.
And we had a large room, it was completely full, there were lots of questions.
CDE does a wonderful job with this STEM conference, it's been a real hit, superintendent, and it was really packed.
and the CDE staff were really supportive of me pulling this together and getting it organized.
It made it very smooth.
I really enjoyed it, so thank you.
And we have one speaker for public comment when you're ready.
First, Board Member Sisson.
I just wanted to generally say thank you to the board for listening so intently to the speeches that we heard this morning from the CAS conference.
I worked really hard and all of the delegates worked extremely, extremely, extremely hard to create these proposals that we're so excited that they're considering implementing.
So just on behalf of the students and the delegates and myself, I want to thank you guys for your attention to those matters.
After hearing if some of it was done at 2.30 a.m., I'm even more impressed, particularly at my age.
Sorry, Doug, one related comment.
So Olivia's birthday was on Monday.
She turned 18 and was here working with students, so I just want to thank you for your dedication and working through your work, your birthday, and happy birthday.
We're so glad we have a new voter.
Thank you.
Okay, Bob, comment?
Hi, I'm Doug McCray, retired testing.
I just want to mention I submitted a handout on your general public comment.
It's the latest version of the 2016 consortia state by state comparisons document that I've been doing the last couple of months.
All the state results from 2016 are in except for New Hampshire, but that's in your electronic folder if anybody's interested.
Okay, well, the board will recess till tomorrow.